TO ARE APRIL TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NATURAL RESOURCES
HEARING A. FEW QUICK.
ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE WE. GET
STARTED WITH OUR FULL.
SCHEDULE OF.
BILL HEARINGS.
AND FIRST OF ALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS
HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO FOR TODAY
TO FILL THE VACANCY ON THE
COMMITTEE.
TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED.
FROM TODAY'S HEARING THAT IS.
.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY NINE BY
MISTER FONG.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE.
BY MISTER PATTERSON.
ITEM TWENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER LEVINE.
AND ITEM THIRTY ONE A. B.
THROUGH THIRTY TWENTY. BY MISTER
FLORA.
SO THOSE ITEMS.
HAVE BEEN PULLED.
BY THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE BEING
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
THEY ARE ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY BY MISTER
QUIRK.
ITEM TWELVE.%
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR BY
MISTER BLOOM.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY TWO BY MISTER PATTERSON.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT BY MISTER CHAN.
AND ITEM TWENTY NINE A. B.
THIRTY TWELVE BY MISTER
GALLAGHER.
AND.
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY SEVEN.
COMMITTEE BILL.
OF.
NATURAL RESOURCES.
SO AS SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
WILL BE.
YEAH OF A QUORUM. NOT NOT QUITE
YET OKAY.
WE WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ABOUT FOUR.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN NEITHER MR
MCCARTY IS SET FOR PURPOSES OF
ADOPTING AN URGENCY CLASS ONLY.
OF THE BILL WILL BE HEARD ON MAY
SEVENTH.
AND THAT LEAVES A FULL SCHEDULE
OF TWENTY EIGHT BILLS HERE FOR
TODAY. AND TO START A SERVE OUR.
OFFICE IS A.
AT SEA AND WE HAVE MISTER
CALDERON.
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR
.
PREPARE. MEMBERS.
I.
POLITICAL CALL A LONG TIME TO
DISCUSS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
.
SO.
REALLY HEROES SIMPLE THIS BILL
IS ABOUT DRAWS UPON.
SO WHEN WE VOTED AND DINING
RESTAURANTS.
YOU WANT A STRONG YOU CAN HAVE A
STRONG GAVE YOU JUST HAVE TO ASK
EQUIPMENT BUT IT'S.
FULL SERVICE DINING BUT.
ESSENTIALLY NEEDS WHERE YOU'RE
BEING STAR.
BUY A. CAR OR A WAITRESS
AND SO.
THAT'S THE ONLY IMPACT THAT
THIS BILL HAS IT DOESN'T BAN
ANYTHING DOESN'T GET RID OF
ANYTHING DOESN'T TELL ANYBODY
THEY CAN'T HAVE SOMETHING IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY BUSINESS OR
ANY OTHER ENTITY. TO CARRY
ANYTHING.
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO CARRY
IT JUST STRASBOURG REQUEST YOU
GO INTO A DINING RESTAURANT YOU
WANNA STRAW YOU CAN HAVE A
STRIKE YOU JUST HAVE TO REQUEST
IT. ON THE REASON WHY I'M DOING
THIS BILL.IS BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
ENDING UP IN OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR OCEAN OUR WATERWAYS AND.
OUR LANDFILLS ARE YOU KNOW TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION ARE FOUND THAT.
PLASTIC STRAWS WITH THE SIX MOST
PREVALENT ITEM AND SANCTION
BEACH CLEANUPS THAT WERE FOUND
ON CALIFORNIA BEACHES AS THESE
PLASTICS GET INTO THE OCEAN THEY
BREAK DOWN INTO MICRO PLASTICS.
WHICH ACTUALLY ACT AS A SPONGE
AND ATTRACT TOXINS
TOXINS THAT ARE THEN INGESTED BY
FISH BECAUSE FISH THINK THEIR
FOOD ODD THESE PLASTICS CAN EVEN
BECOME SO FINE THAT THEY BECOME
A MICRO PLASTIC EXCUSE ME A NANO
PLASTIC.
I STILL FIND THAT YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE THE FISH DOES NOT EVEN HAVE
TO PHYSICALLY INGEST THE.
ARE THE PLASTIC THAT IT GOES
IT'S ALL FINALLY JUST GOES
DIRECTLY THROUGH THE SKIN THE
FISH DIRECTLY INTO THE CELLS AND
THEN WE IN TURN IT AT THE. THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THE WORLD GETS
THERE.
THEIR THEIR THEIR FOOD FROM THE
OCEAN AND SO WE WE WE COULD BE
POTENTIALLY POISONING OURSELVES
AYE AND IT CAN'T BE OVERSTATED
THAT. OUR RESEARCHERS I SAY THAT
BY THE YEAR TWENTY FIFTY.
THERE COULD BE OR THERE WILL BE
MORE PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN THEN
THERE ARE FISH.
I AND SO THESE ARE REAL ISSUES A
LOT OF CITIES HAVE TAKEN OUR
STEPS ARE TO REDUCE SINGLE USE
PLASTICS YOU HAVE SOME CITIES
ACT IF FOR EXAMPLE DAVIS
APPEARED SACRAMENTO THAT.
ALREADY HAS A STRAW THE PLAN
REQUEST POLICIES FOR THEIR
DINING RESTAURANTS.
THE CITY OF MALIBU BANNED ALL
SINGLE USE PLASTICS VERY
RECENTLY SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S CATCHING ON AND THIS IS A
VERY REASONABLE MEASURE AYE IT'S
MEANT IN INTENDED TO BE A
REASONABLE MEASURE TO HELP. CUT
DOWN ON THE CONSUMPTION OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC DOESN'T BAN
ANYTHING DOESN'T TELL ANYBODY
THEY CAN DO ANYTHING JUST AS IF
YOU WANT TO THROW YOU CAN HAVE
IT. YOU JUST HAVE TO REQUEST IT
AT A DINING RESTAURANT.
THAT'S IT THAT'S ALL THE BILL
DOES ON I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WE MOVE ALONG BUT
WITH ME. ARE IN SUPPORT ARE TO
TESTIFY IS KELLY MAY BE
REPRESENTING OUR THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AS
WELL SHELBY O'NEILL WHO IS THE
FOUNDER OF JUNE AN OCEAN. JUNIOR
OCEAN GUARDIAN I THINK YOU
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
WE HAVE A FORUM NOW AND SO I
LIKE TO TAKE PRO.
MEMBERS WENT THROUGH CHIEF THERE
MURATSUCHI HERE ACOSTA. HERE
ACOSTA HERE CHAU. EGGMAN EGGMAN
HERE FLORA. THERE FLORA HERE
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ MULLIN IS
FURIOUS STONE.
RIGHT.
HAVING GO QUORUM I'D LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SECOND.
RIGHT.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS
MATTEUCCI AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE CHAU
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LARA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE BRAOSE.
STONE.
SIX ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU SHARON MEMBERS.
TELLING ME TO BE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP.
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AYE
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AS IT IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
RIGHT.
CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
A PLASTIC STRAW.
AND MAKING THE SURF TO A
STATEWIDE PLASTIC STRAWS UPON
REQUEST POLICY AT THIS MEASURE
WILL BEGIN TO REDUCE THE
NATIONAL BENCHMARK.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION PLASTIC
STRAWS USED EVERYDAY ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES EQUIVALENT OF ONE
POINT SIX DRAWS PER PERSON PER
DAY. AND THE RESTAURANTS A BIT
OF OVERHEAD IN THE PROCESS.
HOWEVER THE OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
BILL EXTENDS FAR BEYOND THE
REDUCTION THAT IT WILL MAKE TO
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL WE STREAM.
AS THE SIMPLE PROCESS OF ASKING
CUSTOMERS WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT A STRAW WILL SERVE AS THE
CATALYST TO GET PEOPLE THINKING
ABOUT THEIR OVERALL PLASTIC
CONSUMPTION.
GETTING PEOPLE TO ASK THE
QUESTION DO WE REALLY NEED THIS.
NOT A TIME WHEN A GLOBE IS
FACING A PLASTIC POLLUTION
CRISIS ASKING A SIMPLE QUESTION
AND DEMANDING MORE SUSTAINABLE
PLASTIC PRODUCTION AND USE WILL
SUPPORT SOURCE REDUCTION WHICH
WE KNOW IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEANS. OF TACKLING PLASTIC
POLLUTION.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
MENTIONED IF WE DO NOT BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS WE WILL SEE
MORE FISH THAN PLASTIC ARE MORE
PLASTIC THAN FISH IN THE OCEAN
BY TWENTY. FIFTY AYE AND IN JUST
SEVEN YEARS THAT SAME STUDY
PREDICTS DIED PLASTIC WILL
OUTWEIGH FETISH I'VE THREE TO
ONE BY.
I JUST THE NEXT SEVEN YEARS.
I KNOW ADDITIONALLY PLASTIC
POLLUTES OUR ENVIRONMENT THROUGH
ITS ENTIRE LIFECYCLE NOTCHES
DISPOSAL BUT FROM EXTRACTION AND
PRODUCTION. AS VIRTUALLY ALL
PLASTICS ARE PRODUCED FROM
CHEMICAL SOURCED FROM FOSSIL
FUELS MEANING THAT A FAILURE TO
REDUCE OUR PLASTIC PRODUCTION
AND CONSUMPTION WOULD BE IN
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
CALIFORNIANS LANDMARK GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTION. GOALS.
A CLOSE BY MENTIONING THAT
YESTERDAY'S A GLOBAL EARTH DAY
THEME WAS ENDING CLASSIC
POLLUTION.
BUT TO ACHIEVE THIS CHALLENGE WE
WILL NEED SIGNIFICANT POLICIES
BEYOND JUST.
STRAW'S UPON REQUEST HOWEVER ON
THE HEELS OF EARTH DAY AT THIS
BILL WOULD TAKE A CRITICAL FIRST
STEP IN EDUCATING CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT THE PLASTIC POLLUTION
CRISIS AND SIMULTANEOUSLY YOU
PROVIDE THEM WITH OPPORTUNITIES.
TO BE EMPOWERED BY THEIR DAILY
ABILITY TO REDUCE CONSUMPTION OF
SINGLE USE PLASTICS WEBSPHERE I
DON'T THINK IT.
THANK YOU.
CHAU MANUAL JUNIOR XIN GUARDIANS
I THINK YOU CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN
MERIT MURATSUCHI MEMBERS OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR TODAY.
MY NAME IS CHAU BOLOGNA I'M A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD JING AT SAM
IN A HIGH SCORING HOLLISTER.
I LEARNED ABOUT THE PROBLEM THE
PROSECUTION POSES TAR OCEAN AS A
BONTA TEAM CONSERVATION LEADER
AT THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM.
AND DECIDED TO TAKE ACTION FROM
ACROSS GOBBLED WHAT PROJECT.
I FOUNDED YOUR NOTION GUARDIANS
AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT THE
PROBLEM OF PLASTIC POLLUTION AND
OTHER EFFORTS CAN HELP AND HURT
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THROUGH GENERATION GUARDIANS I
LAUNCH KNOWSHON NOVEMBER A
MOVEMENT TO IMPART KIDS TO MAKE
ONE SMALL CHANGE BY REFUSING
SINGLE USE PLASTIC STRAWS DURING
THE MONTH OF NOVEMBER. WHAT A
HUGE IMPACT THE SMALL CHANGES
HAVING HONOR OCEANS WATERWAYS
AND PLANET? NO SHOW NOVEMBER NOT
ONLY HAS PARTICIPANTS IN ALL
FIFTY STATES BUT ALSO IN CANADA
THE UK SCOTLAND FRANCE ITALY
IRELAND AUSTRALIA SPAIN JAPAN
HONG KONG TAIWAN KOREA. INDIA
THE GRAND CAYMAN ISLANDS ISRAEL
AND IRAN. GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESSES ARE STARTING TO
NOTICE. AN OCTOBER AGAIN
UNANIMOUS APPROVAL FROM FOR MY
NO CHAU NOVEMBER RESOLUTION BY
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. AND SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MONNING WILL SOON
INTRODUCE A SIMILAR RESOLUTION.
BUSINESSES LIKE DIGNITY HEALTH
FARMER BROTHERS MP GINNY HAVE
ELIMINATED STRAWS FROM THEIR
OPERATIONS WHICH AMOUNT TO MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION SHOTS PER
YEAR.
DELTA AIRLINES HAS ALSO FOUND A
SOLUTION TO REPLACE A PLASTIC
STIRS STICKS.
REQUIRING STRAWS UPON REQUEST ME
LINE THE FINANCIAL LOAD FOR THE
LOCAL MOM AND POP RESTAURANTS
THEY NEED EVERY DOLLAR TO KEEP
THEIR BUSINESSES AFLOAT. BY
REDUCING THE NUMBERS OF STRAWS A
PURCHASE.
PEOPLE ARE WAKING UP TO THE
REALITY THAT POSSE POLLUTION
FRIENDS ARE OCEAN AND OUR HOUSE.
THIS YEAR TO DATE WHAT AT THIS
THIS YEAR EARTH DAY WAS
DEDICATED TO ENDING CLASSIC
POLLUTION. YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
BE CHANGE MAKERS AND APPROVE
EIGHTEEN A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. TO NOT ONLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
BELOVED OCEAN COAST AND
WATERWAYS BUT ALSO TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE SO WHAT IMPACT OUR
PLAN. THANK YOU AGAIN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME AND
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. OF
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR TO OFFER SHOWS ONLY UPON
REQUEST.
I URGE EVE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
COMMON SENSE LEGISLATION BUT
GIVEN MY RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
THEY ARE AT NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY.
HI MY NAME IS ARE YOU JACKSON
AND I'M HERE IN STE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL AND ALSO
TO SHOW THAT THERE IS STRONG
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR IT. AND THE
VIDEO PRODUCER IT BY SPEED AND I
MADE A VIDEO ABOUT WHY STRAWS
ARE HARMFUL TO OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THIS VIDEO IS VIEWED ON FACEBOOK
TWENTY MILLION TIMES AND I GOT A
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
SHARES THE TOP AUDIENCE FOR THIS
VIDEO WAS CALIFORNIANS.
THAT OUR AGES AYE TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY FOUR WHICH
SHOWS THAT. AS CALIFORNIANS
REALLY DO CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT SO I'M SAYING THAT
THE PUBLIC. IS VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL AND I URGE YOU
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR
OCEANS AND ARE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND THANK
THE AUTHOR.
ANGELA HOW BEHALF SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THERESA BURKE* ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAYS ZERO WASTE USA
UPSTREAM POLICY AND PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON ON BEHALF OF
THE FIVE TEARS INSTITUTE SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISORS WHICH TOYO
CHUMASH FOUNDATION.
AND CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT AND OF LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
TO MAKE THE BILL STRUCTURE
THINK.
JUST MULLINBIT ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KYLE JUST HEAR CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK.
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
WE COME ASTRONAUT WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SERVER O. DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AMY WILL FROM FROM THE MONTEREY
BAY AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH THEIR
AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
P. MONTGOMERY FOR SEA WORLD IN
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE CITY
EVEN SENATORS IN SUPPORT.
PAUL YOU'RE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SPORT.
ZERO CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION BE TAKING A VOTE ON
THIS BILL NEXT WEEK IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS FOR SUPPORT.
CHUCKLE GOOD WITH THE PUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE NOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SURE ANYONE HERE.
TWO US FIND OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE OF QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY MS EGGMAN
AS OUR SECOND.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CALDERON FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP I
THINK I KNOW AS A SURFER YOU
LOVE THE OCEAN AND.
THIS IS A TIMELY BILL THE DAY
AFTER EARTH DAY ENDING CLASS
POLLUTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
OF.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING ITSELF.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AT AS THE CHAIRMAN SAID I HAVE
SERVED MY ENTIRE LIFE IT'S
NEVER.
STOP FRUSTRATING ME TO SEE ANY
TYPE OF PLASTIC VOTE FLOW BY ME
IN THE OCEAN UNDERSTANDING HOW
DEVASTATING IT IS SAID THAT
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE AT
LEAST TO DO A LITTLE BIT TO TAKE
A STEP FORWARD TO RAISE
AWARENESS OUGHT TO DO SOMETHING
IN THIS BILL THAT ACTUALLY MAKES
A DIFFERENCE BUT THEN ALSO RAISE
AWARENESS BEYOND. AYE IT'S SO
FUNNY ARE BECAUSE I GET TEXT NOT
MESSAGES ALL THE TIME NOW IS AS
FRIENDS AND FAMILY GOING TO
RESTAURANTS ALL OVER THE STATE.
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE NOW UP
ON THEIR OWN?
WHAT STATE LAW SAYING WE CAN'T
HAVE STRAWS AND SO WE'RE NO
LONGER DOING IT OR WE'VE WE'VE
DECIDED ON AROUND TO ENACT A
STATE US DRAWS UPON? REQUEST
POLICY ON AROUND AND SO NO
MATTER WHAT THE IDEA OF WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IN THIS BILL IS
CATCHING FIRE IT IS. MOTIVATING
A LOT OF PEOPLE TO DO THEIR PART
AND. WE GET WE ARE STE.
WE LOVE OUR CONVENIENCES AS
AMERICANS
UNTIL WE LEARNED THAT WE THERE
IS SOME TYPE OF DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT. OF THOSE CONVENIENCES
ARE AND THERE'S CLEARLY ONE HERE
AND YOU KNOW IF PEOPLE ARE AWARE
WHICH THIS BILL DOES BRING
AWARENESS IF THEY'RE AWARE OF
THE IMPACT THESE SINGLE USE
PLASTICS ON OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THEN IT COULD CHANGE BEHAVIOR
AND THEN THOUGHTS YOU KNOW DOING
A LOT OF GREAT THINGS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO DOING A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS FOR US AS. A
PEOPLE SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MISTER CALDERON BEFORE
WE PROCEED WITH THE VOWED TO.
YOU DID OFFER AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
AND SO I ASSUME THAT YOU ARE
ABLE TO ACCEPT IN AS MANY.
YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION OF THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS REPUBLIC.
ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY MEMBER CALDERON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED ARE
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MURATSUCHI HI
ROUTE TO GI ACOSTA. NO ACOSTA NO
CHAO CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
MULLIN DOES KNOW VARIOUS.
SO.
STONE I.
FIVE THREE.
OKAY WE'RE SHORT ONE VOTE OF
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EVERY.
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER LEVINE
PRESENTING PRESENTING ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
AND I SHOULD HAVE A SAID THIS
FROM THE GET GO BUT.
GOT THREE MAIN WITNESSES FOR
EACH SIDE TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
.
YES THANK YOU MISTER LIVING I
WANT TO KEEP YOUR TWENTY EIGHT
BILL AGENDA RUNNING AS QUICKLY
AND SMOOTHLY AS POSSIBLE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT. AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
SIX THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
AIR BE TO ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN
AN INVENTORY. OF EMISSIONS OF
GHGS ON CONSUMPTION BASED
ACCOUNTING BASIS THIS
CONSUMPTION BASED INVENTORY
WOULD NOT APPLY TO THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
PURSUANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
GLOBAL WARMING. SOLUTIONS ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SIX IT INSTEAD
WOULD BE USED AS A TOOL TO
BETTER ASSESS HOW WELL THE
STATUS REDUCING ITS OVERALL
CONTRIBUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND KEEP WITH THE STATE'SEFFORT
TO MINIMIZE GHG EMISSIONS
LEAKAGE REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S
IMPACT ON CLIMATE CHANGE GOES
BEYOND REDUCING EMISSIONS JUST
INSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT HAS
DEVELOPED THE CONSUMPTION BASED
CHEECH DE EMISSIONS INVENTORY
NOTING THAT IT PROVIDES. A MORE
COMPLETE ANALYSIS OF HOW THE
REGION CONTRIBUTES TO GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH ME TODAY. TO
TALK ABOUT THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S
CONSUMPTION INVENTORY IS THE
DISTRICTS GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR MISTER THOMASON THANK
YOU.
THOUGHT GOOD AFTERNOON CHEERING
MEMBERS TOM EDISON WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT.
OUR BOARD IS NOT YET HAVE A
POSITION I HAD HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE'RE
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT POSITION
AYE ESTATE OUT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHEN WE WERE ADOPTING OUR CLEAN
AIR PLAN A LOOKING AT BOTH
CRITERIA TOXIC SYNCLINE THAT.
WE INCLUDED A CONSUMPTION BASED
EMISSIONS INVENTORY.
AND WE THOUGHT THAT WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FOR THE REGION
WE ALSO THINK IT MAKES SENSE FOR
THE STATE.
HI IT'S NOT AS THE ANALYSIS
NOTES NECESSARILY AN EASY THING
TO DO WHEN THEY'RE CERTAINLY OR.
ASSUMPTIONS THAT YOU HAVE TO
MAKE AND YOU HAVE TO DO SOME
APPROXIMATION BUT NEVERTHELESS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE BIG
PICTURE ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IS A
STATE IN TERMS OF D. H. T.'S WE
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO GO. THUS WERE A SUPPORTIVE OF
OF THE MEASURE AND ENCOURAGING
HER SUPPORT FOR IT. WE WORKED
WITH UC BERKELEY.
TO HELP US IN THAT. ANALYSIS AND
QUANTIFICATION.
WE NOTE THAT THE ANALYSIS
INCLUDES
ARE SOME SUGGESTIONS ABOUT WHO
MIGHT BE PASSED ON.
WHAT WHAT ORT OF AN ENTITY
MIGHT BE PASSED AWAY THE WORK ON
THAT THAT ALL MAKES SENSE TO US?
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANNE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
KELSEY CA.
WALL WE'D WE DID PUT IN A LOT
OF OPPOSITION AND WE WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
WHICH WE APPRECIATE ON.
ON ON THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
IRONING OUT MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S NO DUPLICATIVE PROCESS
TO THE CURRENCY  SEE
EMISSIONS REPORTING PROCESS AND.
ARE MAKING SURE THAT A LINE SO
THAT ARE THERE ARE THERE'S
MARKET CERTAINTY IN SIGNING
CONTRACTS AND TURNED TO
CONTRACTS FOR MISSION PURPOSES
SO.
THAK YOU.
YOU.
ANYA FOR THE WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MOTIONS AND MADE THINGS OR
SECOND.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER LEVINE WHICH
ELECT CLOTHES ARE SEPARATE FOR
NIVEAU.
YOU.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION IS.
I.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE FILL THE
ROOM.
I AM NINETEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY MEMBER LEVINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTE TO GI
ACOSTA. NO ACOSTA NO CHILD CHAU
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON. MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES NO
RAYOS.
STONE.
STONE I.
FIVE THREE FIVE THREE THE BILL
IS ON CALL. THINK VERY MUCH AS
CHAIR MEMBERS
YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE.
MISTER CHU AND.
MISTER GRAYSON.
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE.
I THINK IT IS A CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE IT'S
A BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT SYSTEM TO
ESTABLISH TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT ZONING STANDARDS.
THAT SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT ONLY ON PARK ONLY
AND WITHIN A HALF MILE FROM THE
STATION.
WHY DO WE NEED THIS ARE ARE BAY
AREA SUFFERING FROM TOO INTENSE
CRISES THAT SEVERELY IMPACTS ARE
BARNETT?
HOUSING CRISIS AND A CONGESTION
CRISIS.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF HOUSING
COUNTLESS RESIDENTS SPEND HOURS
IN GRIDLOCK DRIVING BETWEEN
THEIR WORK AND WHERE THEY CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE.
LAST YEAR AVERAGING.
SEVENTY NINE HOUR SITTING IN
GRIDLOCK ON TOP OF AWFUL
COMMUTES THAT ARE RELEASING
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES.
UNFORTUNATE TODAY MANY BART
STATIONS ARE SURROUNDED BY ACRES
OF ASPHALT PARKING LOTS FILLED
WITH CARS BY DAY. AND VACANT AND
EMPTY LOTS BY NIGHT.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE PART
HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE FOR FORTY
FIVE YEARS BUT NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE DEVELOPER PARCELS
ARE STILL PARKING LOTS.
TOO MANY CITIES HAVE NOT BUILT
ANY STE ANY HOUSING NEXT TO A
STATION AND THE ONLY ONES THAT
DID. WATER DOWN PROJECTS AND
OFTEN TOOK TEN TO TWENTY YEARS
FOR APPROVAL.
THIS IS A NARROWLY TAILORED TO
THE BILL.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO BARK ON LAND
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY OR SO
ACRES THAT ARE NOW NINETY FIVE
PERCENT PARKING LOT.
INTERESTINGLY PARK COULD TODAY
BILL TRANSIT FACILITIES WITHOUT
ANY ADDITIONAL APPROVALS BUT
CANNOT BUILD OR PERMIT MIXED USE
HOUSING. UP OR SIMILAR
DEVELOPMENT.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO THOSE PARTS
STATIONS IN AREAS DIRECTLY
REPRESENTED ON THE ELECTED PART
BOARD. THAT WOULD CREATE DIRECT
POLITICAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THUS IS REALLY A DISTRICT BILL
FOR MY CITY A CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO MISTER GRAYSON'S
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND OUR
COLLEAGUES IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE PARK
BOARD TO ESTABLISH BROUGHT TO
DIS OWNING STANDARDS WITH TWENTY
PERCENT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY. A
CITY WOULD HAVE TWO YEARS TO
UPDATE THEIR MORE SPECIFIC SUNNY
WITHIN BROADER GUIDELINE.
BART WOULD BE OBLIGED TO
INCORPORATE LOCAL DESIGN
GUIDELINES IN DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENTS WITH RTO DE
DEVELOPERS.
CITIES THAT MEET MARKET RATE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OBLIGATIONS
UNDER ARENA WOULD BE EXEMPTED
OUR AND WITH THAT THE
STIMULATIVE OVER TO MY JOINT
AUTHORS MR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU AND CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU TODAY OF RELYING TO
PRESENT. THE I AM HERE TO GIVE
NOT ONLY JUST.
AN ANTIDOTE OF OF THE WAY BART
AND THE CITY'S WORK TOGETHER BUT
ALSO MENTIONED IN THE MIDST OF A
HOUSING CRISIS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
TAKE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY UNIQUE
SUCH AS WHAT WE FIND WITH BART
AND BARK OWNED PROPERTY.
IN THE MIST OF CITIES IN A
THREE COUNTY AREA WHERE IT WHERE
EVERY AREA THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
WOULD BE REPRESENTED BY AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL WHERE FOLKS
CONSTITUENTS STILL HAVE. PLENTY
OF OUR ABILITY TO HAVE INPUT AS
WELL AS TO HAVE REPRESENTATION
BY VOICE ON A BOARD THAT IS
p JUST FOR INFORMATION I THINK
IT'S WORTHY TO NOTE.
THAT THE LARGEST CITY IN MY
DISTRICT.
THAT OF THIS WHAT IMPACT.
ONLY INCREASED A NET INCREASE OF
A HUNDRED AND NINE LIVING UNITS
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
AND IN THE MIDST OF A HOUSING
CRISIS THIS IS NOT MEETING THE
NEED.
AND SO WE WONDER WHY OUR HOUSING
IS GOING UP AS HIGH AS IT IS
WHEN WE HAVE CITIES THAT ARE
ONLY PRODUCING A NET INCREASE
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES HOUSING ESTIMATES.
ALONG WITH THAT OF THE CONCERN
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED THAT OF BART
WOULD NOT WORK OR WOULD HAVE
STRAINED RELATIONS WITH LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AND AGENCIES. IN
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS I'M HERE
TO ATTEST THAT WHEN I SERVED AS
MAYOR OF VIA OF CONCORD.
THAT BART WAS PROPOSING
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECT FOR
THE DOWNTOWN BART STATION.
AND.
I WILL TELL YOU WHEN THEY CAME
IN AT SUBMITTED THEIR PLANS TO
THE CITY FOR REVIEW. THE CITY
HAD QUITE EXTENSIVE.
OPINIONS AND ALSO ALTERATIONS
AND IN ALMOST EVERY SINGLE CASE
EVEN DOWN TO THE LIGHT STANDARDS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE USED BART
CONCEDED AND WENT ALONG WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE CITY SO.
THERE IS HISTORICAL PRECEDENT
FOR BART WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH CITIES
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF BOTH PARTIES.
THAT.
THANK YOU WANNA TURN IT OVER TO
WHAT ONE OF OUR SPONSORS FROM
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
BUT ALSO MENTION.
THERE IS A MEMBER FROM THE PARK
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MISTER NICK
JUST SIPOWICZ WHO'S HERE IN CASE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE ARE WITH SPECIFIC
TECHNICAL UNSPECIFIC TECHNICAL
ISSUES.
MICHAEL AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE BEAR WERE
LACKING GO FOR MORE THAN TEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER ACRE.
PUBLICLY HEALTH PLANS A VALUABLE
AND PRECIOUS RESOURCE.
GIVEN THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED PLAN TO BE INVEST IN
THE BART SYSTEM THIS LAND MUST
BE USED WISELY AND PROVIDE REAL
COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
PRIOR TO THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ADOPTION OF PARTS TOT GUIDELINES
THERE WAS A MORE THAN TO YOUR
PUBLIC PROCESS IN WHICH MANY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING MINE
PARTICIPATED. AND THE SMART AND
PROGRESSIVE THE GUIDELINES FOR
VERY WELL KNOWN AND ADMIRED.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICY
INCLUDED IS EXCELLENT AND WE
NEED THE COOPERATION OF IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS NOW FOR EXPEDITED
IMPLEMENTATION. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ARE FEASIBLE WITH
THE APPROPRIATE DENSITY AND
DESIGN STANDARDS.
THESE POLICIES ARE ALREADY
EMBEDDED IN KEY STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
WHICH IS AS FUNNY WITH CAP AND
TRADE RESOURCES. AS WELL AS THE
THE CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE PROGRAM.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN PH STAND
RIGHT TO DELIVER TRANSIT OR AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON BART SITES
BUT WE NEED THE ZONING DENSITY
AND DESIGN STANDARDS TO BE A
LINES AND WE URGE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHILE ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
MISTER JUST JUST
JUST SIMPLE WHAT SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO US A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S DIRECTOR NICK TO SURF
WITH SOME VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BART BOARD LIKE ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE BART BOARD. I
AM DIRECTLY ELECTED BY THE
RESIDENTS OF MY PARK DISTRICT.
I'M WHICH IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
RANGE BEEN FOR RAIL TRANSIT
AGENCY IN RELEVANT FOR THE
CHANGES PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
BOUGHT HAS ADOPTED A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE BONTA SO LONG
STANDING.
POLICY AND PRACTICE OF CLOSE
COOPERATION WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY. PARTNERS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE THIS GENUINE COMPLETE
COLLABORATION WEATHER AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY THREE
BECOMES LAW OR NOT. I'M A
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
JURISDICTIONS IS ESSENTIAL TO
RUNNING AN EFFICIENT MASS
TRANSIT.
INTAKE MENU TRIPLE POSITION
HOWEVER PART OF KNOWLEDGE IS
THAT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
WOULD PLAY A. VITAL ROLE IN
ACHIEVING BOX GOALS REGIONAL
GOALS AND IN MOST CASES THE
GOALS OF THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
WHICH ABOUT SERBS BOUGHT OWNS
ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ACRES
OF DEVELOPED BILL PROPERTY. AND
WILL NEED TO DEVELOP NEARLY ALL
OF IT TO MEET OUR TARGET OF
TWENTY THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS
SEVEN THOUSAND OF WHICH WOULD BE
AFFORDABLE. AND FOR THE HALF
MILLION SQUARE FEET OF
COMMERCIAL SPACE.
AB HISTORICAL RATE OF
DEVELOPMENT THIS WILL TAKE NOT
YEARS. NOT DECADES
BUT GENERATIONS.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL.
SO VITAL.
I'M THIS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE BILL'S
ALSO THOSE FOR BEING EXTREMELY
RESPONSIVE TO BAR AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. I'M AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT WE KNOW
AND I REALIZE I SHOULD OPEN MY
STATEMENT BY SAYING.
I ACCEPT THAT SUGGESTED
COMMITMENTS.
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF ALL EUROPE
HAVE THE CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO'S FOR THE BILL.
SUCH SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
SO IT'S A MAD MAD WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS PART ABOUT
THINKING.
THEY MISTER CHAIR KEYSTONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THE BILL.
GEN A PRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW BIG
RECLINING CONSERVATION LEAGUE
PCO HAS NOT HAD A FORMAL
POSITION AS OF YET ON THIS BILL
BUT.
WE ARE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT WE ALSO ARE CONSIDERING
IN AND.
PORTING SEACM JUST AMENDMENTS
FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES CONCERNING
LONG TERM ANTI DISPLACEMENT
MEASURES BUT.
THE PROPONENTS OF IT WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH US AND PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND WE. ARE CONFIDENT
THAT THOSE ISSUES WILL BE
RESOLVED AND WE DO HOPE THAT
THIS MOVE FORWARD PAYING HIM.
CHAIRMAN RECESS IDEAS ABOUT HALF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL THE
CO SPONSORS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
XENA WHO THE BILL.
ALRIGHT.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS EGGMAN.
OTHER THINK I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON THIS KIND OF
INNOVATIVE IDEA O BE ABLE TO
MOVE SOME THINGS FORWARD. A AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS A LOT OF LOT OF
MY RESIDENTS WHO ARE COMMITTING
TO THE BAY AREA IT'S BEEN A LOT
OF TIME SITTING IN TRAFFIC. I
THINK THE MORE WE CAN CLEAR THAT
UP THE BETTER OFF THAT WE ALL
ARE.
I PROJECT.
MR MCCARTY THING AND I I SUPPORT
THIS ON YOU KNOW THE OFFICE IS
NOT HERE BUT BUT I WOULD THINK
THEY WOULD ARGUE THAT THIS IS
THEIR DISCRETION AND AND AND
LOCAL CONTROL.
IT ANYTHING ONE AT THAT WELL I
THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT THEY
WOULD CERTAINLY SAY THAT.
THE THE COUPLE OF ENTITIES THAT
HAVE. POSED AT THIS POINT THIS
ONLY APPLIES TO BART ONLY AND SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ACRES THAT CURRENTLY AT
THIS MOMENT ARE. PARKING LOTS
AND.
I EAT I JUST HEARD FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE SUGGESTION OF A
SOME CONCERNS AROUND
DISPLACEMENT. ARE YOU CAN'T
REALLY DISPLACEMENT OFF A
PARKING LOT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE
IDEA THAT IF WE PUT HOUSING ON
PARKING LOTS THAT MIGHT HAVE
DISPLACEMENT EFFECTS IN OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS AND CERTAINLY WE
CAN WE CAN ADDRESS THAT BUT ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE.
IN THIS A BILL IS A TWENTY
PERCENT AT LEAST OF WHATEVER'S
PROPOSED NEEDS TO BE AFFORDABLE
SO. ARESO I THINK FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT I KNOW CARES VERY MUCH
ABOUT.
CONGESTION OUT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO INCREASE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP SUSTAINABILITY
WALKABILITY REDUCE CAR USE
CONGESTION AND GREENHOUSE GASES
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS
A.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I.
CERTAINLY CAN APPRECIATE.
THE ISSUES THAT YOU ARE
EXPERIENCING.
IN YOUR DISTRICT WITH RESPECT
TO HOUSING I THINK WE'RE ALL
EXPERIENCING THAT DRUG
CALIFORNIA BUT MY CONCERN IS. IS
BESTOWING THIS TYPE OF.
POWER TO AN ELECTED.
MEMBERS.
.
THANK YOU FOR LET ME JUST ANSWER
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT UNELECTED MEMBERS
BART THE PARKS BOARD IS I
BELIEVE THE ONLY MAJOR TRANSIT
AGENCY INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
THAT IS ACTUALLY ELECTED. BY
CONSTITUENTS AND THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO THE OUT THOSE PARK
STATIONS WHERE THERE ARE
DIRECTLY ELECTED MEMBERS SO FOR
EXAMPLE TO COMPLETE.
CARVE OUT FOR ONLY THE AREAS.
THAT ARE REPRESENTED BY ELECTED
MEMBERS THAT'S RIGHT IN FACT
THERE ARE BUNCH SPORTS STATIONS
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO BUILD
HOUSING AROUND BUT BECAUSE AT
THIS MOMENT THERE'S NOT A
DIRECTLY ELECTED MEMBER IN THAT
AREA. WE CARVE THAT OUT BECAUSE
WE ANTICIPATED THIS POTENTIAL
ISSUE IF MIXTURE SEPARATES WHO
REPRESENT SANFRANCISCO.
SUPPORTS DEVELOPMENT AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS DON'T LIKE THAT
THEY CAN VOTE HIM OUT IN THE
NEXT ELECTION. AND AND THAT'S.
BOTH THE RESPECT MISTER JUST UP
WHICH THAT'S IN PART WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S AN
ALIGNMENT.
OKAY WELL THAT'S.
HELPFUL IT'S REALLY YOU IT'S
QUITE UNIQUE IT'S.
.
I LIKE AND I COMMEND YOU FOR
MAKING SURE THAT YOU'VE ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN.
I STILL.
YOU KNOW MENTION WAS MADE THAT
THERE WILL BE. TWENTY THOUSAND
UNITS BUILT SEVEN THOUSAND OF
WHICH WOULD BE AFFORDABLE.
WHICH IS.
NOT VERY HIGH NUMBER CONSIDERING
THE NUMBER OF UNITS HE WOULD
NEED AND THE BAY AREA TO SATISFY
THE NEED THAT EXISTS THERE.
.
THE WHEN I LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
THERE'S FOUR AND A OVER WHILE
FOUR AND HALF MILLION SQUARE
FEET OF COMMERCIAL.
THAT WILL BE GOING IN.
I WONDER WHERE EVERYONE'S GOING
TO PARK.
SO THERE'S NOTHING FROM A LAND
USE
I KIND OF I JUST I GUESS I IT
FEELS AS THOUGH THIS IS BEING
PRESENTED AS A WAY TO. SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
IN THE BAY AREA OR AT LEAST
MAKE A DENT IN IT AND I JUST.
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE
CASE I THINK THE POLICIES THAT
ARE PUT IN PLACE BY THIS
LEGISLATURE THE REASON FOR THE
HIGH COST OF HOUSING AND THE
HIGH COST OF LAND AND THE IT
INABILITY TO TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I DON'T
THINK TAKING THE PARKING LOTS
AWAY. FROM BART IS GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
.
BUT BONUS POINTS FOR BEING.
CREATIVE. AND HOW YOU'RE
APPROACHING THIS PROBLEM BUT I'M
FOR CHECK CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
BUT I AM A A DEFERRED TO THE
PARK DIRECTOR IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS BUT ALSO A FEW
THINGS WE WE ARE NOT CLAIMING
THAT THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE BAY AREA
BUT WE DO THINK. THAT TWENTY
THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING ON TOP
OF SURFACE PARKING LOTS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO
THAT'S THE FIRST THOUGHT THE
SECOND IS.
WE'RE NOT REMOVING PARKING
SO THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR HOUSING
A MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT TO GO UP
ON TOP OF A PARKING LOT BUT YOU
COULD BUILD A PARKING GARAGE YOU
CAN STILL. ALLOW FOR PARKING
ALTHOUGH OUR HOPE IS WITH TWENTY
THOUSAND UNITS THEY'RE BUILT
RIGHT ON TOP OF BART STATIONS
THAT THAT DOES AT LEAST
ELIMINATE THE DEMAND FOR
PARKING.
OF THE FOLKS WHO LIVE.
A WHO LIVE RIGHT THERE SO WE
COULD STILL ALLOW FOR PARKING I
ACTUALLY LOVE TO TURN IT OVER TO
MISTER JOSEPH WHAT'S BECAUSE I
KNOW THIS IS BEN AND. A
DISCUSSION THAT I JUST DO YOU
KNOW THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW WHO WANT HOME. IN YOUR AREA
BUT CAN'T FIND ONE OR CAN'T
AFFORD ONE.
PLAN EVER EXPECT YOU TO KNOW
THE EXACT NUMBER DISEASE.
I WITH MY I MEAN THAT'S WHAT YOU
THINK YOU THIRDS OF THE BAY AREA
IS STRUGGLING WITH OR ELSE
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
ABSOLUTELY AND I'M NOT I'M NOT
I'M NOT SO AGAIN I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THIS IS GOING TO
AND THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT I
THINK THIS IS. A VERY TAYLOR
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
POLICY THAT TAKES A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO DO THE KIND
OF TRANSITORY DEVELOPMENT THAT
WE WANT. AND AND THIS ONLY
ADDRESSES PART OWN LAND IF YOU
KNOW BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PROPOSALS OUT THERE THAT WOULD
IMPACT. A MORE LAND AROUND
TRANSIT STATIONS THAT IS NOT
THIS PROPOSAL THIS IS MEANT TO
BE.
CAREFULLY CARVED OUT PROPOSAL
AROUND PARTLY.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
MYTHS AND MIS EGGMAN THEN MR
ACOSTA.
AT NIGHT.
THEM.
CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT SO FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
LIVE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR
ANYWHERE AROUND THE BAY AREA.
.
I DON'T KNOW IF IF IF PEOPLE
REALIZED WIN IT TWENTY THOUSAND
UNITS OF HOUSING FREES UP A LOT
OF THINGS BECAUSE IF THERE'S NOT
ROOM FOR PEOPLE LIVE.
THEY THEN GO TO ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES
AND FOR SOMEONE WHO LIKE
REPREHENSIBLE PRESENT STOCKTON
THROUGH AB.
VERY DIFFICULT TIME WHEN BEFORE
EVERYBODY MOVED TO STOCKTON
UNTIL THE HOUSING PRICES
IT CRASHED WE WENT INTO
BANKRUPTCY A PART OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE THE INABILITY OF THE BAY
AREA TO BE ABLE TO CREATE ANY
KIND OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
SO PEOPLE CONTINUE TO MOVE OUT
INTO THE VALLEY AND THEN. AND
THEN CAME BACK.
BUT.
BUT
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE BAY AREA CREATES A HUGE.
CHAIN OF EVENTS THAT GOES ALL
THE WAY INTO THE VALLEY UP AND
DOWN AND INCREASES TO THEM.
RAISE UP OUR HOUSING COSTS AND
CREATE LESS PLACES FOR OUR FOLKS
TO BE ABLE LIVE WHO MAKE UP
OFTENTIMES OF THE. UP AND A LOT
LESS PEOPLE DO IN THE BAY AREA.
SO ANY KIND OF WAY THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE TO ADDRESS IS VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND I
UNDERSTAND IS MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIVE. IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR ANYWHERE
AROUND THE BAY AREA TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS OF
IT HAS WHEN THE BAY AREA DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT A RATE. OF THE PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD.
YOU'RE ENTIRELY RIGHT AND I'LL
SAY IT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THIS
THIS BILL IS AROUND IS THE
STATUS QUO ACCEPTABLE OF THESE
TWO OR FIFTY ACRES WHERE WE'RE
NOT BUILDING ANY HOUSING AND ARE
JUST SURFACE PARKING LOTS. OR
SHOULD WE BUILD SOMETHING ON TOP
OF THEM I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT IN A CAR IN A
TARGETED WAY. AYE AND THE STATUS
QUO DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BUT TO
YOUR POINT.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
HOUSING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING IN THE HIGH COST CENTERS
OF THE CITIES IN THE BAY WERE
DRIVING TWO THREE FOUR HOURS A
DAY COMMUTING FROM YOUR PART OF
THE STATE. UP WHO ARE OUR
TEACHERS ARE CHILDCARE WORKERS
ARE SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE RETAIL
WORKERS AND THAT'S NOT JUST A
FUNCTION OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
BUT IT EXACERBATES. THE
CONGESTION CRISIS GREENHOUSE
GASES WHAT THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW
CARES ABOUT.
ALRIGHT MR ACOSTA.
I THINK YOU AYE YOU APPRECIATE
THE OUT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT IN
TRYING TO. DO SOMETHING.
WE OFTEN STE
STRUGGLE WITH THE DO SOMETHINGS
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE HAVE SEQUEL
AMENDMENTS.
AND EXEMPTIONS.
PART LABOR WEEK IT SEEMS LIKE.
WHICH IS A PART OF THE THE
ISSUE WE ALSO HAVE A NIMBY ISSUE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE IT
WHERE I LIVE.
YOU KNOW WERE WERE A SUBURB OF
LOS ANGELES IS NOT UNLIKE AT
TINA TO ON MY COLLEAGUE PARA.
FROM.
STOCKINGS COMMENTS SAID IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT A WHOLE LOT
DIFFERENT IN THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE VERY VERY EXPENSIVE OVER
PRICED HOUSING. YOU KNOW THAT
PEOPLE TRYING TO FLEET FOR A LOT
OF REASONS BUT ONE OF THEM IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS NO
LONGER AFFORDABLE ANYMORE.
IF I TOLD YOU WHAT MY WIFE I
PAID FOR FIRST CONDO THIRTY
YEARS AGO HE'D BOY BOY DID DID
BY TEN BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S CRAZY.
BOB I HAVE A.
ALTHOUGH I I.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE GOING
WITH US I'VE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH IT. OF.
ONE OF THEM BEING.
YOU'RE VESTING.
BY THIS BILL BART TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THEIR OWN
PROPERTY WHICH IS GREAT.
BUT.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THAT PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY SAYS WE DON'T WANT IT?
CAN YOU CAN YOU.
ADDRESS THAT YEAH I MEAN AGAIN
THIS IS A CHOICE THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE THE REALITY IS THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT FOR FORTY FIVE
YEARS HAVE HAVE SAID NO HAVE
SAID THEY WOULD PREFER TO SEE
SERVICE PARKING LOTS. RATHER
THAN MIXED USE DEVELOPMENTS AND
AND HOUSING AND RESTAURANTS AND
WALKABILITY AROUND BART STATIONS
AND. WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO
CHANGE THAT UP AND I AM OPEN TO
ANY OTHER IDEAS TO TO THINK
ABOUT IT BUT WE THOUGHT THIS WAS
A MOST TAILORED AND TARGETED WAY
TO DO THAT.
TOTALLY. APPRECIATE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT NAME BE
CULTURE THAT FRANKLY IS TAKING
HOLD EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE THESE ISSUES FRANKLY IN
MY DISTRICT AS WELL YOU KNOW ARE
WE ARE WE SHOULD BUILD MORE
HOUSING BUT. NOT NEXT DOOR TO ME
OR NOT YOU KNOW HIGH DENSITY OR
WE HAVE YOU WE HAD THE. SENATE
BILL IT JUST RECENTLY AT DIDN'T
MAKE IT THROUGH WHICH IS SIMILAR
IN IN VAIN STATEWIDE.
BUT YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT BAR.
WHO?
TO MY MIND.
HAVING SERVED ON ON AN MPO.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
LARGEST IN THE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WORKED IN C. H. DE WORK AND
TRANSPORTATION A COMMITTEES.
I HAVE A REAL CONCERN WITH NOW
AN AGENCY LIKE BART WHO DOESN'T
DO HOUSING.
NOW WHERE THEY GONNA GET THE
EXPERTISE.
THE AUTHORITY YOU'RE GONNA BEST
IN THEM. AND HOW ARE THEY GOING
TO WORK WITH THESE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES THAT UP TO THIS
POINT.
DON'T WANT THIS THIS HOUSING
WHICH THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T.
IS THIS SOMEHOW.
AND THEN RUN DIG TO GIVE SOME
COVER FOR THE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES I MEAN I'M ASK A
TOUGH QUESTION HERE BECAUSE I
WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER. AND
SOMETIMES THOSE ARE WELCOME BUT
NOT ALWAYS SO.
THOSE ARE REALLY THE CHALLENGES
THAT I'M HAVING WITH THIS I JUST
WISH WE COULD TAKE A MUCH MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH.
STATEWIDE STATE OF THESE GIANT
MANDATES FROM ON HIGH AND
SACRAMENTO SAYING YOU MUST DO
THIS.
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT EVERYTHING
HOLISTICALLY AND GETTING
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM AT TOUGH
TO WORK WITH YOU WE WE TALKED
LAST YEAR BRIEFLY ABOUT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES. WHEN WE WERE.
HAD THAT ONE MEETING.
I'D LOVE TO DO THAT BUT WE'RE
HAVING A HARD TIME IN THE STATE.
IN GRAPPLING WITH ALL THESE
ISSUES AND GETTING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER WE ARE GETTING LABOR
BUILDERS ENVIRONMENT
COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW TRANSPORTATION SECTORS
EVERYONE TOGETHER IN A ROOM AND
GET THE SINKS HASHED OUT SO WERE
WE HAD UP WITH THINGS LIKE THIS
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT. HOUSING ON
SURFACE PARKING LOTS AND YOU
MIGHT BE GOING IT'S THE WILL OF
THOSE ACTUAL COMMUNITY SO YOU'RE
TRYING TO TO BENEFIT SO. I I
APPRECIATE WE'RE COME FROM A
PROBABLY ALCHEMY SPRINGER
BUILDING AS YOU CAN IMAGINE BUT
I LOVE TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE TO
THOSE COUPLE OF ISSUES
PARTICULARLY WITH THE BARK. UP
HAVING ANY EXPERTISE IN THIS AT
ALL IS ARE THEY GONNA CREATE
MORE ARE THEY HIRE NEW PEOPLE TO
DO IT YET SO SUBVERSIVE AND I'D
LOVE TO HAVE A LONGER
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT THIS
I KNOW THERE'S A. TENSION
BETWEEN WANTING TO SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL BUT UNDERSTANDING THE
LOCAL CONTROL IS SOMETIMES.
UP BLOCKING THE VERY TYPES OF
SMART GROWTH THAT I THINK WE
WANT AND THAT'S A CONSTANT
TENSION THAT THAT WE ADDRESS SO
FIRST OF ALL WITH REGARD TO WHAT
PART WOULD DO BAR UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY BE ALLOWED TO
SET. VERY BROAD TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT GUIDELINES ANOTHER
WORKS UP WOULD BE ABLE TO SET
AND AND AND THE AND THE
GUIDELINES THAT THEY'RE SETTING
ARE ALREADY OUT THERE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEY PASSED.
OUR AROUND DENSITY AND HEIGHT
AND PARKING BUT EVERYTHING ELSE
WOULD BE STILL CONTROLLED BY
LOCALS IN FACT WE THIS BILL CAME
OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. AND WE TOOK A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS EXACTLY
THAT SO WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE
LOCAL CONTROL FOR A LOT OF THOSE
DETAILS.
ON THIS BILL GIVES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TWO YEARS.
UPDATE THEIR LOCAL ZONING TO
ADDRESS THE THAT THE GENERAL
PARAMETERS THAT PART SETS BUT
THEN ALSO TO PROVIDE THEIR OWN
LOCAL ZONING FOR THIS SO THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
INPUT.
OVER ESTHETICS DESIGN EXCEPT
FOR.
SOME AND THEN THE LAST MEAL SAY
AND AND AGAIN WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM PART ON THIS
IS PART HAS HAD A VERY LONG
HISTORY. OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ON THIS BUT
WHAT WE FOUND OVER FORTY FIVE
YEARS IS EITHER IN MOST OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS THEY JUST SAID NO.
OR THE HANDFUL OF JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE SAID YES.
THE DEVELOPER HAS BEEN.
STRUNG OUT FOR UP FOR LESS
HOUSING AND AND MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
SMART GROWTH AND. OFTENTIMES
THESE PROJECTS TOOK TEN TO
TWENTY YEARS SO WE HAVE A CRISIS
TODAY WERE TRYING TO ACCELERATE
THAT AGAIN HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
MORE OF A CONVERSATION.
IT'S QUICK AND IT'S VERY VERY
BRIEF FOLLOW UP THAT HER THAT
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
SEE QUIRK RELIEF IN THIS BILL AT
ALL FOR THIS THIS TRANSIT PROP
PROJECTS.
THIS BILL.
ALLOWS PART TO BASICALLY.
TO TO MANAGE THAT SECRET
PROCESS SO WE'RE SIMPLIFYING THE
MATTER BUT TO YOUR POINT IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT FUNDAMENTALES
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPACTED SICK WHEN
THE WEATHER AYE I SUSPECT YOU
WOULD. BE WHAT YOU WANT WHY I
THINK FROM JUST STRICTLY THE
THAT THE.
.
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT SIDE OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN I THINK WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE GERMANE TO THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THEY CAN. DO
ALL THE ENTITLEMENT THEY WANT
WORK WITH THESE COMMITTEES
COMMITTEES CAN SAY YES AND THEN
SOMEONE ELSE COME IN WHO DOESN'T
EVEN LIVE IN THE BAY AREA. AND
SAY OH WE SHOULD DO THAT BECAUSE
EXPIRES THE AND THAT YOU'RE
STILL TALKING OR TEN OR TWENTY
YEARS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACOSTA I APPRECIATE THAT I DON'T
THINK THE REST OF THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD HAVE WANTED THIS BILL TO
BE. THE SITE OF A FIGHT OVER
WHETHER SEQUEL SHOULD INVOLVE
MORE LESS LAWSUITS HE WANTED TO
WANT TO LET THIS COMMITTEE
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES IN WITH
OTHER BILLS FOR JUST TRYING TO
BUILD. A TWENTY THOUSAND YEARS
OF HOUSE AROUND PART SIX.
RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT.
AS A MADE
IT'S OUR SECOND.
ALRIGHT.
MISTER CHIU.
I.
APPRECIATE YOUR VERY CREATIVE.
PROPOSAL HERE.
CLEARLY FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S SMART GROWTH
IT'S A HIGH DENSITY HOUSING
AROUND EXISTING.
RAIL TRANSIT.
YOU HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
SITUATION WHERE. YOU HAVE AN
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVE.
.
OFTEN THE BOARD BOARD.
AND SO IN A SENSE IT'S REPLACE
IT'S NOT TAKING AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL BUT.
IT'S REPLACING ONE LOCAL
CONTROL WITH ANOTHER FORM OF
LOCAL CONTROL.
.
I NORMALLY HAVE OF A VERY.
I'M VERY PROTECTIVE OF LOCAL
CONTROL IN AND A FOR THAT REASON
I.
GAVE A NON RECOMMENDATION FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
AS AS FAR AS YOUR BILL.
BUT.
.
AS TRYING TO THINK OF.
ARGUMENT SO WHY SHOULD NOT VOTE
FOR YOUR BILL AND I THINK YOU'VE
ADDRESSED ALL OF THEM AND SO I
WILL BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR BILL THANK YOU RIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE ALL HAD ABOUT
THIS THESE ARE DIFFICULT TOPICS
AND UP HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION ON IT BUT
AGAIN.
WE'VE REALLY TRIED TO NARROWLY
TAILORED THIS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
BILL IS ABOUT ADDRESSING
SUSTAINABILITY IN COMMUNITIES
REDUCING CONGESTION GREENHOUSE
GASES. ARE AND.
AND AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
DRESSING THE TWIN CRISES OF
CONGESTION AND HOUSING AND THAT
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOTIONS MADE
AND SECONDED.
MADAM SECRETARY.
I DON'T TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY THREE BY MEMBERS CHU
AND GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA
NO CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
MELENDEZ. MULLIN DOES NO RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE. STONE AYE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
NEXT WE HAVE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO MISS
CHAVEZ A. B. AUTHORITY TWENTY
SEVEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
REALLY ENJOYED THAT LAST
DISCUSSION BECAUSE. I HAVE A
BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE TALKING
EXACTLY ABOUT THE HOUSING
PRICES.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
NOT AS LARGE AS DESTRUCTIVE
PREVIOUS ONE BUT IT DEALS WITH
IT NAY MORE.
MONETARY WAY.
CHICO IS A GOOD PROCESS THAT CAN
BE ABUSED BY THOSE SEEKING TO.
PAT THEIR OWN WALLETS RATHER
THAN HONORABLE RESIDENTS.
OR ORGANIZATIONS OF EVERY TRUE
VESTED INTEREST IN THE
DEVELOPMENT.
AB THIRTY TWENTY SEVEN SIX TO
PUT REGIONAL PARAMETERS AROUND.
WHO CAN BE AWARDED ATTORNEY FEES
WHEN INTERVENING IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS?
BY NARROWING THE FIELD AROUND
WHO GETS AWARDED ATTORNEY FEES.
THOSE YOU LIVE NEARBY OR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE A TRACK RECORD.
AND PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT.
WE CAN WEED OUT SOME OF THE BAD
ACTORS THAT EXPLOIT CHICO.
THIS BILL.
DOES NOT NARROW WHO CAN
INTERVENE IN THE PROCESS.
SHIPLEY WHEN IT IS APPROPRIATE
FOR THEM TO COLLECT ATTORNEYS
FEES.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
SEQUEL PROCESS AND DO NOT WANT
TO DIMINISH THAT.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT SHE DOESN'T UP OPPORTUNITY
TO GET RICH.
OF CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WHO
EMPLOY OUR NEIGHBORS ARE NOW
WORKING TO ALLEVIATE THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CRISIS.
I WORKED TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE IN CHAIR
AND AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE
RENTERS.
AND TO FURTHER CLARIFY THAT
NONPROFIT STATUS OF THOSE WHO
CAN RECOUP THE FEES.
.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
SOMETIME IN OUR DISTRICT CAPTURE
MANY PEOPLE FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OF HER DECISION.
I HAVE TWO MEMBERS.
FROM FROM MY AREA ERIC FLOOR
DYING.
HE'LL BE MAKING HIS COMMENTS
AND ALSO HIS LAWYER AND ANDREWS
SKETCHY
SEWER ERIC.
GOOD AFTERNOON HARPER CHAIRMAN
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME'S
ERIK FLOW DEAN THAT REPRESENT
STRAT EQUITY GROUP TO SPONSOR OF
AB THREE OR TWO SEVEN.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE URBAN LAND
INSTITUTE DE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND A LIFE MEMBER OF
THE SIERRA CLUB.
OUR COMPANY STRAT EQUITY GROUP
WAS STARTED BY THREE BROTHERS
WHO IMMIGRATED FROM MEXICO.
TO CALIFORNIA.
THE FOUNDERS MADE THE DIFFICULT
DECISION TO LEAVE THEIR HOME.
TO ESCAPE THE RAMPANT GRAFT AND
OTHER FORMS OF EXTORTION THAT
THEY SUFFERED IN THE NORMAL
COURSE OF THEIR BUSINESS THERE.
THEY'RE STRONG FAMILY VALUES IN
THEIR STRONG JEWISH FAITH WOULD
NOT ALLOW THEM TO TOLERATE THE
EXTORTION TACTICS ANY LONGER SO
HE MOVED TO UNITED STATES AND
STARTED AGAIN WITH A SMALL REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPMENT COMPANY.
WHICH HAS SINCE GROWN TO OVER
FIFTY CALIFORNIANS.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE TO OUR
COMPANY FOUNDERS TO ONCE AGAIN
ENCOUNTERING NEW FORM OF
EXTORTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS TIME UNDER THE DISGUISE OF
SEQUEL. WHAT'S WORSE IS THE
PRACTICE IS NOT CURRENTLY
ILLEGAL.
WE WORK FOR OVER THREE YEARS ON
A SPECIFIC PROJECT WITH THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AT THE
NEIGHBORS AND THE CITY ON
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED MIXED USE
PROJECT COMPRISED OF A
NEIGHBORHOOD COMMERCIAL CENTER.
AND WORKFORCE HOUSING.
WITH NO LOCAL OPPOSITION.
SO FOLLOWING UNANIMOUS APPROVAL
WE RECEIVED A LEGAL CHALLENGE
FROM A QUORUM CALL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUP THATWAS FORMED CO
FOUNDED BY SOMEBODY WHO LIVES IN
ARIZONA AND SOMEBODY WHO LIVES
THIRTY MILES AWAY FROM OUR
PROJECT.
THEY CLAIMED THAT OUR PROJECT E.
I. R. AGAIN WHICH WAS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED.
WAS INADEQUATE AND REQUESTED THE
ADDITION OF TWO ADDITIONAL
MITIGATION MEASURES AND A
PAYMENT OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THESE MITIGATION MEASURES WERE
WINDOW DRESSING FOR THE REAL
REASON FOR THE LAWSUIT AND THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE CHANGED ANY OF
THE PROJECTS ALREADY LESS THAN
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS.
SO AFTER MONTHS OF MEETINGS AND
PHONE CALLS WITH THE PLAINTIFFS
ATTORNEYS WE GAVE THEM A CHOICE.
WE CAN INCORPORATE THE TO
MITIGATION MEASURES AND THEN PAY
THEM A SETTLEMENT OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR WE COULD
PAY THEM A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH NO
MITIGATION.
AS YOU MIGHT GUESS.
THEY CHOSE TO A SETTLEMENT TO
POCKET A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS NO MEDICATION NO PROJECT
CHANGES BECAUSE NONE WERE
NEEDED.
SO WE HAD TO GO ON REYES A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO PAY THEM OFF.
MILITARY THERE'S ANOTHER SMALL%
COMPANY THAT WE KNOW OF THAT
DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY OFF
THE SETTLEMENT AMOUNT AND SO
WITH THEIR SETTLEMENT REQUIRES
THE DONATION OF TWO RESIDENTIAL
LOTS.
AS PAYMENT
CARRASQUILLO TRY TO WRAP UP YES
SIR SO THIS IS REALLY HAPPENING.
THIS IS REALLY HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
SEEM ETHICAL MORAL OR LEGAL TO
YOU. WE DON'T ACCEPT THAT THIS
IS THE TERM THAT COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
THERE ARE ELECTED LEGISLATURE
INTENDS FOR THESE OUT OF TOWN
BAD ACTORS TO CONTINUE TO REAP
FINANCIAL WINDFALL.
FURTHER FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES.
THIS DOES NOT AFFECT THE ABILITY
OF CONCERNED LOCAL CITIZENS AND
LEGITIMATE ENVIRONMENT
ORGANIZATIONS FROM CHALLENGING
PROJECTS ON SEQUEL GROUNDS.
SO IN AND REFERENCE OF TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU HEARD A REAL
FACE ON THIS REAL ISSUE AND WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
TO ME THIS IS AND.
BUT IT AND ENTER SKETCHY WITH
OFFER INVEST FESTING KRIEGER.
THIS ONE TO CLARIFY ITS BEEN
EXPLAINED THOROUGHLY BUT THIS
BILL WOULD NOT PROHIBIT ANY
LAWSUIT UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT WOULD
SIMPLY DISCOURAGE THOSE THAT
SEEK TO USE EQUAL FOR ECONOMIC
GAIN. VERSES THE REAL REASON
PERCY CHO WAS A WHICH IS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEARLY COVERED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I ASSISTANCE AMONG THE OFFICE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATIONS PER.
P. MONTGOMERY FOR THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OF PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE JOINS US
HERE OF CALIFORNIA AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TODAY I'M
I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THAT ATTORNEYS FEES ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR PREVAILING PARTIES
IN SEQUEL LAWSUITS.
AND SO THOSE ARE FOR CASES THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH ON THE MERITS
AND THERE'S BEEN A FULL OF
JUDGMENT AND SO CASES INVOLVING
SETTLEMENTS WOULDN'T BE COVERED
BY THE SPELL.
IS THAT COVERED UNDER THIS BILL
BUT I I THINK WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT ANY
GROUPS OUT THERE WHO ARE LOOKING
TO.
SUE TO ENFORCE THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHTS TO HAVE.
A LIVABLE AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT.
MIGHT BE DISCOURAGED BY THIS
BILL OFF FOR SOME CASES YOU HAVE
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE WORK FOR
NONPROFITS WHO WILL TAKE CASES.
PROVIDED THAT THEY.
ONLY ON THE CONDITION THAT THEY
GET ATTORNEY'S FEES THEY WENT UP
AND SO FOR SOME ORGANIZATIONS
THIS WOULD BE. LIMITING THEIR
ABILITY TO USE THE LAW TO
ENFORCE THE RIGHT OR MAKE IT
HARDER TO FIND ATTORNEY.
MEANING THAT THOSE WHO JUST
CAN'T AFFORD ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WILL LOSE THAT RIGHT.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
POST AND ASKED FOR AND ABOUT
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SORRY MATTHEW BAKER PLANNING
CONSERVATION THE COULD. WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE RESEARCH
JUST ABOUT HEAR CLAPPING.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ME AS MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ASSEMBLYMAN CHVEZ I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD WE SEE A NUMBER OF BILLS
COME THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
THAT TRY TO NIBBLE AT THE EDGES
OF SEQUEL TRY TO DO SOME SORT OF
REFORM I THINK. MOST PEOPLE THE
LEGISLATURE AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO DO THAT.
ALTHOUGH WE SEE AGAIN AND AGAIN
THEEFFORTS REMAIN UNSUCCESSFUL
IN THAT IS UNFORTUNATE THIS BILL
IS I THINK GETS TO THE HEART OF
THE PROBLEM WITH WITH A SEQUIN
BEAST THAT WE SEE IN THIS STATE
WHICH IS THESE ATTORNEYS. WHO GO
FROM CITY TO CITY IN FROM
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT LOOKING
FOR A WAY TO GET A CHECK?
WE'VE ALL SEEN IT ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE COUNTY SUPERVISORS
ARE CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS PARTY
COMING HERE WE ALL KNOW EVERYONE
HAS THE GROUP. THAT THE
ATTORNEYS
WHO TRAVEL IN A PACK AND THEY GO
IN THE SO IN THE SUIT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS OURS WAS RAY
JOHNSON.
IN OUR AREA YOU KNOW THEY JUST
GO ROUND AND THEY SAY.
EITHER YOU.
HAND THIS OVER SOME MONEY OR
WE'RE GONNA STOP YOUR
DEVELOPMENT COST YOU THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL FEES.
UP UNTIL YOU FINALLY SAY UNCLE
AND GIVE US WHAT WE WANT AND ITS
ITS ITS PASSED TO STOP. THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLE BURDEN ON THE
TAXPAYERS IN THE CITIES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO BRING DEVELOPMENT
INTO THE CITY'S WEATHERS.
AT RESIDENTIAL OR WHETHER IT'S
COMMERCIAL.
THEY END UP PAYING THE COST
WHICH IS WHICH IS WRONG WHILE
THESE ATTORNEYS WHO WANT TO SEE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
SIT BACK FAT AND HAPPY.
GETTING RICH OFF THE BACKS OF
THE AVERAGE CITIZEN SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WITH THAT I MOVE THE
BILL.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR I
REALIZE THAT SEEK WAYS IN
PERFECT.
I SUPPORT EFFORTS TO TO
STREAMLINE AND AND LOOK AT THAT
WAYS I PROPOSED SOMETHING THIS
COMMITTEE. LAST YEAR TWO YEARS
AGO. I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS IS
THAT IS LOOKING FOR WHAT YOUR
TESTIMONY. I GOT AS ONE ASK YOU
A QUESTION SO THAT I THINK THERE
IS A CLARIFICATION FROM THE.
OPPOSITION THAT IT'S NOT JUST.
SETTLEMENTS AS ACTUAL JUDGMENTS.
BUT UP ON THE ANALYSIS IT TALKS
ABOUT THAT. THERE'S A THRESHOLD
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THERE'S
THERE'S PROOF THAT THERE. THERE
WERE FEES AT STAKE BUT THERE HAS
TO BE. A FINDING OF A ABOUT
PUBLIC BENEFIT SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC BENEFIT SO.
.
SURE LIKE CANADA THAT THAT
FOCUSES ON THAT THERE'S MONEY
AND THE HOUSE TO BE A A
PREVAILING BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC
AND SO.
WHY IS NOT THAT NOT ADDRESS WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO TELL THANK VERY
MUCH RUG? SOMEWHERE MCCARTY YOU
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE LIKE TO DRESS
FUNNY DO THAT SHORT YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. UNDER
EXISTING LAW THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A JUDGE TO LOOK
AT WHETHER FEEDBACK THAT SPEAK
TO THE MY SHORT UNDER THE
EXISTING LAW. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE JUDGE TO
LOOK AT THE PETITIONERS AND.
A CASE IN DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
BENEFIT THE PROBLEM THAT ARISES
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT IS
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT.
SUCH A BROAD THINK IT IMPACTS
EVERYBODY SO JUDGES HAVE
STRUGGLED AND THERE ARE VARYING.
DEGREES OF.
RESULTS ON THESE CASES BECAUSE
THE JUDGE LOOKS AT A
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWSUITS AS WELL
DOESN'T THAT EMPIRE MEANT IMPACT
EVERYBODY YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT. BUT
A LOT OF THESE LAWSUITS ARE
PURELY FOR PRIVATE GAIN AND THEY
ARE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S DIFFICULT.
FOR THE JUDGES TO WEIGH THAT AND
I'D.
FEEL AS THOUGH THIS WOULD GIVE
THEM MORE DIRECTION AS TO WHEN
IT IS APPROPRIATE.
FIND THAT BALANCE BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT VERSUS THE
PRIVATE BENEFIT.
MR AGO ACOSTA.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISS CHAVEZ I'LL SECOND THE
MOTION BY THE WAY FOR THE
RECORD.
.
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL STRUGGLE WITH
THIS AND IN OUR DISTRICTS I I'VE
BROUGHT UP IN THIS COMMITTEE.
LOCAL.
PROJECT TWENTY YEARS IN THE
MAKING REVIEW REVISE THE LAST
FIVE YEARS FRESH CIR.
BYE BYE AND FROM ALL THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THE NEIGHBORHOODS
CALTRANS BECAUSE IT'S ADJACENT
TO A FREEWAY YOU KNOW YOU NAME
IT.
ALL KINDS OF SETTLEMENTS BROKE
FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT AND I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE WANTS THE ENVIRONMENT
TO SUFFER ONE IOTA WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AND I WOULD
PERSONALLY LIKE TO SEE. OUR
THESE LAWSUITS BEING ADDRESSED
AND WE HAVE A REAL SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE DOING THAT.
.
THE THAT I AM AND FOR TO THE
KYLE.
JOHN SAID FROM SIERRA CLUB SAT
DOWN.
AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME BACK
A FEW LIKE BUT BUT I I DIDN'T
MEAN TO CALL YOU OUT MISS JONES
BUT.
I DON'T I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW.
IN THIS THIS CASE AND IN THE
THREE HUNDRED A SYDNEY THE.
THE MILLION MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
LAWSUIT THAT A LOCAL DEVELOPER
FOR IT MAKES USE PROJECT JUST
RECEIVED. WITH BOGUS MITIGATION
I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT THIS IT'S
THERE'S NOTHING HERE TO MITIGATE
AND YET THEY WANT MONEY AND
THEY'RE EXACTLY THE SAME
SITUATION AS A THREE PERSON LAW
FROM FROM SAN BERNADINO. THAT
HAS IT WOULD HAVE A HUNDRED
MILES FROM THE SENATE RATE OF
ALLEY AND THEY POP UP OUT OF NO
WHERE DAYS BEFORE YOU KNOW
PLAYED SPORTS TO BE TURNED.
THESE ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TO START GETTING AND
WHETHER IT'S THIS BILL OR THE
NEXT BILL I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
SOME KIND OF MOVEMENT BECAUSE WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT NOT BRIBIE
HERE. HOPEFULLY NOT.
BUT I'LL PROBABLY BE HERE MANY
YEARS FROM NOW DEALING WITH THE
SAME ISSUE AND I HOPE WE CAN
COME TO AGREEMENT I HER I CAN I
COUNT MULTIPLE VOTES. FROM THIS
DAIS THAT WANT TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE SO I WELCOME. MY
COLLEAGUES SAID WHO HAVE SAID
THAT USED TO SIT DOWN AND NOW
WILL WILL ORDER SOME PIZZA AND.
GET SOME SODAS AND COFFEE AND
AND START TO HASH THIS THING OUT
BUT I I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT.
FRANKLY.
IT'S.
LONG TIME COMING.
THAT WE DO SOMETHING ON THIS
ISSUE IN HERE WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW
IMMIGRANTS.
WHO YOU KNOW WORKING THAT
TRYING TO ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND WHAT THEY ARE BEING
STIFLED AT EVERY TURN SO?
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS AND
AT THE FLEA BE SPORTING A
BUILDING. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE.
THANK YOU SEE GOOD TENDS TO.
SO ALWAYS BE A BIT OF A. A
WHIPPING BOY IN IN THESE CASES
BUT THERE'S SOME. COMPONENTS OF
IT THAT ARE REALLY CRITICAL IN A
LOT OF. THE SEEK REFORM NOTIONS
THAT COME AROUND.
REALLY DO.
NOTHING BUT TAKE THE PUBLIC INTO
AND TAKE THAT THE EXPANSIVE
PROCESS AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC
CANCER IF WE. GO AFTER THE
ATTORNEY'S FEES HERE WHICH WHICH
IS FAIRLY CAREFULLY CRAFTED.
IN SEEK WORK AND IT THE.
THOSE WHO ARE. FILING SUIT DON'T
ALWAYS GET ATTORNEY SEES IN
THESE CASES.
AND HAVING BEEN A LOCAL ELECTED
DONE A NUMBER OF OF LAND USE.
ITEMS THAT SOMETIMES GET THE SIX
OKAY SOMETIMES NOT GET TO SEE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL WHEN WE'RE TAKING A COME
APART COMPONENT AGAINST. THE
PUBLIC OUT OF THAT THE QUESTION
HERE BECAUSE IF WE IF THEY WE
DON'T GIVE ATTORNEYS FEES WHEN
THERE'S A VERY GOOD REASON FOR
SOMEONE TO HAVE BROUGHT A SUIT.
REGARDLESS OF ALL OF THE OTHER
HYPE AROUND THAT THE SEQUEL
LAWSUITS THEN THAT'S GONNA HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT CHILLING EFFECTS
ON THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY TO WEIGH
IN ON A CASE. PLENTY OF
JURISDICTIONS GET THEMSELVES IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE THEY DON'T DO
THINGS LIKE ALTERNATE IS
ANALYSES
AND OFTENTIMES THAT NO ONE ELSE
IS THAT THE THAT THE.
JURISDICTION WANTS SHINES
THROUGH AND THE ALTERNATIVES
THAT ARE PRESENTED ARE GIVEN
REALLY SHORT SHRIFT THAT IS ONE
OF THE IN THE AREAS WHERE.
THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL ON AND MANY OF THESE
LAWSUITS THAT I SEE. OFTEN COME
BACK AROUND AND EVERYBODY AGREES
IN THE END WHEN THE SETTLEMENT
IS THERE THAT ALL THIS IS A
BETTER PROJECT AND IT'S A BETTER
PROJECT. BECAUSE.
IT HAD THE JURISDICTION
ULTIMATELY LISTENING TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE THERE
SOMETIMES IN THOSE CASES TOURNEY
SEES IT AWARD SOMETIMES NOT SORT
OF DEPENDS ON. ON THE OVERALL
CIRCUMSTANCE AND THAT'S WHERE
STRUGGLE WITH ON THIS BILL. IS
SENDING THAT MESSAGE OUT TO THE
PUBLIC THAT YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
MONEY TO BRING SUITS THEN ONLY
THOSE WHO HAVE THE MONEY TO
BRING SEE BECAUSE THEY CAN
AFFORD THE THE LEGAL FEES.
AND.
IT'S A WAY OF OF BALANCING THE
INTERESTS IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR THOSE NEIGHBORS FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO DON'T
HAPPEN TO HAVE MONEY THAT'S A
WHOLE NOTION BEHIND. ATTORNEY'S
FEES PROVISIONS ESPECIALLY IN
THESE CASES WHERE IT IS A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT IS. IS
ACTING SO THERE MAY BE THINGS WE
CAN DO AROUND SEQUEL BUT BUT IN
THIS CASE I MEAN THIS WILL HAVE
A CHILLING EFFECT. ON EXACTLY
THE NEIGHBORHOOD KIND
NEIGHBORHOOD CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE SO I'M I'M NOT
ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAVEZ WAS LIKE
CLOSE ITS I LIKE BREAKABLE
COMMENTS TO THE.
I'M NOT LOOKING TO MAKE IN
SEQUEL WHIPPING BOY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE.
IN AS FAR AS IT BEING CAREFULLY
CRAFTED.
YOU JUST HEARD.
ERIC MAKE THE GAVE YOUR TRUE
STORY WHERE IT'S NOT BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED.
A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
EXTORTION ON A PROJECT IS NOT A
CAREFULLY CRAFTED ENVIRONMENT.
YOU'RE WE THE AMENDMENTS WE MADE
HERE. WE WE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FIVE ONE C. THREE AGENCY
FOR.
HE'S ARE COVERS HERE EARLIER
THAT WASN'T A MAN WE JUST TOOK
WEEK GO CAN YOU SAID YOU'RE
RIGHT WE WANT YOU TO BE INVOLVED
IN THIS.
YOU HAVE AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY IN THIS ASSEMBLY EVER
I KNOW ALL YOU MEMBERS HERE.
HAVEN'T SEEN ME GIVEN NUMBERS
SPEECHES ON THIS I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
MY ACTUALLY MEMBER THE LITTLE
BUYER MIDDLE CAUCUS
SO DECISION NOT.
I'M NOT SOME CRAZED INDIVIDUAL
IS GOING AFTER THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE HEARING YOU HAD BEFORE.
IN A HEARING YOU HAVING RIGHT
NOW.
DEALS WITH THE ISSUE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
DELUDE MONEY.
WHEN HE HAS TO PAY A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND OR THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO SOMEBODY.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING HE'S GONNA
TAKE OUT OF HIS POCKET THAT'S
WHAT WAS GOING TO GO THE COST OF
THAT HOUSE. IN THOSE THOSE
PROJECTS.
WE THIS IS A VERY SMALL
MOVEMENT.
TO MAKE HOUSES MORE AFFORDABLE.
I'D ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAVEZ SITE.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR YOUR LEAD WITNESSES SO
PERSONAL STORY AND I I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT THERE WERE
NOT FOR WHO WE ARE AGAINST
EXTORTIONIST LAWSUITS AND THAT
WE WANT TO TRY TO TRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS.
TO UP CUT DOWN ON IS
EXTORTIONIST.
LAWSUITS
HOWEVER THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE
AS MR STONE INDICATED IS.
YOU KNOW DAY BYE BYE.
LIMITING THE CLASS OF PEOPLE
THAT CAN RECOVER ATTORNEY'S FEES
WHEN OFTEN ESPECIALLY FOR THE
LITTLE GUYS.
AND AND AND THE LITTLE GIRLS IT
OF OUT THERE IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHO HAVE LEGITIMATE GRIEVANCES
THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY CAN
BRING?
SEQUEL LAWSUITS IS THROUGH THE
ATTORNEY FEES.
THAT WHILE I APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
YOU YOU THE MANAGER BILL TO
INCLUDE TENANTS.
TWO ONE OF THE POINTS THAT I
HAD RAISED BUT.
.
NO I I THINK THERE OTHERS.
YOU KNOW.
SMALLER ENVIRONMENTAL OR
COMMUNITY GROUPS TO START THAT.
THAT WOULD BE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TO BE ABLE
TO BRING LEGITIMACY QUILL
LAWSUITS.
.
AND SO.
THE PROBLEM IS REAL.
BUT I CANNOT SUPPORT YOUR
PROPOSED SOLUTION HERE TODAY AND
FOR THAT REASON I'M WRECKING
RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM THIRTY TWO A. B. THIRTY
TWENTY SEVEN BY MEMBER CHVEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI NOW ROUTES IF
YOU KNOW ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE
CHAU.
SHOWN UP VOTING. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING. FLORA.
FLORA KILEY MON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S AYE VARIOUS.
REYES NOT VOTING STONE.
STONE NO.
THREE THREE A RIGHT IN THE
BILL'S ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MAKE YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE.
ITEM THIRTY FIVE MS RUBIO A. B.
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
ABSENCE OF AVAILABLE MARKET
REQUIRED FOR WASTE DIVERSION OF
RECYCLED MATERIALS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR CHINA IMPOSE
NEW STRICT POLICIES LIMITING
RECYCLABLE IMPORTS AND PLACING
OUTRIGHT BANS ON MIXED PAPER AND
VARIOUS PLASTICS.
THIS HAS RATES GREAT CONCERNS
BECAUSE CHINA HAD BEEN THE
LARGEST WORLD MARKET FOR MANY OF
OUR RECYCLABLE PRODUCTS.
SOMETHING THE CALIFORNIA LAW DID
NOT ANTICIPATE AND THAT
CURRENTLY DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES EACH LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO DIVERT FIFTY
PERCENT OF SOLID WASTE BY THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONALLY
LAW DOES NOT PROHIBIT THE
DISPOSAL OF RECYCLABLE MATERIALS
BUT THAT'S EXPOSED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CIVIL PENALTIES.
IF THEY'RE DISPOSABLE DISPOSAL
ACTIVITY LEADS THEM TO DIVERT
LEFT IN THE REQUIRED FIFTY
PERCENT UNLESS THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE TO HAVE MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO DO SO.
HOWEVER EXISTING NOT DOES NOT
LIST A RECYCLABLE RECYCLABLES
MARKET FAILURE AMONG THE
CRITERIA THAT CAL RECYCLE SHOULD
CONSIDER IN DETERMINING WHETHER
TO ISSUE A COMPLIANCE ORDER OR
IF THE ABSENCE OF A MARKET CAN
BE CONSIDERED AS A GOOD. FAITH
EFFORT THE LAW ALSO DOES NOT
TAKE MARKET FAILURE INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN REQUIRING FIFTY PERCENT
DIVERSION OR DURING THE ISSUING
OF CIVIL PENALTIES FOR FAILURE
TO MEET THE FIFTY PERCENT I
VERSION.
MY BILL AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT ADDRESSES THE ISSUE BY
ALLOWING A JURISDICTION TO
TEMPORARILY ARRANGE AND DISPOSE
OF MATERIALS IF IT IS NECESSARY
TO DO SO UNDER EXISTING LAW.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE TEMPORARY
PROTECTION FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
FROM IF ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS OR
CIVIL PENALTIES PENALTIES WHEN
THEY NEED TO DISPOSE OF EXCESS
MATERIALS OCCURS EVERY IS AS A
RESULT OF MARKET FAILURE. WHAT
THE BILL DOES NOT DO IS REPEAL
OR THREATEN EXISTING LAW OR
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS TO RECYCLE
MATERIALS? IT ALSO DOES NOT
PROVIDE DIRECT RELIEF TO HAULERS
OR TO WASTE RECYCLERS BECAUSE
ENFORCEMENT UNDER AB NINE THIRTY
NINE IS DIRECTED TOWARDS LOCAL
AGENCIES NOT TO THE CONTRACTORS.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES DO IS TAKE
THE ABSENCE OF AVAILABLE MARKETS
INTO ACCOUNT BY ESTABLISHING A
TEMPORARY MEASURE TO ADDRESS
UNPREDICTABLE AN UNSUSPECTING
STABLE WORLD MARKETS FOR OUR
MATERIALS?
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS IN GOOD FAITH EFFORT
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE I
WILL ACCEPT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS. THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
REQUIRING CAP BIKEL TO CONSIDER
EFFORTS THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE MADE TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF THE RICH AND. REMOVE
CONTAMINANTS FROM RECYCLED
MATERIALS WHEN MAKING A
DETERMINATION OF GOOD FAITH
EFFORT.
ALSO REMOVING SUBPARAGRAPH SEE
FROM FORTY ONE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO
POINT ZERO TWO WHICH WOULD
STRIKE THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET THAT
WOULD PROTECT LOCAL AGENCIES
FROM PENALTIES. UNDER AB NINE
THIRTY NINE REMOVE REMOVING
REFERENCE TO THE STATE'S FIFTY
PERCENT DIVERSION.
REQUIREMENT BY STRIKING OUTLINES
FIVE THROUGH TWELVE ON PAGE FOUR
OF THE BILL I AM ALSO PREPARED
TO ACCEPT. THE FIRST AMENDMENT
THAT MARKETS MAY BE MAY BE
CONSIDERED AN COMPLIANCE ORDER
DETERMINATIONS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH ME UP
UNTIL THE LAST MINUTE TO MAKE
SURE THAT I GET I COULD THAT
PRESENT THE BILL THAT WOULD.
PLEASE THE.
THE COMMITTEE.
HERE TO TESTIFY AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I HAVE
WITNESSES OUT KELLY ASKED ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
.
THANK YOU IS RUBIO A MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KELLY ASTRO
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE
RECYCLING COUNCIL.
I TOO AM GRATEFUL FOR A LOT OF
THE.
GUIDANCE GIVEN TO US BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THERE'S A
VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS YOU KNOW.
AS I PREPARED FOR TODAY'S
HEARING AT ONE POINT IN TIME A
LARGE PART OF MY REMARKS WAS ME
DEVOTED OUTLINED THE PROBLEM I'M
HOPING. WILL UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM WON'T GO INTO TOO MUCH
THE SIGNIFICANCE EXCEPT TO SAY
THAT.
WE'RE SEEING AN UNPRECEDENTED
MARKET FAILURE WE BENT DOES THE
LAW SOME OF US WERE AROUND
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS GOING AB NINE
THIRTY NINE PASSED.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS AND IT'S NOT CALIFORNIA
ALONE IS NOT THE WEST COAST
ALLIANCE NOT AUSTRALIA IT'S
EVERYBODY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
MATERIALS WERE GOING TO A PLACE
AND NO LONGER ACCEPTS MUCH OF
WHAT THEY WERE ACCEPTING.
SO ALWAYS TELLING COMMUNITY THAT
I REPRESENT HAS GONE TO GREAT
LENGTHS TO TRY TO IMPROVE
PRODUCT QUALITY THEIR SWORDS
SLOWING THE SORTING LINES ARE
PRETTY EQUIPMENT ALL THESE
THINGS IN ANTICIPATION TRYING TO
MEET THE NEW NEED.
AND TO SOME EXTENT THEIR
SUCCESSFUL BUT THERE'S A PART
THAT THEY CANNOT CONTROL.
IT TOOK TO PUT IT DOWN DO IS
STEP WAS TERMS IT DISTILLS THIS
WAY.
WILL CONTINUE TO COLLECT
MATERIALS WILL CONTINUE TO
PROCESS SOME TO INTEGRITY. WILL
WORK DILIGENTLY TO IDENTIFY
MARKETS BUT FOR THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE DESPITE THOSE EFFORTS
THERE IS NO MARKET.
OUR APPEAL TO YOU TODAY IS TO
GET GIVE US SOME RELIEF AND HOW
IS THE AUTHOR INDICATED WITH A
NEW SET OF AMENDMENTS WE'VE
AGREED TO IN CONCEPT.
I WOULD HAVE LANGUAGE REFER TO
COURSE YET BUT.
THERE'S NO LONGER ANY
AFFIRMATIVE RELIEF IN THE BILL
THE RELIEF FROM PENALTY
PROVISION IS ONE OF THE.
AMENDMENTS THAT.
ONE OF THE. PROVISIONS OF VOTES
COMING OUT SO WHAT'S LEFT.
THERE ARE TWO AREAS IN LAW
CURRENTLY WERE CAL RECYCLE
FOLLOWS A LIST OF CRITERIA IN
MAKING DECISIONS.
ONE OF THOSE HAS TO DO WITH A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
TERMINATION.
AND THE SECOND ONE WHICH FOLLOWS
THAT YOU'RE NOT FOUND TO BE A
GOOD FAITH THE CALVIN CYCLE THEN
DECIDES BASED ON CERTAIN
CRITERIA. WHETHER OR NOT A
COMPLIANCE ORDER WILL ISSUE.
WHAT THIS BILL ASKS IS THAT IN
EITHER IN BOTH CASE BOTH CASES
MARKETS BE CONSIDERED?
NOW WHAT WE MIGHT WANT TO ASSUME
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ANYWAY
AND I WOULD CONCEDE WITH THE
POINT RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT TO DATE. COVER CYCLES NEVER
MISTREATED US.
BUT HERE'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT THE
SCALE OF THIS PROBLEM IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS SINCE WE HAD
A WASTE BOARD WE MIGHT HAVE
APPEALED TO HAD THERE BEEN A
PROBLEM WITH WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
WANTED TO DO.
AND SO IF IT'S OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION BUT BECAUSE
WE'RE CHARTING NEW TERRITORY
HERE WE JUST THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE. THAT MARKETS BE
CONSIDERED CAL RECYCLE STILL
RETAINS ALL DISCRETION IS DAMN
MUCH WEIGHT THEY GIVE TO THESE
CRITERIA WE SIMPLY WANT TO ADD
THIS TO THE LIST.
AND ARE THERE SOME CONVERSATION
ABOUT DISS BILL AFFECT DIVERSE
ARE NOT NO IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
COUNTS IS DISPOSABLE.
VERSES DIVERSION.
DOESN'T IT JUST A FIFTY PERCENT
REQUIREMENT WAS ALWAYS DIRECTED
TOWARD ENFORCEMENT AS A RESULT
OF THE LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS
WERE NOW DOWN TO JUST.
HAVING MARKETS IDENTIFIED ON THE
CRITERIA LISTS.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE DRIVE
VOTE.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. AND FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY KELLY ASTOR
AND BY THE AUTHOR WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
CARE MARTINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULET REPRESENTING SEE OUR
NARN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA MELISSA
CHAYTOR ENTRY ON BEHALF THE
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA OR SUPPORTIVE IN
CONCEPT.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
POSTURE WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I JOIN OF THEIR BILL ON BEHALF
AT THEN SERVICES ALSO SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'M AARON
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. THE LEAGUE
HAS TAKEN A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE SPELL LARGELY
BECAUSE WE'D REALLY LIKE TO
ENGAGE IN THIS CONVERSATION AND
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. HOW MARKETS
MIGHT BE DEVELOPED REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE MEASURE I
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU?
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
CHAIR MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE.
WERE WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AS IT WAS IN PRINT ARMED
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL BE REMOVING. OUR
OPPOSITION I I GUESS I'M
INTERESTED IN. UNDERSTANDING THE
THE. THE DETAILS OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS IT YOU KNOW AS THE AS
THE AUTHORS STATED WE ARE IN A
CRISIS.
AND WE THINK IT'S NECESSARY FOR
ALL OF THE STAKE HOLDERS THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN RECYCLING
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PRIVATE SECTOR RECYCLER
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEE TO BE
WORKING TOGETHER. TO IMPROVE
MARKETS AND RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEED TO INVEST MORE IN THE
PROCESSING AND THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THOSE MARKETS.
THAT SHOULD BE OUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE AND THIS IS
POTENTIALLY A VEHICLE FOR DOING
THAT BOMB.
WE DON'T NEED TO BE RETHINKING
THE FIFTY PERCENT WE MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION WITH THE
SPONSORS AS TO WHAT THEIR
INITIAL LANGUAGE DID. BUT I
BELIEVE THAT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND
FOCUS ON THE COLLECTIVE WORK OF
DEVELOPING THAT THE NECESSARY
AND USE MARKETS AND THE
RESOURCES FOR PROCESSING
MATERIAL. SO THAT WE CAN RECYCLE
IT HERE IN CALIFORNIA CREATE THE
JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE SO AT THIS POINT. BUT
I'M NOT.
I AYE I BOMBING TRUSTING THAT
THE CHAIR TO INTERPRET WHAT THE.
AUTHOR'S INTENT WAS.
SIR ANY ANY IF YOU CAN NO I
REMAINED AT THE TABLE. LOOS
LIKE WE MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ADDRESSED TO YOU ARE THERE ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON BICU ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOVING
COALITION INCLUDING HEAL THE BAY
SURFRIDER AND OTHERS.
ALSO WERE IN OPPOSITION AND
WILL BE REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
AND THE CONSIDERING THINK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RAYOS THEM AS
EGGMAN.
FIRST I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS MAKES EVERYTHING MUCH
EASIER.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION FROM THE
CALVET LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION
VOTERS.
SHE LEAVE.
HAS THAT THAT THEY WERE IN
OPPOSITION HAS OPPOSITION BEEN
REMOVED.
I TALK TO JENNA TEN MINS AGO SHE
SAID SHE WOULD BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU MS
EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU I WANNA. I WANNA
THANK THE THE AUTHOR FOR THE
HARD WORK WE WE TALKED EARLIER
TODAY AND WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH MR ASK TO HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATION. I'M
EVEN JUST MY CONCERN ABOUT
COUNTING THAT AS AS A
AS PART OF THE FIFTY PERCENT.
AND I I HAVE AND WILL HEARD ME
SAY THIS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
AND I'M SWEATING EMBARRASSED
HONEST IS OUR RECYCLING AND I
UNDERSTAND.
THAT.
THE HOLLERS AND THE PROCESSORS
ARE ON THE END OF THAT STRING.
AND THEY DON'T GET A SAY IN IN
THE MARKET PART OF IT.
SO I I I I I I I I I I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
SINCE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
POLITICS AND RECYCLING THAT'S
BEEN MY ONE THING WE HAVE TO
CREATE OUR OWN MARKETS I WAS
SAYING SINCE.
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS DOES NOT
GONNA WANT ADDRESS PERSON WELL
IT'S YOU KNOW IT IT HERE IT IS
IT'S HAPPENED AND BUT WE ALL
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THIS.
COMMIT THINK WE WE STILL NEED
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE OUR TRASH CLEANER.
ON A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
OUR TIPPING FEE IN OUR SINGLE
STREAM AND THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLICATED ISSUES.
BUT THE ISSUE IS THAT THERE'S A
CRISIS RIGHT NOW AND THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TAKE SOME STEPS
I APPRECIATE THE SUNSET.
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS YOU'VE
TAKEN AND A MOVE THE BILL.
ALRIGHT.
MOST OF THEM MADE AND SECONDED
TO MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WONDER IF I CAN GET THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES BACK UP TO THE
MICROPHONES THAT I COULD. JUST.
ASK FOR SOME CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU.
.
SO IF I HEARD YOU CORRECTLY YOU
SAID THIS WAS A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION BY THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES BUT I DIDN'T.
HERE WHAT AMENDMENT IT WISE
THAT YOU WANTED.
THAT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
SO THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES THE REMAINS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR RECYCLING
GOALS OF THE STATE. AND SO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE REQUESTED.
ARE TO.
INCLUDED SUNSET DATE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND.
I'LL BE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS.
AS THEY COME ACROSS.
SO THE SUNSET DATE.
ADDRESSING A MECHANISM TO
ADDRESS MARKETS INSIDE LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSORS AND ALL OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT. AS WELL AS
FUNDING TO HELP ADDRESS MARKETS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THAT.
SO.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO I WANNA.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD JUST
RECENTLY HAD WITH THE WASTE
HAULERS IN MY DISTRICT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT. CHINA DOESN'T WANT IT
ANYMORE RIGHT SO WHAT ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO DO WITH THAT STOCK
IN WAREHOUSES WHAT ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO DO WITH IT AND THIS
IS A MAJOR. PROBLEM.
AND AND I COMMEND YOU FOR YOU
KNOW BRINGING FORWARD A BILL
THAT AT LEAST. AT ADDRESSES IT
IN A IN A PRAGMATIC WAY AND THIS
ISN'T THE END OF THE DISCUSSION
OBVIOUSLY BUT WE DO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING I THINK YOU HEARD.
I THINK EVERYONE HEARD SOME
PRETTY GOOD POINTS MADE BY YOUR
WITNESSES AS TO WHY WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS.
SO WITH THAT I KNOW THAT I
BELIEVE THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED.
BUT I I'M HAPPY SPREE ABOUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE TOM IS RUBIO AYE
AS WANT TO CLARIFY FOR THE
RECORD.
I ALLEN IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE.
ACCEPTED ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
IT IS THAT INCLUDE PAGE FIVE
THEY ANNOUNCES.
PAGE FIVE.
THE PROVISION IN THE ONE TWO
THREE FOURTH PARAGRAPH THAT ONE.
.
SUBPARAGRAPH SEES ISN'T THE
SPONSOR IS RECOMMENDING THAT
SUBPARAGRAPH C. BE REMOVED.
WHICH IS SAD LINES THIRTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN I'M ON PAGE
FOUR MISTER CHAIR.
I'M ACTUALLY REFERRING TO PAGE
FIVE PARAGRAPH.
IN THE ANNOUNCES PARAGRAPH FOR
THE COMMITTING.
IS RECOMMENDING. THE AMENDMENT
TO REQUIRE CAL RECYCLE TO
CONSIDER EFFORTS THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE MADE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF A REMOVE
CONTAMINANTS.
FROM RECYCLED MATERIALS WHEN
MAKING A DETERMINATION OF GOOD
FAITH EFFORT YES.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS RUBIO FLORA MISTER CHAIRMAN
I FORGIVE ME SIR MAY I JUST
CLARIFY ONE THING. WITH THAT
SUBPARAGRAPH SEE ON PAGE FOUR OF
THE BILL COMING OUT THE SUNSET
ONE ALSO COME OUT AT THIS POINT
IS THAT WAS THE PROVISION. WE
WERE SAN SETTING ALL THE REMAINS
OF THAT SECTION OF THE BILL
FORMER SECTION TO ARE THE SIX
FINDINGS IS TO CLARIFY THAT WAS
STAFF THOSE DON'T SUNSET.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT
WHAT THINK YOU THAT THANK YOU
MISTER TERRY I AM JUST A YOU
KNOW FOR CLARIFICATION THE
REASON THAT THIS CAME ABOUT AS I
WAS DOING SOME. SOME VISITING IN
AND OUR. LOCAL HAULERS AND AND
IT'S IT'S A CRISIS AND YOU KNOW
AND I APPRECIATE THE THE.
.
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
CAN ADDRESS IT IT CHINA JUST
DECIDED TO DO IT YOU KNOW ALL OF
A SUDDEN AND SO THERE WAS NO
PLANNING AND SO HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL. GIVE.
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
ON HOW WE CAN PLAN AND HOW WE
CAN FUND SO THAT SOME OF THESE
ON PROJECTS AND I THINK THAT'S
THE PROBLEM IS. YOU KNOW WE
WEREN'T EXPECTING IT AND AND SO
NOBODY WAS NECESSARILY PLANNING
OR INVESTING IN THESE MARKETS SO
I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH THEM
ARM INTO COMMUNITY ON HELPING US
IDENTIFY HOW. WE CAN FUNDING IS.
I TO TO TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO SAY
YOU NEED TO FIND THIS AND THEN
ANOTHER THING IS WHO'S GOING TO
FUNDED. AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION.
CONTINUING AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS RUBIO FOR.
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS.
ADDRESS IN THIS.
.
THIS CRISIS.
AND THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
IS AYE AS AMENDED.
AND WITH THAT THE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE.
I DON'T THIRTY FIVE A. B. THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY MEMBER
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED IN REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING Y.
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA. CHAU CHAU
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. LIMON.
MCCARTY. MELENDEZ REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO.
FIVE ZERO BILLS ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY LINK YOU.
OUR NEXT WE HAVE MISTER HOLDEN
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'D LIKE
TO.
.
PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX
TODAY.
MUCH LIKE ACTIVE PRODUCTION
SITES.
IDLE ABANDONED AND HAZARDOUS
INACTIVE OIL AND GAS WELLS CAN
LEAD POLLUTION INTO THE AIR
WATER AND GROUND. CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN ADDRESSING POLLUTION FROM
THESE WELLS THROUGH RECENT
LEGISLATION AND REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BETTER THE PUBLIC'S
KNOWLEDGE.
AND FORM ONGOING OIL AND GAS
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION AND
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THROUGH ACCUMULATING EMISSIONS
DATA.
THE STATE AND PRIVATE COMPANIES
ARE PLUGIN IDLE AN ABANDONED
WELLS BUT ARE NOT TESTING AND UP
AND REPORTING WHAT IF ANY
CHEMICALS ARE BEING EMITTED.
FROM THESE WELLS.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX PROPOSES
EMISSIONS TESTING TO BE DONE ON.
PROXIMITY WELLS THOSE THAT ARE
WITH ONE QUARTER MILE OF A HUMAN
OCCUPIED BUILDING. THAT ARE
BEING PLUGGED IN ABANDONED BY
OIL AND GAS OPERATORS PURSUANT
TO AN IDOL WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND HAZARDOUS ABANDONED WELLS
BEING PLUGGED AND ABANDONED BY
DR.
ENHANCE FLOW RATE TESTING MUST
BE PERFORMED ON WELLS WARRANTED
IT INDICATION OF AN ACTIVE
EMISSIONS SOURCE IS PRESENT.
AND THE DATA COLLECTED FROM SUCH
TESTING SO BE MADE AVAILABLE ON
THE DOCTOR WEBSITE.
I HAVE WITH ME TIM O'CONNOR
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA OIL
AND GAS PROGRAM IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR WEAVERVILLE DEFENSE
FUND IS A SPONSOR OF AB THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX AND OVER THE PAST
OF FOR YEARS EDF HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
TO CHARACTERIZE THE AIR WATER
AND CLIMATE.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS FROM
THE OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS BILL THROUGH ITS NARROW
FOCUS ON I DON'T ABANDONED WELLS
WILL HELP SOLVE THE CRITICAL
KNOWLEDGE GAP ASSOCIATED WITH
AGING OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE
IN CALIFORNIA. MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT IDLE AND
ABANDONED OIL AND GAS WELLS CAN
AND DO LEAGUE COMPOUNDS INTO THE
AIR ONE SUCH COMPOUND METHANE.
IS A POTENT GREENHOUSE GAS
EIGHTY FOUR TIMES THAT MORE
POWERFUL THE CARBON DIOXIDE. I
COULD YOU TO CLIMATE CHANGE OVER
THE FIRST TWENTY YEARS IT'S
RELEASED. O. OTHER COMPOUNDS
INCLUDE BENZENE AND TOLLEY WE
WHICH ARE BOTH KNOWN HUMAN
CARCINOGENS UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH
RESEARCH ON IDLE AND ABANDON
WELL LEAKAGE HAVE NOT ANSWERED
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHICH
CALIFORNIA WELLS ARE LEAKING.
LEAVING REGULATORS AND FENCE
LINE COMMUNITIES WITH LITTLE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH
OUR PROGRAMS ARE EFFECTIVE AT
CONTROLLING POLLUTION FROM THESE
POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS SITES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 27-29 TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF IDLE AND
ABANDONED WELLS IN THE STATE. AS
A RESULT OF THIS LAW OPERATORS
WILL SOON BE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF WELLS HE'LL BE
PLUGGING ON A YEARLY BASIS AND
DAUGHTER WILL BE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF WELLS THAT IT RESPONSE
TO.
THAT ARE ON AN ABANDONED WELL
LIST AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX
ADVANCES THESE EFFORTS BY
DEVELOPING DATA ON A MISSIONS
BEFORE AND AFTER WELL PLUGGING
WILL HELP PROVIDE A SCIENCE
BASED DETERMINATION. OF WHETHER
CALIFORNIA'S DOING ENOUGH TO
LIMIT THE EMISSIONS FROM THE
SOURCES BY TARGETING WELLS THAT
ARE ALREADY GOING TO BE
REMEDIATED A. B. THIRTY ONE
FORTY SIX. CAPITALIZES ON LABOR
THE WILL ALREADY BE DEPLOYED AT
THE SITES THEREBY REDUCING COSTS
AND TARGETING WELLS THAT ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE EMITTING
POLLUTION.
THE OPPOSITION THIS BILL WILL
LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE THAT A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX IS
DUPLICATIVE OR OTHERWISE
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE THERE ARE
OTHER RULES AND OTHER
REGULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA OR AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. WELL THERE
ARE STANDARDS ON VARIOUS ASPECTS
OF THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY THEY
DO NOTHING TO UNDERMINE THE NEED
AND THE VALUE OF THIS BILL.
NONE OF THE EXISTING RULES OR
STANDARDS DEVELOP THE EMISSIONS
DATA ON THESE WELLS THAT THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX WILL CULTIVATE.
AND WILL MAKE IT AND WILL MAKE
IT A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE MANNER.
WITH REGARD TO THE DISTANCE
ESTABLISHED IN THE BILL.
HERE AB ONE THIRTY EARTH THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX SIXTY SCIENCE
BASED YET CONSERVATIVE APPROACH
ACCORDING TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
STUDY BY STAND ELWAY. A A OF
LOOKING LOOKING APPEAR REVIEWED
RESEARCH IN EIGHT SEPARATE
STUDIES EVALUATED THEIR DOCUMENT
EXPOSURES OF POTENTIAL
DELETERIOUS IMPACTS ON NEARBY
COMMUNITIES FROM OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS AT A DISTANCE ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FEET. AB ONE
THIRTY FIVE ONE FORTY SIX
ESTABLISHES A CONSERVATIVE A
DISTANT AT APPROXIMATELY THIS
LINE PLUS ABOUT A TEN PERCENT
MARGIN OF ERROR. IT ITS COULD
WRAP UP.
IT GO THIRTY FOUR IT THROUGH
FORTY SIX INDUSTRY VEHICLE FOR
THE STATE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACTS OF UNPLUGGED I DON'T
BEEN WELLS WE'VE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU DRIVE UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PETER
BETTER AND I HAVE BEEN AN
INDEPENDENT CONSULTANT THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS.
THE PRIMARILY INVOLVED IN THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY SECTOR.
I'VE DONE WORK IN THE OIL AND
GAS SECTOR AS WELL.
FOCUSING PRIMARILY ON IMPROVING
FIELD OPERATIONS.
AND ADVISING.
.
ON MY CLIENTS ONE.
THE ACQUISITION AND EVALUATION
OF.
STRIPPER OIL WELLS.
DO MY WORK BECOME IT WILL BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE REALITIES OF
OPERATING LOW PRODUCING WELLS
AND MANY OF THESE PRACTICES
ASSOCIATED WITH LOW MARGIN
OPERATIONS.
FOR SUCH OPERATORS AIBILEEN WELL
AS MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
PREFERABLE TO ENCOURAGE THE HIGH
COST OF PROPERLY PLUGGING IN THE
BAND IN A WELL.
CAME INTEREST IN STATE THE
PROBLEM OF THE BAND THAT NIGHT
WELLES AFTER READING THE ARTICLE
IN THE LA TIMES.
WITH REFERENCE TO NASA JPL
CALTECH STUDY OF METHANE IN THE
LA BASIN.
THEY'D FOUND METHANE LEVELS UP
TO SIXTY ONE PERCENT GREATER
THAN HAD PREVIOUSLY PROTECT BEEN
PREDICTED BY THE EPA.
BEEN A RESIDENT OF THE LA AREA
IT'S CAUSED ME GREAT CONCERN AND
CREEK MY INTEREST.
AS I'VE LOOKED DEEPER INTO THE
SUBJECT STUDY AFTER STUDY I'VE
REVIEWED CITED FINDINGS THAT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THE
ACCIDENT EPA'S ESTIMATES OF
METHANE LEAKAGE FROM OIL GAS
OPERATION. HAS BEEN SUSPECT.
APPEARS THAT MANY CASES EPA
GROSSLY UNDERESTIMATED FREAKY
TREE.
ONE OF MORE RELEVANT STUDIES ON
AN OIL AND GAS WELL WHICH WAS
PERFORMED ON WE GET FROM ONE GAS
WELLS WAS PERFORMED BY PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY. IN A STUDY THROUGH A
SMALL SAMPLE OF WELLS IN
PENNSYLVANIA WAS FOUND THAT
ALMOST ALL THE WELLS OBSERVED.
WERE LEAKING TO SOME EXTENT SOME
QUITE HIGH.
OTHER PEER REVIEW PUBLICATIONS
SUPPORTED THE FINDING THAT I'D
ONLY BEEN THE WELLS. HAVE A
LEAKAGE PROBLEM AND THE INDUSTRY
ITSELF HAS REPORTED THAT WELL
CASE FAILURE RATES MAYBE OVER
TWENTY PERCENT.
INCREASING AS THE WELLS AGE.
IN THE LA BASIN LIKE CENTRAL
VALLEY ITEM BIGELOW WELL WAS ARE
COMMON PLACE MANY OF THESE WELLS
WERE BANNED LONG BEFORE THE
FORMATION OF DOGRA NINETEEN
FIFTEEN. AND BEFORE THEIR ANY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF
PLUCKING AND ABANDONED MEANT
STANDARDS.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
THERE WERE NO AND INDUSTRY
STANDARDS AS TO HOW TO PLUG AND
ABANDONED OIL WELL.
OF THE OVER TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED IDLE IN
BAND OF WELLESLEY CALIFORNIA.
THOUSANDS THESE WELLS HAVE BEEN
IDLE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
IN SEVERAL HUNDRED LISTED HAVE
BEEN IDLE FOR FORTY YEARS OR
MORE.
SIR AND ASK YOU TO
TRY TO WRAP UP THOUGH RIGHT.
.
YEAH I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE.
PEOPLE FROM.
.
THE.
STANFORD SCHOOL OF EARTH ENERGY
ENVIRONMENT SCIENCE AND THEY ARE
ATTEMPTING TO MEASURE METHANE
LEAKAGE FROM BEEN DENIED WELLS
IN CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON THEIR PRELIMINARY
RESEARCH AND IT IS ADMITTEDLY
SMALL SAMPLE.
IT APPEARS THAT AMONG THE IDA
WELLS SURVEYED THE MAJORITY OF
THEM. HAVE BEEN LEAKING.
.
THE.
IF WE COULD RATES HOLD ON
ADDITIONAL WELLS THAT GET
TESTED.
.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT.
LEAKS FROM ABANDONED IDA WELLS.
CONTRIBUTORS ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE.
METHANE POLLUTION THE STATE.
I BELIEVE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
THE STATE INVESTIGATE LEAKAGE
FROM THESE THOUSANDS OF IDLE IN
BAND AND WELLS IN EFFORT TO
QUANTIFY THE PROBLEM BY BUILDING
AN ACCURATE DATABASE OF LEAKAGE
LEVELS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SHARON MEMBERS DON'T WE GO
COURSE PROCLAIM THEIR SUPPORT.
WILL VARY WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENCE MAKERS
ASK BY THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ASTHMA COLLABORATIVE TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT.
CAO JUSTICE URKEL CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
IT'D JUST MULLIN FROM NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SAYING NINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
AND.
YOU CAN STAY HERE.
ACTUALLY WHAT.
COME OUT OF IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
REALLY SUCH AS WITH THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
REGRETTABLY ARE OPPOSED TO A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE ALTERNATE
STAFF.
HAVING AN OPEN DOOR POLICY AND
HAVING A ROBUST CONVERSATION ON
THE ISSUE.
BUT YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE AN EXTENSIVE ARE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS RELATIVE
TO I DON'T WELL SUBJECT TO THE
STRINGENT MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER FEDERAL
STATE.
AND SOME LOCAL PROGRAMS OUT TO
BEGIN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THE
US EPA GREENHOUSE GAS REPORTING
PROGRAM COVERS EMISSION FROM
MULTIPLE ASPECTS OF THEOIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY UNDER THIS PROGRAM
OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF WILES.
AND RELATED EQUIPMENT MUST
REPORT THE COMBINED EMISSIONS
FOR ALL WELLS THAT THEY OWN AND
OPERATE.
WITHIN EACH PRODUCTION BASE AND.
THESE PROGRAMS REQUIRE ANNUAL
REPORTING A OF THEIR CO TWO AND
METHANE EMISSIONS. BASED ON
MEASUREMENTS OF FUELING PRODUCE
GAS THIS INFORMATION IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE I DON'T WANT TO GET ON
THE NEW ONCE IT'S ON THE
CALIFORNIA SIGN MY COUNTERPART
IT'S A BILL WILL COVER THOSE.
BUT THERE IS.
IDA WELLS ARE SUBJECT TO
SECTION NINE FIVE SIX SIX EIGHT
OF THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS SPECIFIC TO LEAK
DETECTION AND REPAIR. WHICH SUCH
EXTENSIVE REQUIREMENTS FOR OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION FACILITIES
THEY INCLUDE AUDIO VISUAL
INSPECTION. THAT IS REQUIRED ON
A DAILY OR WEEKLY BASIS FOR ALL
EQUIPMENT.
ON ON THE LOCAL AIR PROGRAMS.
.
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION DISTRICT WHERE OVER
EIGHTY PERCENT OF OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION OCCURS IN THE STATE.
REQUIRES QUARTERLY INSPECTIONS
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR
REQUIREMENTS THAT LIGHT OIL
PRODUCTION.
FACILITIES
AND AT THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
THEY REQUIRE FACILITIES OPERATE
UNDER THE DISTRICT.
PERMIT TO ANNUAL REPORT
EMISSIONS FROM ALL THEIR
EQUIPMENT.
IN ADDITION ANY DISTRICT WITH.
LOCATION SELECTED BY THE ARB
WILL DEPLOY A COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND MAY
REQUIRE STATIONARY SOURCE TO
DEPLOY FENCE LINE MONITORING
SYSTEM OR OTHER APPROPRIATE REAL
TIME. ONSITE MONITORING IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT EXISTING
PROJECTS PLANNED TO TRACK
COMMISSION THINK COMMUNITIES.
THE ARB IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING
PROJECTS TO BETTER CHARACTERIZE
AIR QUALITY COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL
AND GAS OPERATIONS LIKE THAT
SNAPS PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDE WILL PROVIDE A
BETTER ARE A BIT MORE CLEAR
PICK.
EXCUSE ME PICTURE ARE ON ON THE
ISSUES.
TO FOCUSING ON JUST OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION SITES ESPECIALLY ON
IDLE WELLS.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX DOES
ACKNOWLEDGE OTHER COMMENT
SOURCES OF POLLUTION THAT EXIST
WITHIN THE PROXIMITY OF CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES. SO THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY NOT ADDRESSING A BIG
PICTURE ON THE COMMITTEES
EXPOSURE TO COME IT CUMULATIVE
POLLUTION SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS P. ANTHONY THOMAS TRIPS
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS I'VE. I'VE READ THE
BILL. A FEW TIMES AND I'VE READ
THE ANALYSIS IS A COUPLE TIMES
AND I'M.
STILL NOT EXACTLY SURE.
WHAT PROBLEM THIS BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE NOW THE
PROPONENTS DID A VERY?
NICE JOB IN IN SAYING ABOUT
POLLUTION AND AN. IDOL WELLS
AND.
AND AND THE BALANCE OF THE WELL
THAT THAT WE HAPPEN I'M STILL
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO DO.
ANY POLICY ENVIRONMENT MEMBERS
THE FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE
THE SECOND QUESTION IS WHAT IS
THE HISTORY THAT THIS BILL IS IN
REACTION TO IF YOU CAN'T SOLVE
WERE ANSWER THOSE TWO QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE BILL.
NOW ARMY TWENTY SEVENTEEN CARP
OWN COMPLETED A NEW REGULATIONS
FOR MONITORING AND A REDUCTION
OF METHANE EMISSIONS.
BOB APPALLING AND NATURAL GAS
PRODUCTION FACILITIES WHICH
INCLUDES BOTH ACTIVE.
AS WELL AS IDLE WELLS.
THE BILL WOULD MANDATE
ADDITIONAL TESTING.
AS THE PROPONENTS ATTEMPTED TO
SAY THAT WE WOULD ALSO COMMENDED
AND INDICATE.
BUT THE OPERATORS AT THE
DIRECTION OF DR FOR I'D WELL
DONE A PRESIDENT IS SCHEDULED TO
BE PLUGGED.
AND A BAND
SEX INTO A STATES PERFORM
APPROPRIATE TESTING AS
DETERMINED BY THE SUPERVISOR OF
ANY WEALTH AND ASSOCIATED
EQUIPMENT.
BEING PLUGGED IN ABANDONED TO
DETERMINE
THE PRESENCE OF ATMOSPHERIC
EMISSIONS HYDROCARBON POLLUTANTS
BEFORE THE INITIATION OF AND
AFTER THE COMPLETION OF PHYSICAL
WORK.
IS CURRENTLY BEING DONE.
IT'S CURRENTLY BEING DONE.
NOW.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE TO
BUILD IT STEP AHEAD A CHANCE TO
WORK ON STATUE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
DID CHANGE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
OPERATORS MANAGE THEIR IDYLLWILD
INVENTORIES.
OPERATORS NOW HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO ENTER INTO A
TITLE WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN
AND IT DOES REQUIRE MEMBERS.
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT OF A
PERCENT OF IDYLLWILD ON A YEAR
TO YEAR BASIS.
PARTICULATE XIN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE AND
THEN AB SIX
S. ONE SIX ONE SEVEN BOTH AREN'T
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH THE LET'S
REPEAL THOSE DECISIONS AND PUT
EVERYTHING THAT. THAT WAS IN
THOSE PROVISIONS.
AND WHAT THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX
HAS THE TEMPERAMENT DO AND IT'S
MAKING A BILL.
LET'S NOT REPEAT WHAT HAS
ALREADY GONE ON.
LET'S NOT BE REPETITIVE MEMBERS
NOT BE REDUNDANT.
JUST BECAUSE.
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH A
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY IN THE
STATE.
AND AS I CLOSE I'M ONLY
REFERENCE OVER REGULATION THIS
IS THE PRIME EXAMPLE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE WHAT
PERCENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN SO I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
ONE IT'S.
WELL IS THAT ARE TO BE PLUGGED.
ARE TESTED PRIOR TO THAT TAKING
PLACE SO.
DOES THIS
THIS SEEMS LIKE IT PROLONGS.
THAT ACTION THAT NOW YOU HAVE TO
STOP RATHER THAN GOING HAD
IMPLIED THAT YOU HAVE TO WAIT
AND GO THROUGH THE STEPS OF
DOING THE TESTING RATHER THAN
JUST.
DOING WHAT YOU SET OUT TO DO.
CAN YOU JUST.
COMMENT ON THAT SURE A. WHAT THE
BILL DOES?
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO DO IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN AND
AROUND WITHIN A QUARTER MILE.
SO IT'S BEEN VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
THE DISTANCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
A ABANDONED WELLS IDA WELLS THAT
ARE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT THE A
REVIEW OF THESE WELLS TESTING.
TO BE VERY CLEAR OF WHAT KIND
OF.
HYDROCARBONS EMISSIONS THAT ARE
COMING FROM THE POLLUTANTS THAT
ARE COMING FROM THESE PARTICULAR
WELLS THAT ARE CLOSE AS I SAY TO
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD
SENATE'S.
WITH THAT GOAL IN MIND AND THERE
ARE SOME TESTING THAT'S BEEN
DONE THAT'S TO BE SURE THERE
BEEN A NUMBER OF BILLS IN RECENT
TIMES TO ADDRESS THAT. HA BUT
THIS BILL IS LOOKING TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE LASER TO IN ITS
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS.
ABANDONED WELLS NOT A WELL
CENTER CLOSE TO RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS AND BE SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT IS COMING OUT OF
THOSE WELLS INDICATES.
ACTUALLY LEAKING INTO THE GROUND
AND INTO THE ATMOSPHERE. AND TO
PROVIDE MORE DATA THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO. OUT TO THE PUBLIC
AND NOW TURN TO THE SPONSORS TO.
ADD ON TO THAT IF THAT'S AN AND
I ASK BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE
IS ALREADY TESTING THAT IS
REQUIRED.
OF NEARLY ALL OF THESE WELLS SO
I'M JUST.
I'M NOT SEEING HOW THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT. WOULD
CHANGE WHAT'S ALREADY BEING
DONE.
FIGURES OWNER TIM O'CONNOR FOR
THE VIRAL DEFENSE FUND SO YOUR
CRACK THERE ARE TESTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED OF WELLS.
THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS OF OF
BEING ABANDONED HER THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS FOR AIR EMISSIONS
TESTING IN PARTICULAR WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE PROCESS OF AN
AMENDMENT YOU CAN TAKE WEEKS IF
NOT MONTHS TO BE.
PERFORMED.
ONE OF THESE AIR TESTS CAN TAKE.
BETWEEN FIFTEEN MINUTES IN ONE
HOUR A TO BE CONDUCTED.
SO IT IS MEANT TO CAPITALIZE ON
ALL THAT WORK IN MANPOWER THAT
IS ALREADY GOING TO BE THE SITES
TO CONDUCT A TEST.
WHERE IT WILL NOT IMPACT THE?
THE LONGEVITY OF THE OF THE
PLUCKING PROCESS SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL HAS A PROVISION THAT
SAYS NOTHING.
SHALL IMPEDE O. OR PREVENT.
OPERATIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO.
MAINTAIN A SAFE OPERATION OR
TWO.
THEY WILL IMPEDE THE SAFETY OF
OF WELL SO VARIES SPECIFICALLY.
THERE'S A CARD IN THE BILL FOR
THAT.
AND WE DO NOT EXPECT IT WILL
ACTUALLY INCREASE ANY OF THE
TIME.
FOR THE POINT OF.
INITIATION TO COMPLETION FROM
ANY WEB LOGGING OPERATION.
WHO?
I WANTED TO TURN INTO A DIALOGUE
CHO INTEREST BE RESPECTFUL OF
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A VERY BIG
AGENDA I'M JUST.
.
SO I HAVE.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COULD OWN QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NONE.
HIT IDEA ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MO MOVEMENT SECONDED.
.
THIS HOLDEN WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I THINK IT WAS SECURING
COMMITTEE.
THIS'S
FOR AN AREA THAT WE BELIEVE
AGAIN NEEDS.
.
SPECIFIC FOCUS I THINK GOOD BILL
IS VERY TARGETED IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
HOLDEN AYE UP AS A FELLOW MEMBER
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES.
KEY ISSUES OF VITAL AND
ABANDONED WELLS ARE.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AS WE ALL
KNOW.
NOT JUST IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA BUT THE BUT STATE AND SO.
GOOD BILL AND I.
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE.
ITEM THIRTY FOUR A. B. THIRTY
ONE FORTY SIX BY MEMBER HOLD ON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND PRO
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS WERE UP TO
JULY MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA
CHILD.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN FLORA LOAN FROM.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOTORIOUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
THREE ONE THREE ONE GOES ON CALL
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER SALAS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
THE PRESENT BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
BUT BEFORE I BEGIN LET ME FIRST.
.
STATE THAT'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF'S WORK
ON THAT THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT.
AND.
WITH THAT AYE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE THE
AIR B. IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY.
QUANTIFYING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS RESULTING FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
FUND INVESTMENTS INTERPOL THE
PROGRAMS
AS THE STATE CONTINUED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN AIR
POLLUTION REDUCTION PROGRAMS
WITH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN GRANTS AVAILABLE.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IT
IS CRITICAL TO IDENTIFY WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE.
IN REDUCING AIR POLLUTION
EXPOSURE WHICH.
ARE AND WHICH ONES ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
IMPROVING.
AIR QUALITY OF PUBLIC HEALTH A
QUITE SIMPLY MEMBERS IS THAT.
WE'RE GETTING OUR MOST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK IN HOUSE AT IMPACTING
PUBLIC HEALTH WOOD CARVEL
FORGETTING THE DATA THAT WE NEED
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH CHEESE PARA
FUNDING WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR.
AND WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
SAY NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MOTION MADE AND SECONDED THIS
BILL DOES ENJOY IT.
SUPPORT SUPPORT. REGULATION.
SELFLESS LIKE CLOTHES.
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
CALL CALL PLEASE
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY MEMBERS SOLACE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS WERE NOT SO
CHEAP HIGH.
WHERE THIRTY AYE ACOSTA? CHILD
SHALL I EGGMAN FLORA. DAMONE
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE STONE.
FOUR ZERO.
RIGHT BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE MS CABALLERO WHO IS
NOT HERE OKAY AND.
.
SHE'S ON HER WAY OUR RIGHT HERE
SHE AS ALRIGHT PERFECT TIMING.
SO MS AVITAL HAS THREE BILLS.
.
I DON'T TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE WHERE WE GO IN
THE.
FILED ORDER.
THAN ITEM THIRTY AB THIRTY
FIFTEEN.
AND THEN ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY.
ACOSTA.
NO IT IS.
YES IS WONDERFUL.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
ALL OF US ARE AWARE OF THE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES OF THE
TO HAVE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES BUT THERE
ARE LESSONS TO BE LEARNED. WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE MILLION DEAD. OR
DYING TREES IN OUR FOREST AND WE
KNOW THAT OUR FORESTS ARE OVERLY
DANCE HISTORICALLY THERE WERE
FOUR HUNDRED. FORTY TREES TO AN
ACRE NOW THERE ARE SEVERAL
HUNDRED TREES TO PER ACRE.
IN ORDER TO RESTORE OUR FOREST'S
TO A HEALTHIER MORE RESILIENT
STATE WE NEED TO REMOVE THE
EXCESS FUEL. THEN OUR FOREST SO
THAT THE REMAINING TREES CAN
GROW BIGGER. TALLER AND STRONGER
AND INCREASE BOTH THE PACE AND
SCALE OF THE WORK WE ARE DOING
TO ADDRESS THE DENSITY PROBLEM.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE IS
BASED UPON A BILL OF RIGHTS
ESTABLISHED BY CAL EPA FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMIT SUBMITTERS.
MY BILL DOES NOT BYPASS ANY SICK
STEPS IN THE TIMBER HARVESTING
PLAN REVIEW PROCESS FOR
ELIMINATE ANY SAFEGUARDS HE
MAKES THE REVIEW.
MORE EFFICIENT
BY REDUCING SUBMISSION ERRORS
THROUGH USE OF A CHECKLIST THAT
INCLUDES WHAT. CONSTITUTES AN
ACCEPTED TEACH P..
A TIMBER HARVEST PLAN AND BY
CREATING EFFICIENCIES IN REVIEW%
TIME BY ENCOURAGING AGENCIES TO
INCLUDE MITIGATION MEASURES FOR
ADDITIONAL PERMITS.
THE SPONSORS AND STAFF MET
SEVERAL TIMES WITH THE
COMMITTEES CONSULTANTS AND CAL
FIRE AS WELL AS THE SIERRA CLUB
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS.
CONCERNS RAISED.
THOSE AMENDMENTS RESULTED IN A
REWRITE OF THE BILL CONTAINED IN
THE APRIL SIXTEENTH VIRGIN
VERSION. I HAVE ALSO AGREED TO
AN ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT TO
ADDRESS A FINAL CONCERN RAISED
BY COMMITTEE STAFF AND HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE THEIR
CONCERNS AND TODAY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. WITH ME I HAVE
SEVERAL WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. RICH GORDON
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CALIFORNIA'S ANDREA HOWELL
SIERRA PACIFIC INDUSTRIES AND
CHRIS MERTON'S SIERRA BUSINESS
COUNCIL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SAID DE I'M
HERE IS PRESIDENCY
CALIFORNIA SUN THE SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY SUPPORTED AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO WHICH AMONG OTHER
THINGS CREATED A ONE PERCENT
ASSESSMENT ON LUMBER PRODUCTS
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THE DEDICATED FUNDING FROM THIS
SOURCE IS USED TO SUPPORT THE
ACTIVITIES AND COSTS.
OF THE DEPARTMENTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE REVIEW OF PROJECTS ARE
ERMITS NECESSARY TO CONDUCT
TIMBER HARVEST OPERATIONS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
WOULD ALIGN PERFECTLY WITH THE
INTENT OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO.
THE FORCE PRACTICES ASK ACT
PROVIDES FOR REVIEW OF TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN IN AS LITTLE AS
SEVENTY ONE DAYS.
HOWEVER THE REPORT UNTIL
REGULATION AND FORCED
RESTORATION.
NOTED IN THAT REVIEW THAT THE
REVIEW TIME IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AVERAGE A HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
DAYS.
SEVENTY ONE PREDICTED HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN DAYS ACTUAL IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND THAT WAS
AN INCREASE.
HAVE FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN ONE OF
TOOK A HUNDRED SEVEN DAYS.
THIS INCREASE IN THE TIME OF
PROCESSING A IS IN SPITE OF THE
FOLLOWING.
ONE.
THE NUMBER OF TEACH PEACE
SUBMITTED FOR CONSIDERATION
DECREASED IN THOSE YEARS. BY
SIX.
TO.
THE NUMBER OF ACRES TO BE
TREATED WAS REDUCED IN THOSE
YEARS BY TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES.
AND THREE. THE NUMBER OF STAFF
IN THE DEPARTMENT'S INCREASED BY
TWENTY FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS.
EVEN AFTER TV APPROVAL.
TEACH FEW SUBMITTERS MUSLIM
SEEK ADDITIONAL PERMITS TO DELAY
CAN STREAM THAT ALTERATION
AGREEMENTS AND PERMITS
ASSOCIATED WITH NONPOINT
SOLUTION DISCHARGES.
THIS OFTEN EXTENDS THE REVIEW
TIME WELL BEYOND A HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN DAYS.
WHY IS TIME IMPORTANT?
THE PUBLIC POLICY IS TO
CALIFORNIA THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OF ALL DESCRIBE
OUR FORESTS AS BEING IN CRISIS
YOU'D EXCESS FUEL.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE IN ORDER
TO RESTORE FOREIGN TRIP FORCED
RESILIENCY.
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
CATASTROPHIC FIRE. AND MEET OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS.
YEAH AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
WOULD PROVIDE ASSURANCE FOR
TIMELINESS IN PLAN REVIEW.
WITHOUT REDUCING A SINGLE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
WHEN REPEAT THAT.
WITHOUT REDUCING A SINGLE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE CALLS FOR
EFFICIENCY IN THE PROTECTION OF
OUR ENVIRONMENT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
VERY MUCH IN THIS CUP AT ALL OF
YOUR WITNESSES SAKE OF THIS BILL
DOES ENJOY A SUPPORT SUPPORT. I
THINK ASIAN.
AS THE AT ANDREA HOW A SIERRA
PACIFIC INDUSTRIES GLAD TO BE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND. GIVEN THE
COMMENTS JUST THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
TECH CHRIS MEARNS WITH THE
SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL OVER
SUPPORTING THE BILL FOR TWO
REASONS ONE IS.
BEFORE TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
RESTORING OUR FORESTS WE NEED TO
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR THE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO HELP OFFSET THE COST
RESTORATION. WERE ALSO SEEN THIS
BILL IS A JOB CREATOR IN RURAL
AREAS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE OF
THE FOREST PRODUCTS INDUSTRY.
AND THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
URGENT ABOUT THANK YOU YOU.
JULIAN ALLEN ASK BOBBY HAVE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE WE
HAVE TO FOR CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE CALCULATIONS
FORCE ASSOCIATION ALL
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRIS MCKAY
WE ON BEHALF OF MENDOCINO IN
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT.
RAIN THOMPSON WITH RECURSIVE
CLIENTS APART.
FAILURE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
VINCENT WHAT MODULE WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON PATH I TREAD
POWER SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
STACY HERO COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
LISTEN SINCE IN THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND.
REX W. HIME WITH CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS ROBERT
SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION SUPPORT.
KELLY BOY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LOW CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ERIK
KARLSSON ASSOCIATED CALIFORNIA
LOGGERS AND SPORT.
THANK YOU ANY HOME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FOR.
MR CHAIRING COMMITTEE AND.
.
MISS CABALLERO WE.
ORIGINALLY WERE COMING
APPEARANCE IN OPPOSITION BUT THE
BILL HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
AMENDED AND WE APPRECIATE WHAT
THE STAFF HAS DONE AND WHAT YOUR
STAFF HAS DONE IS CABALLERO AND
THE ON IN THE US SPONSOR SO.
WILL BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THINK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION OR REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I WRITE SAYING NONE.
MS COMBAT ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR.
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK CAREER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
IT WITH EMOTION. OKAY MOTIONS
BEEN MADE AND SECONDED ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
I DON'T TRY FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE BY MEMBER CABALLERO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE REFUGEE
AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIRAY THIS.
VARIOUS YE STONE.
SIX ZERO SIX THE BILL ON OUR.
NOBODY'S.
OKAY.
SIX.
HERE OKAY SIX ZERO THE BILL WAS
OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY AB THIRTY FIFTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING I
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON THE INTENT
LANGUAGE FIVE THAT WAS SAM.
LATE BLOOMING. AYE AB THIRTY
FIFTEEN WILL ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEED TO PLAN FOR A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OF OUR
FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
AND SUPPLY CHAINS FROM OUR
CURRENT DIESEL BASED TECHNOLOGY
SWORDS AT ZERO AND NEAR ZERO
ADMISSION EMISSIONS FUTURE. THIS
WILL BE A COMPLEX AND EXPENSIVE
PROCESS AND NOT WITHOUT SOME
CONTROVERSY BUT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION INCLUDING A WHOLE.
THINK YOU THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
IT TRANSLATE TRANSITION NEEDS TO
OCCUR.
IT WILL BE A COMPLEX AND
EXPENSIVE BUT IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT IT BE PLANNED AND
IMPLEMENTED WITH OUR INDUSTRY
AND LABOR PARTNERS AT THE TABLE.
AND THAT WHEN WE INVEST STATE
DOLLARS INTO NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
IN NEW EQUIPMENT THAT WE DO IT
WITH A WELL THOUGHT OUT IN
STRATEGIC PLAN. OTHERWISE WE RUN
THE RISK OF SETTLING THOSE WHO
ULTIMATELY PAY FOR INVESTMENTS
IN OUR PORTS. THE OWNERS OF
EXPORTS AND IMPORTS OF CARGO
THAT GETS SHIPPED WITH
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND JEOPARDIZE
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF OUR
PORTS.
AS YOU ARE ALL WELL AWARE
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ARE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH HEAVY
INTEREST IN AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND INVESTMENT
IN OUR PORT GATEWAYS CAN SUPPORT
AND GROW JOBS ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE KNOW TOO
WELL THAT INCREASED TRADE
BARRIERS CAN CAUSE REAL HARM.
INCREASES IN THE COST OF TRADE
CAN ALSO OCCUR AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND AB THIRTY FIFTY
FIFTEEN WILL HELP TO AVOID THIS.
WE CAN ALL ANTICIPATE THAT WE
WILL HAVE MORE COSTLY PART
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT
COSTS BUT WITH GOOD PLANNING AND
LONG TERM INVESTMENTS WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT ARE ZERO. THEIR
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSIONS
WILL HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
JOBS AND LIGHTS IN BOTH RURAL
CALIFORNIA IN INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
NEIGHBORING OUR PORTS WE HAVE
RECENTLY RECEIVED COMMUNICATIONS
OF CONCERN FROM LABOR AND WILL
WORK TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
IF THE BILL PROP.
PROCEEDS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
AND WITH ME TODAY IS MY TAKE UP.
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIGHT TAKE WITH PMS I.
ON OUR INDUSTRY IS VERY PROUD OF
THE WORK WE'VE DONE.
TODAY WITH RESPECT TO EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND ACHIEVED REAL.
IMPROVEMENTS.
SURROUNDING THE PORTS LA LONG
BEACH OAKLAND IN PARTICULAR WITH
RESPECT INTRODUCTION OF.
CONVENTIONAL BEST AVAILABLE
CONTROL TECHNOLOGY.
EQUIPMENT IN EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THE NEXT STEP IS
MOVING TOWARDS ZERO NEAR ZERO
MISSION SOLUTIONS TO FURTHER.
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS SOME OF
THOSE.
A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT AND WE
DEVELOPMENTS HAVE ALREADY
OCCURRED. THAT'S OVER TERMINALS
BUT MOST OF NOT. THEY WILL BE
SUBJECT TO FUTURE ROAMING MAKING
BY THEIR RESOURCES BOARD BUT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAMARO.
WILD OUT VERY CLEARLY.
THE SUCCESS AGAIN BE RELYING ON
FUTURE INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL.
THAT IS BE A PLAN FOR IN HIS BE
PAID FOR.
AND THAT'S A DISCUSSION THAT
NEEDS TO BE HAD IN EARNEST WE
HAVE TO PLANNING PRINCIPLES.
BEEN OUR RD ENCAPSULATED IN AND
STATE LAW IN THE FREE MOBILITY
PLAN THAT CALTRANS DOES AND THEN
THE CLINCHER SCOPING PLAN UPDATE
WOULD LIKE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THOSE PLANS MOVING FORWARD BASED
ON TECHNICAL ANALYSIS.
TRANSIT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RIGHT
THERE IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING MATSON NAVIGATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAVE FIRST
TO BUY ONE I'M LATE I WITH THEIR
OPPOSITION SO I WANNA BE CLEAR
ON THAT ONE AT THINGS COMING ERA
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FULLER AND
FOR. COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS THE BILL TO TALK WITH
US SO WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
BILL MOVE FORWARD. BY WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE BILL I
HAD THAT WE THINK THAT THOSE
CONCERNS COULD BE ADDRESSED.
I IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE SAW WHAT
THAT WE ASKED AT THE BILL MOVE
OR THINK YOU OKAY AND JUST FOR
THE RECORD SAKE I MIGHT HAVE
MISSED IT BUT COULD YOU
IDENTIFY.
YES I WANT ANYTHING THAT OUR
CAPITAL. HEREBY REPRESENT AND I
I'LL W. LOCUST THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE NINE FOR THE PORT WORKERS
OUT OF AYE LA LAW BEACH AND SEND
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
MS EGGMAN.
OTHER THAN. I THINK I JUST WET
MY QUESTION AND MAYBE I'M MAYBE
I'M JUST WRONG BUT BUT. THIS
CITY OF STOCKTON INSIDIOUS
ARGUMENT IN STOCK AND WE HAVEN'T
INLAND PORT IN THIS REPORT
CONTINUES REFER TO SEAPORTS.
BUT I'M I'M ASSUMING EVERYBODY
WILL IT BE INCLUDED IN THIS YEAH
AT THE.
EVERYONE OF INCLUDED AND AND
AND ONE PORTS ARE INCLUDED IN
THE SYSTEM AFRAID ACTION PLAN.
IT UP BY THE STATE THERE'S.
FOUR DIFFERENT WAYS IN THE
HARBORS NAVIGATION GO TO CREATE
A CORD AND WE INTEND TO INCLUDE
ALL OF US.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU. ENOUGH FOR
THEM COME A COUP COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
XENA AND.
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS A COUPLE
AT ALL FOR US.
AGAIN BRING IN THIS.
FORWARD I APPRECIATE HOW.
IN PARTICULAR I. SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT THE I'LL W. IS
RAISING AND SO I. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO ADDRESS THEIR.
ISSUES RELATED TO AUTOMATION.
.
BUT WITH.
THAT COMMITMENT TO I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AYE VOTE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. CLOSE.
AGAIN I MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTY AB THIRTY FIFTEEN BY
CABALLERO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT FIFTEEN AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMON.
LET ALONE I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S BELINDA'S IRENAEUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE. STONE AYE.
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO THE BILLS
OUT.
NEXT WE HAVE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT.
AB THIRTY THIRTY WHICH ATTACKS
POVERTY IN EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE DESIGNATED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BY CREATING
MARKET MARKET CONDITIONS FOR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAPITAL TO
REACH COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED
BY CHRONIC POVERTY THESE REALLY.
THE OPPORTUNITY ZONES ARE THE
POOREST OF THE POOR IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
RECENT STUDIES INDICATE THE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
POVERTY WITH OVER TWENTY PERCENT
OF OUR RESIDENTS IMPACTED WE
NEED THE NATION FOR CHILDREN
LIVING IN POVERTY TOO. MANY
RESIDENTS IN OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
ARE BELOW THE POVERTY LINE WHILE
URBAN COASTAL AREAS OF THE STATE
HAVE BEEN A FATE BENEFITTED FROM
AN ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION SINCE
OUR GREAT RECESSION.
AB THIRTY THIRTY MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S POOREST AREAS AN
ATTRACTIVE OPPORTUNITIES OWN
FUND INVESTMENT AS CALIFORNIA
COMPETES FOR FUNDS NATIONALLY
WITH EVERY OTHER PROJECT SEEKING
OPPORTUNITY FUND INVESTMENTS.
THE LACK ABOUT ACCESS TO
INVESTMENT CAPITAL PRECLUDES
POOR COMMUNITIES FROM ADDRESSING
ISSUES LIKE BUSINESS STARTS
HOUSING AVAILABILITY BLIGHT AND
OUT ULTIMATELY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH. THIS LACK OF
ACCESS TO INVESTMENT CAPITAL
KEEPS POOR PEOPLE POOR.
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS TAPPED
INTO A SIX TRILLION DOLLAR
MARKET OF UNREALIZED CAPITAL
GAINS HELD BY CORPORATIONS AND
IN INDIVIDUALS.
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OPERATE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS WILL
CLOSE IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
SO THERE'S A VERY SHORT WINDOW
FOR COMMUNITIES TO WORK WITH
THESE FUNDS AND BRING IN PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY WILL
SEEK OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITIES
OWN FUNDS AND ALREADY EIGHTEEN
STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA HAVE
TRACKS THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
BY THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT
OF TREASURY. CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
DESIGNATED TRACKS ARE
COMMUNITIES DEFINED BY THE
GOVERNOR AS MOST IN NEED OF
INFUSION OF INVESTMENT CAPITAL.
BECAUSE THEIR CENSUS TRACTS THAT
SUBURB SUPPER FROM ABJECT
POVERTY.
BUT HAVE FIT CONDITIONS SUCH AS
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR THE RAPID
REDEVELOPMENT A BLIGHTED
NEIGHBORHOOD.
SO LET ME JUST SAY THAT AS WE
LOOK AT THE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
EVERY MEMBER HERE ON THIS
COMPACT AT COMMITTEE IT
COMMITTEE. WELL BENEFIT IF ABLE
TO ATTRACT INVESTMENT CAPITAL
FROM OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS.
AND EIGHTY SIXTY SIX ZONE TRACKS
ARE LOCATED NEAR WEST CARSON IN
EIGHTY SIXTY SEVEN IT'S THE AREA
SURROUNDING PARRIS VALLEY IN
WINCHESTER. FORTY NINE ITS
DESIGNATED SMALL PORTIONS OF
EAST EL MONTE.
THIRTY SEVEN FILMORE AND SANTA
PAULA.
TWENTY NINE TWIN LAKES SANTA
CRUZ MARINA AND SEASIDE.
FORTY SEVEN.
UP OF FONTANA RIALTO BLOOMINGTON
SAN BERNADINO COLTON AND LOW MY
VEST LOMA LINDA.
THIRTEEN STOCKTON AND FRENCH
CAP.
CAMP
BUT TWELVE.
EAST STOCKTON INTERLOCK MODESTO
AND KEYS.
AND OH SEVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY ZONE EXTENDS FROM
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO DARDEN IN
FLORIN AREAS ALMOST FORTY
PERCENT OF THE DIST AT THE
DISTRICT THE ENTIRE DISTRICT.
DIEM IN PIC IMPACT OF INVESTMENT
CAPITAL REACHING NEIGHBORHOOD
SEPARATE SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC
POVERTY CANNOT BE UNDER UNDER
ESTIMATED.
THE LOCAL INITIATIVES SUPPORT
CORPORATION OR LISK IS A
NATIONAL SOCIAL ENTERPRISE THAT
INVESTS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
POOR COMMUNITIES.
AND ITS C. E. O. MORRIS MAURICE
JONES IS AN ADVOCATE ADVOCATE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY ZONES
BECAUSE HE HAS SEEN FIRSTHAND.
THE IMPACT OF LISTS.
INVESTMENT IN POOR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN THEY'D HEAVILY INVESTED IN
REHABBING IN NEW CONSTRUCTION A
PROPERTIES AND POOR COMMUNITIES
THOSE AREAS PERFORMED BETTER ON
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH. WITH MORE PRE
PEOPLE WORKING AT HIGHER WAGES
PREEMIE BRINGING CAPITAL BACK
INTO THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
RATHER THAN INTO OTHER ACT
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT THEY FOUND
IS THAT THE MEDIAN INCOME ROSE
WHEN THERE WAS A HEAVY
INVESTMENT. OF LESS.
INVESTMENTS.
WITH A DEMONSTRATED CONNECTION
BETWEEN FILE LEVELS OF
INVESTMENT CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
IN NEIGHBORHOOD THAT SUFFER
CHRONIC POVERTY IT'S NO SURPRISE
THAT LIST IS EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN PROGRAM IT'S A
FEDERAL DESIGNATION.
AND AS I SAID CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY ON BOARD WITH THE
DESIGNATE THAT DOES DESIGNATING
ALL OF OUR TO OUR DISTRICTS.
AB THIRTY THIRTY WAS RECENTLY
AMENDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES AN OPPORTUNITY ZONES
WILL NOT EXPERIENCE AN
INTENTIONAL DISPLACEMENT AND
GENTRIFICATION. AND IMPORTANTLY
LISK DID NOT OBSERVE ANY
GENTRIFICATION IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE IT MADE ITS
INVESTMENT.
BUT IS SEEING A DIVERSITY AMONG
ITS INCOME EARNERS.
GOVERNOR BROWN IS ALREADY JOIN
THE FIGHT AGAINST POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA BY VOLUNTARILY
SUBMITTING THESE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE TRACKS NOW IT'S
TIME TO GIVE THOSE COMMUNITIES A
WIDE BERTH AND ROBUST PLATFORM
TO GO INTO THE MARKETPLACE AND
COMPETE WITH EVERY OTHER STATE.
PROPER TO ENTITIES OWNED FUNDS
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH
DONE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY ONE FOR
BRING THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
FORWARD TO COMBAT. POVERTY IN
OUR STATE AND ALSO PROVIDE
HOUSING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PURPOSE
CHAU MIGHT ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
YEAH GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED THINKING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HAPPY AT
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
ANY FURTHER.
REX FBI WITH CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN KYLE
JOHNSON CIRCLE CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS A
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
WHAT THE BILL DOES IS CREATE A
CONVOLUTED EXEMPTION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
ARE PUBLICLY DISCLOSED ANALYZE
AND MITIGATE THEIR IMPACTS?
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTED OUT THAT THERE
THERE.
THAT THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE
MUCH UTILITY IN THIS EXEMPTION
SINCE IT'S
PRETTY MUCH GOING TO THE SEQUEL
PROCESS AS.
.
IT ALREADY EXISTS.
AND AND I WOULD NOTE THAT.
SHOULD ANYBODY FAILED TO
ANALYZE OR DISCLOSE OR MITIGATE
ANY IMPACTS THEN THEY COULD BE
LITIGATED FOR USING THE
EXEMPTION AND IT IT'S BASICALLY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE UNDER
EXISTING LAW. OF THE ANALYSIS
ALSO POINTS OUT THAT HOUSING
PROJECTS ALREADY RECEIVED
NUMEROUS EXEMPTIONS ARE UNDER
THE LAW THROUGH AT A STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS BUT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT THERE'S HOT
PROCESSES IN WHICH TO TEAR UP
PROJECTS OFF OF.
GENERAL PLAN YEAH OURS TO MAKE
THE PROCESS GO QUICKER.
THERE'S ALSO THE COMMUNITY PLAN
EXEMPTION FOR PROJECTS WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY PLAN OR CLASS
THIRTY TWO EXEMPTIONS FOR INFILL
PROJECTS SO GIVEN THE THE WORLD
OF OF EXISTING. DEVICES OUT
THERE THAT THAT FOLKS COULD USE
FOR AYE HOUSING THAT HAS NO
IMPACT.
WE WE THINK THAT THAT THIS THAT
THIS
ISN'T.
AS WRITTEN THE BILL WOULDN'T
REALLY BE UTILIZED AYE AND SO WE
URGE A NO VOTE TODAY.
THIS SHOWS THAT IF YOU KINGS AS
A AT THE TABLE BECAUSE I KNOW I
FOR ONE HAVE.
A FEW QUESTIONS.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
CNN OKAY.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS EGGMAN.
TO THIS IT IT SUNSET BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN THE THE FUND RUNS OUT IS
THAT CORRECT CREEK SO THERE IS
SOME EMERGENCY AT.
YEAH I AM.
I THINK THE THE THE THE CRITERIA
THAT YOU DRAFTED WHILE SIMILAR
TO SEQUEL I THINK.
I'M BETTING PROVIDE SOME PRETTY
CLEAR OUTWEIGHS ITS STEPS AWAY
FROM THAT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
BEING ABLE TO GET INVESTMENT IN
THOSE PLEASE COMMUNITIES BETWEEN
TWENTY SIX. PLEASURE NOTED MOST
OF MY BUT MUCH OF MY DISTRICT IS
ALREADY IN THE ZONES.
.
AND WE ARE IN DESPERATE NEED OF
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION MISTER
JONES IF.
THE BILL.
.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH COVERED IN YOUR
OPINION BY EXISTING EXEMPTIONS
THEN WHAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE BILL.
I I JUST THINK THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM AND MOVING FORWARD WITH.
PROPOSALS AGES I THINK IT
COMPLICATES THE CODE IT IT ADDS
MORE LAYERS IN THERE THAT. I
DON'T THINK WE NEED.
YOU KNOW IT DOES SUNSET BUT IT
JUST IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT TO GO FORWARD
WITH AND.
YEAH I AGREE THAT INVESTMENT IN
THESE COMMUNITIES IS GOOD BUT I
DISAGREE.
AND I STE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
THAT WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT I I DISAGREE WITH
THAT THERE AGAINST THE CONCEPT
BEHIND THE BILL AS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS THAT SEEK WHY IS IS
WHAT'S HOLDING UP THESE
INVESTMENTS I AM I THINK. IT'S
WHEN YOU KNOW UP UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THERE'S PLENTY OF
TIME AND WHEN ORDER TO GO
THROUGH PROPER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS GET COMMUNITY BY AND FOR
PROJECTS. AT AND GET THOSE
INVESTMENTS TO OCCUR.
ALRIGHT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SINGH NANDA MS COVERED IT WAS
LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
THIS BILL TODAY WANT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE EXPENDITURE OF
ANY STATE FUNDS. DOESN'T REQUIRE
THE EXPENDITURE OF ANY LOWER
LOCAL. LOCAL FUNDS.
AND.
I KNOW I'VE HEARD. OVER MANY
YEARS THAT.
.
THE SECRET DOESN'T GET USED AS A
TOOL. TO SHUT DOWN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT IN MY REGION.
.
IT'D BEEN USED EVERY TIME TO
DELAY ORDERS TO SHUT DOWN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A TRACK
RECORD RECORD SHOWING UP AND
ARGUING AGAINST ANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BECAUSE TOMORROW
THERE'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY CAN.
TO SOMEHOW DO IT.
THERE IS A.
AB FROM THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
THAT IT ACTUALLY IS AN AN AN
OPINION FROM THEIR EDITORIAL
BOARD HOW.
SEQUENCE BEING USED AS FOR THE
NEWBIES TO SHUT DOWN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND I THINK.
PART OF THE REASON I REALLY
LIKED THIS IDEA AND I'VE BEEN
REALLY WORKING AT TRYING TO
NARROW DOWN. I'M TRYING TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE
INFILL PROJECTS AND TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I AM I MEET REGULARLY WITH
RESIDENTS IN MY REGION AND THE
PRICE OF APARTMENTS HAS GONE
THROUGH THE ROUGH. AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION VERY RECENTLY WHERE
WITHIN THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
.
THIS INDIVIDUAL THAT I TALKED
WITH HER RENT WENT UP A HUNDRED
PERCENT FROM A THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO TWO THOUSAND AND SHE WAS
MOVING GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE OUT
OF TOWN BECAUSE SHE COULD NO
LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE. ON IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WHAT SHE TOLD ME
IS THAT SHE WAS SCARED SHE WAS
EMBARRASSED.
AND SHE WAS.
.
MORTIFIED.
THAT.
SHE WAS IN THIS SITUATION AND I
ASKED HER WHY. WHY WOULD YOU
FEEL THIS WAY WHY WOULD YOU FEEL
LIKE IT'S YOUR FAULT AND SHE
SAID BECAUSE LIKE I FEEL LIKE I
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN AND I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PLAN BETTER?
IT'S DRIVING PEOPLE OUT AND
THEY'RE ASHAMED. THAT THE AB
THEIR HOUSING SITUATION AND SO
WE CAN'T WAIT.
WE HAVE A DESPERATE NEED THAT
THESE ARE THE POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT IT WOULD
PROVIDE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO BRING IN FEDERAL FOR
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN. AND THAT THE
EVIDENCE IS THERE THAT WHEN
THERE'S IN THE INVESTMENT.
PRIVATE INVESTMENT INTO OUR THE
POOREST OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE WAGES GO
UP PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
THERE NEW BUSINESS STARTS IN THE
AREA I THINK WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN AND THE
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
IS VERY SHORT SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ON. TO I THINK TO
ALL OF US BUT IT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE FROM MY COMMUNITY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
.
MS CABALLERO SO I.
AS AS CHAIR DID NOT TO GIVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON ON THIS.
.
BILL I THINK SOME OF THE.
QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT THE BILL.
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED BY MISTER
JONES OF THE SIERRA CLUB AND
ALSO SOME RICE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES.
BUT.
YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
AND RECOGNIZE WHAT YOUR.
DE ATTEMPTING TO DO A TO US
SPUR INVESTMENT VESTMENTS
CRITICALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE QUALIFIED OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
LA AND SO WHILE I'M.
NOT MAKING A RECOMMENDATION ON
THE BILL I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL LOOK AT THE SAME.
TIME.
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD INTO.
CONTINUE ALLOW YOU TO TO WORK
WITH YOUR OPPOSITION.
SO.
MOTION'S BEEN MADE WE NEED A
SECOND.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
THIRTY BY CABALLERO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS A REFER TO LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING Y.
ROUTES WHICH HE AYE ACOSTA AYE
AYE ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
REYES.
STONE.
STONE I.
ZERO SIX A BILLS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
TURN.
THANKS TO.
BECAUSE.
THANK YOU.
MR KILEY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY SIX.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND DIE. FOR
THAT REALLY HELPFUL COOPERATION
IN THIS BILL AND I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AS THE ROLE WHERE.
LAST YEAR WILDFIRES BURNED
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FORTUNE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES OF LAND.
STRONG MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND
RESULTING IN AT LEAST FORTY SIX
LOST LIVES.
THESE FIRES AS WE KNOW DID NOT
REMAIN CONFINED TO ON INHABITED
AREAS THEY THREATEN THE
COMMUNITIES OF LOS ANGELES AND
SANTA ROSA ROSA. PROMPTING
MANDATORY EVACUATIONS
SPARTAN BICU ON THE LIVES OF
MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS.
THE THOMAS FIRE WAS THE LARGEST
FIRE EVER RECORDED IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY BURNING OVER TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A BLAZE BIG
ENOUGH TO ENGULF WASHINGTON DC.
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE PIRATES THE CRISP
EXIST ACROSS OUR STATE NIGHT OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED. IN THOSE
VERY EFFORTS MOVE THE BILL.
ONE MAJOR ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA IS
THE VAST AMOUNT OF UNDER MANAGED
STATE OWNED LAND WITH EXCESS
DEBRIS AND BRUSH THAT POSES A
FIRE HAZARD.
IN MANY AREAS INCLUDING MY OWN
THIS LAND IS DIRECTLY ADJACENT
TO PRIVATELY OWNED OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OWNED PROPERTY.
WELL I THIS STATE OWNED LAND CAN
POSE  SIGNIFICANT FIRE HAZARD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE OFTEN HONEY UNABLE TO
DO ANYTHING TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THESE RISKS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY ALLOWING PRIVATE LAND
ROVERS OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO REQUEST THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO REDUCE SERVICE
FUELS ON STATE LANDS THE LAND
THAT IS WITHIN THREE HUNDRED
FEET OF A STRUCTURE LOCATED ON
PRIVATE. OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OWNED PROPERTY
THE BILL HAS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED WILL REQUIRE THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT TO CONSULT WITH CAL
FIRE AND BEGIN WORKON THE AREA
WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF COMPLETING
ALL THE NECESSARY PLANNING. AND
PERMITS THE SCOPE WOULD BE
LIMITED TO LAND MANAGED BY THE
PARKS DEPARTMENT THAT IS ALSO
FULLY OR PARTIALLY WITHIN A
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA THAT
YOU AMENDMENTS ALSO AT A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET THE BILL. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF WILD
FIRES THAT CONTINUE TO THREATEN
OUR STATE.
THE BILL WILL HELP ASSURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT PUT AT
UNNECESSARY RISK BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS NOT MAINTAINED ITS OWN
LAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK
IN MORE DETAIL. ABOUT THIS BILL
AND THE RISKS IN MY DISTRICT IS
UP BE LUPE RODRIGUEZ THE FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF FOLSOM.
YOU NEED A GOOD AFTERNOON
ACTUALLY I MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SLEEPER
RODRIGUEZ SOME FIRE CHIEF THE
CITY OF FOLSOM.
I DO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL.
AS YOU KNOW FULSOME IS IN AN
AREA THAT.
BORDERS A STATE PARKS LAND AND
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA LANDS
AS.
DESCRIBE WITHIN THE BILL.
AND WE HAVE SOME AREAS THAT ARE
A LITTLE BIT OVER GROUND THAT
ARE.
ADJACENT TO STRUCTURES NOW
WITHIN ANY OF THE CITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOCAL AREAS
NORMALLY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REQUEST OR ACTUALLY REGULATE THE
THE LANDS OWNED BY PRIVATE
OWNERS TO. HAVE SOME DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AROUND THE STRUCTURES UP
TO THE PROPERTY LINE. BUT IN OUR
CASE AS IN MANY OTHER CASES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT EXCEEDS PASSED THE PROPERTY
LINE.
WITH SOME VEGETATION THAT'S
NEAR THE STRUCTURE SO WE'RE
ASKING SOME SUPPORT ON THIS TO
ALLOW THE HOMEOWNERS AND OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CHIEFS AT SUCH
AS MYSELF TO.
HAVE STATE PARKS REGULATE OUR
TAKE CARE OF THAT LAND THAT'S
CLOSE OF STRUCTURES AND
HOPEFULLY PULL LITTLE BIT OF A
BUFFER BETWEEN THE HOMES. AND.
THE VEGETATION THAT'S OF
CONCERN WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A
CLEAR CUT OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
JUST SOME LATTER FUEL REDUCTION
AND OTHER REMOVAL OF SOME OF
THOSE SURFACED FUELS TO ALLOW
THE FIREFIGHTERS TO GET IN THERE
AND AT LEAST TRY TO. PREVENT ONE
OF THOSE FIRES FROM SPREADING
INTO NEIGHBORHOODS AS WE HAD
LAST YEAR SO I WITH THAT I
SUPPORT YOU WILL NOT BE.
OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHIEF
OF FOR.
YOUR ANY FURTHER WITNESSES THIS
BILL DOES HAVE A SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION.
YEAH WE GOT IT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT SO THAT THIS
BILL WILL DEFINITELY HELP
HOMEOWNERS COMPLY WITH EXISTING
LAW BUT ALSO IMPAIR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE A GOOD
NEIGHBOR.
THING.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IN A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED BY
MISTER CRAWLEY WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK BERNADETTE THANKS VERY MUCH.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I DON'T TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX BY MEMBER KILEY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
AYE REFUGEE AYE ACOSTA. AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESIRAY YES.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I. SEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT
THANKFULLY.
ALRIGHT THE NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
DALY ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX AB
THIRTY TWO ZERO ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
LET ME START BY.
HIGHLIGHTING THAT I HAVE AGREED
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE.
OPPOSED BY.
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHICH ARE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
OH OKAY.
THE ISSUE WAS IN THE ANALYSIS
EXCUSE ME.
.
THIS MEASURE ALLOWS LOCAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE INCENTIVE FUNDING.
AS THEY TRANSITION TO A ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT ZERO EMISSION
STATEWIDE TRANSIT BUS FLEET.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
RELEASED TO PROPOSE REGULATORY
CONCEPT TO ACHIEVE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT SYSTEM BY TWENTY FORTY.
THIS LAUDABLE GOAL HAS
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT AND WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET OUR AGGRESSIVE
CLIMATE TARGETS.
WITH THIS WITH TRANSITION WILL
COME ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES
ON TRANSIT AGENCIES.
WHICH ALREADY OPERATE ON SMALL
MARGINS.
PRICE FOR ZERO EMISSION BUS CAN
BE THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MORE EXPENSIVE OF COURSE THAN
CONVENTIONAL BUSES.
AS OF A FEW MONTHS AGO TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN OUR STATE HAD ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN ZERO EMISSION
BUSES IN OPERATION WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED FORTY
ON ORDER.
ALL OF THESE WERE PURCHASED WITH
THE HELP OF INCENTIVE FUNDING
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT INCENTIVE FUNDING.
ON TOP OF THE UP FRONT COST
PRESSURES TO PURCHASE THESE MORE
EXPENSIVE BUSES TRANSIT AGENCIES
MUST ALSO FUND AND CREATE A
COMPLETELY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM.
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A ZERO
EMISSION BUS FULLY.
IT'S VITAL THAT FUNDING REMAIN
AVAILABLE IN ORDER FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO SUCCESSFULLY MAKE
THE RAPID TRANSITION. TO A ZERO
EMISSION BUS FLEET WHICH WE HOPE
THEY WILL DO.
THE LANGUAGE THAT I HAVE.
AGREED TO IN THE AMENDMENT WILL
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL BY
ELIMINATING THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF INCENTIVE FUNDS TO
MEET REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND
REMOVING THE PROPOSED LONG TERM
OUTLOOK INVESTMENT PLAN
RESTORING IT. TO THE CURRENT
ANNUAL REQUIREMENT.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ADDS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LARGE SCALE
DEPLOYMENTS OF TRANSIT BUSES TO
THE LIST OF PROJECTS THAT MAY
RECEIVE THIS ESSENTIAL FUNDING.
WITH ME IS MICHAEL PIEMAN TALL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION. AND MORE
ATOP REPRESENTING THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION. ONE I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE AND FOR
SO ABLY ARTICULATED IN THE
LANDSCAPE THE FUNDING LANDSCAPE
THE MY TRANSIT AGENCY MEMBERS
ARE OPERATING AND.
DISPOSED SIMPLY STATES IT IS
TRANSIT AGENCIES WILL OUT THERE
ZERO EMISSION BUSES AND
ULTIMATELY IMPLEMENT LARGE SCALE
PROJECTS THE STATE SHOULD
CONTINUE PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO THEM. INCLUDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
* BOOK WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
AS A WIN FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES AS
A HELP SOME STRETCHED THEIR
STATE AND FEDERAL FORMULA
DOLLARS WHILE ADVANCING ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES. AND THE
BILL IS ALSO WIN FOR THE TRANST
RIDERS WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM CLEARING PART OF
BUSES ALONGSIDE STRONG TRANSIT
SERVICE.
A VOTE FOR A B. THIRTY TWO A
ONE.
TODAY REAFFIRMED OUR COMMITMENT
TO PROVIDING ROBUST FUNDING TO
SUPPORT YOUR MISSION BUS
DEPLOYMENT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR A TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.  WE CAN ATTEST TO
THE FACT THAT.
THAT MOVING TO CLEANER FLORA
FLEETS IS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
WERE COMMITTED TO IT BUT IT IS
EXPENSIVE. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT AND
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
I'D FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBERTS WHO WAS SHOT HERE AND WE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA'S BIG BLUE BUS THE SANTA
CRUZ METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DISTRICT. THE LOS ANDES THERE
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF WAS ALSO
ASKED TO CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF
GUARDINO TRANSIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE.
OPPOSITION.
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON AT YOUR MERCY
SHE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE I'M
RYAN KENNY WITH CLEAN ENERGY AND
ALSO REPRESENTING THAT YOU WERE
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS A CONFERENCE
CALIFORNIA GAS AND VEHICLE
COALITION. AND THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL HAS A FATAL
FLAW BECAUSE IT IS INSERTING A
NEW PROJECT A CATEGORY LARGE
SCALE ON THE PLANET OF TRANSIT
BUSES. WHERE THERE WASN'T BEFORE
AND?
WITH DUE RESPECT THE AUTHOR
INTO THE SPONSOR WIDGET DID
PROPOSE AN AMENDMENT OF CAPPING
THAT NEW INCLUSION AT NO MORE
THAN TEN PERCENT.
AND IT WAS NOT ACCEPTED AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS CONCLUSION IS
GOING TO BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
AND I THINK THAT'SWHY AIR BE IS
LOOKING UNDER EVERY ROCK FOR
FUNDING AND THAT WILL BE.
THIS IS THAT THE NEW.
VEHICLE TO TO DO SO FOR THE
INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT RULE.
SO WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THERE
ISN'T ANY AYE COST CONTAINMENT.
AND THAT THE EXISTING.
PROJECTS WITHIN THE CLEAN TRUCK
AND BUS.
PROGRAM WILL BE AT A
DISADVANTAGE TO THAT PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS PREFERABLY.
WITH THIS THIS NEW INCLUSION SO
WE DO ASK THAT THE BILL LATIN
NOT GO FORWARD OR AT LEAST BE
AMENDED TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
COST DE CAP.
SO THAT THE OTHER PROJECTS CAN
ENJOY A CERTAINTY AND THAT
BUSINESS THAT.
.
PLANNING CAN CAN CONTINUE
UNINTERRUPTED HOW WE ALSO
BELIEVE THE BILL IS PREMATURE
AND AT THE.
INNOVATIVE CLEAN CHANCE A RULE
AT AIR BE SHOULD FIRST BE
ADOPTED BEFORE A FUNDING
MECHANISMS THAT IS IDENTIFIED
THANK YOU.
I'M CATHERINE PHILLIPS WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
BEEN AN OF OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR TOOK
AND THE WORK THAT THE STAFF DID
IN.
I AM I DO WANNA SAY THAT I THINK
THE REST OF THE BILL IS A IS
GOOD IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO.
A BERKELEY MENTION.
DEPLOYMENTS OF
OF.
FLEETS.
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN ELIGIBLE
BUT THERE'S NO HARM IN MAKING IT
VERY CLEAR ADDITIONALLY JUST SO
YOU ALL KNOW.
ON THE TWENTY FIFTH.
TWENTY FIFTH OF THIS MONTH THE
CARDBOARD WILL BE VOTING ON HOW
TO DISTRIBUTE SOME.
VW SETTLEMENT MONEY AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION IS
TARGETED TO GO TOWARDS TRANSIT
BUSES SCHOOL BUSES.
AND AND THE SOMETHING ELSE SOME
OTHER KIND OF A SHUTTLE BUS.
BETTER ZERO MISSION SO THERE
WILL BE MONEY OUT THERE.
AND SO ALL YOU TRANSIT PEOPLE
GET ONLINE BEFORE THE RULE COMES
OUT NOW'S THE TIME TO DO IT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
AND FOR THEIR OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL.
XENA AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I TO HAVE A QUESTION OF MS
PHILLIPS. IS CLC VIS POSITION IN
OPPOSITION ON THE CEMENT THAT
ARE YOU REQUESTING CERTAIN A
MADMAN SIERRA CLUB IS REMOTE. AT
SORRY AND THAT'S A GOOD
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I FAILED
TO SAY WE'RE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION THREE GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE MISTER
DALY AYE.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
.
YOU'RE.
LEADERSHIP AND HELPING.
.
OR.
ACHIEVE ZERO NEAR ARE ZERO
EMISSION KNOW TRUCK BUS AND OFF
ROAD VEHICLES.
AS WELL AS.
PORT INFRASTRUCTURE.
NIGHT I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THE CLEAN ENERGY IS
ARGUMENTS ABOUT.
PICKING.
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND ALSO.
.
CONCERN RAISED ABOUT.
IN THE ANALYSIS.
ABOUT.
.
THE.
USING THE DOLLARS BREAK FROM
TRADITION IN IN USING THE
DOLLARS FOR.
.
FOR COMPLIANCE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT.
WILL I THINK A OR B. WILL
ULTIMATELY MAKE THE DECISION THE
GOAL HERE.
I MEAN I WAS ON A LOCAL TRANSIT
BOARD IN ORANGE COUNTY. ARM.
THESE.
PUBLICLY FUNDED.
BUS SYSTEMS DON'T HAVE AN
ANALYST'S AMOUNT OF MONEY. TO
BUY EXPENSIVE NEW TECHNOLOGY.
THEY ALREADY SUBSIDIZE THE BUS
FARES WE ALL SUBSIDIZE BUS
FARES.
IN MY DISTRICT.
THERE'S NO ROOM TO RAISE BUS
FARES.
AND.
IN FACT RIDERSHIP IS DECLINING
BECAUSE OF OTHER.
SOCIETAL TRENDS BUT.
IT SEEMS TO ME IF THE STATE IS
GOING TO MANDATE EXPENSIVE NEW
VEHICLES
ST OUGHT TO HAVE A WAY. TO HELP.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
PAY FOR THOSE.
THOSE SO.
THAT NEW TECHNOLOGY.
SO I THINK IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATE'S APPROACH IN THE PAST
WE NEED WE MAY NEED MORE FUNDING
IN THE FUTURE BUT I THINK TO.
TO MAKE LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES
IN ELIGIBLE. TO COMPETE.
.
IS A STEP SIDEWAYS OR BACKWARDS
SO ULTIMATELY A OR B. WILL BE
MAKING THIS DECISION WHETHER YOU
WANT TO CHARACTERIZE IT IS
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS I
WOULDN'T. I WOULDN'T
CHARACTERIZE IT THAT WAY I THINK
IT'S
IT'S ABOUT PROGRESS IN ZERO
EMISSIONS.
I THINK WE WON IT WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE A ARE BE.
TO.
.
TO HELP THESE LOCAL AGENCIES
TRANSITION THAT'S THE GOAL SO I
THINK WE'RE ALL WE ALL HAVE THE
SAME GOAL IT'S HAD A WE GET
THERE.
SHE LIKED TO GET WE TAKE THAT AS
YOU CLOSE YES SIR AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WAS A PROPOSING
THE AMENDMENT AND.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION APPRECIATED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO A CONTINUE
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION.
BUT.
ERECTED CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
IS TO.
SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND.
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND CHECK.
OKAY.
KIM WHY ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO
WITH SO MOVED IS HER SECOND.
SECOND OKAY. LOCAL.
ITEM THIRTY SIX A. B. THIRTY TO
A ONE BY MEMBER DALY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED ARE
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ARE OUT
SEARCHING ON ROUTE FIFTY AYE
ACOSTA. FIGHT ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I.
SIX
FOR NOW WRITE COLUSA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER WORD ITEMS
TO BILLS ITEM EIGHT AND I DON'T
FIFTEEN.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN AND AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE.
ARE WE GO UP IN THE FILE ORDER.
SO.
AB TWENTY TO SIXTY SEVEN.
EVERYBODY GET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE IN THEIR
STAFF FOR THIS WORK ON THE WORK
ON THIS BILL. I PRESUME YOU ALL
HEARD WE HAD FIRES IN.
ASSN SEVENTEEN OKAY ALRIGHT.
OF THESE WERE.
THESE WILDFIRES EXCEEDED THE
TOTAL INSURANCE CLAIMS FROM ANY
WHILE FIRING CALIFORNIA HISTORY
IN THE SEVERITY THESE FIRES THAT
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN SEVERAL COUNTIES
WHICH OF A SWITCH SOMEWHAT SOME
LOSSES.
IN SOME COUNTY WELFARE IS
WORSENED AT AND EXISTING SEVERE
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
BY OUR HOUSE WILDFIRES DESTROYED
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND HOMES IN
THE COUNTY.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN WOULD
ALLOW WILD FERRET DAMAGE
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING TO REAP BE
REPLACED OR REBUILT. AT A FIFTY
PERCENT HIGHER DENSITY CURLY
THIS DENSITY BONUS ONLY APPLIES
TO SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD ADD
SPECIFIC WHILE FOR DAMAGE.
DAMAGE HOUSING LANGUAGE INTO
SEQUEL GUIDELINES AND CLARIFY
THAT THESE RECONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR SEQUEL
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THE BILL WOULD NOT PREVIOUSLY
PRE EXEMPT ARE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
EXCEPTIONS CURRENTLY LISTED IN
THE SEQUEL GUIDELINES.
OFTENTIMES WHEN REBUILDING A
HOME A HOMEOWNER OFTEN WANTS TO
EXPAND OUR MAKE ADDITIONS ON
THEIR EXISTING PROPERTY. THE
ALLOWANCE OF A HIGHER DENSITY
CAN INCENTIVIZE HOMEOWNERS TO
REBUILD AND HELP INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY.
A REALIZATION OF PROPERTY AS AS
AT THAT THIS TIME WOULD ONLY
EXASPERATED A HOUSING CRISIS AND
WOULD REPRESENT A LOST
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD SMARTER.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
PAUL YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF CINEMA
COUNTY.
WELL YEAH.
NO ON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OTHER MEMBERS
SPOILER SHUDDER AND TO HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR AWHILE SO I'M
GONNA VERY BRIEFLY JUST STATE
THAT WE NEED TO REPLACE FIVE
THOUSAND HOMES. LOW OVER FIVE
THOUSAND HOMES IN CINEMA THAT'S
AS MANY HOUSES WERE BUILT IN THE
COUNTY BETWEEN TWENTY ELEVEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IT'S BASICALLY
A SMALL TOWN. WE DESPERATELY
NEED THIS BILL AND I WOULD URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THINK THIS CHAIRMAN KEEP THEM
HALF THE SNOW MCKINLEY REGIONAL
CLIMATE PROTECTION AUTHORITY AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHECK YOUR
ROTH ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA ALSO IN SUPPORT AND
ALL THE COMMENTS YOU'VE HEARD.
LIKEWISE YELLING COVERAGE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'LL ASSISTANCE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF CUT CHAMBER IN SUPPORT.
JERRY MEMBERS BRUCE MAGNANI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CEMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAY NONE.
IT'S WHAT WAS LIKE CLOTHES
RESPECT LAST FOREVER THANK YOU.
SUPPORT SUPPORT ITS
RECOMMENDATION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALDERON.
BY MEMBER WHAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI BY
WERE OUT TO GI ACOSTA ON THE
COST AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON. LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
RIGHT YES.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I.
EIGHT ZERO ITS SHARE THE BILL IS
OUT.
AND THE NEXT ITEM IS FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF LIKE TO THINK COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES WERE
AMENDMENTS.
I TRIED BE BRIEF SINCE I KNOW
THE SUSPEND ALONG HEARING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT
OUR HISTORIC APPROACH TO FIRE IS
INADEQUATE. WORLD'S GETTING
WARMER TRYOUTS REFLECTING
CALIFORNIA AND EVERY YEAR THE
VEGETATION GROWS CREATING MORE
AND MORE FUEL THE STATUS QUO.
KEEPS DIGGING A DEEPER HOLE IN
EACH YEAR WERE SEEN MORE
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES.
THE COST OF FIGHTING THESE FIRES
IS ASTOUNDING WE SPENT MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE EMERGENCY FUND IN FIVE OF
THE LAST SIX YEARS FIGHTING
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
OVER TWO BILLION IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS ALONE. MOREOVER DATA
SUGGESTS THAT IN EACH OF THE
LAST THREE YEARS FIRES OF
ADMITTED MORE CARBON THAN EVERY
TAILPIPE IN THE STATE COMBINED.
THE TUBS FIRE IN MY DISTRICT
SINGLE HANDEDLY ADMITTED MORE
CARBON IN ONE WEEK THAN EVERY
TAILPIPE IN THE STATE DOES OVER
AN ENTIRE YEAR.
WHILE ACCOUNTS YEAR QUALITY
OCTOBER IN CINEMA AND NAPA
COUNTY WAS THE WORST ON RECORD
AND THE HEALTH PACKED HEALTH
IMPACTS WERE REMARKABLE.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY RELEASED IN
THE JOURNAL THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION SMOKY AIR IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE FIRES WAS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE FORTY TWO
PERCENT. OF THE HIGHER RISK OF
HEART ATTACK COMPARED TO SMOKE
FREE AIR AT TWENTY TWO PERCENT
RELATIVE RISK OF EMERGENCY
VISITS FOR CORONARY ARTERY
DISEASE.
NORTH BAY FIRES THAT HAVE
DEVASTATED LARGE PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT IN OCTOBER WAS THE MOST
COSTLY FIRESTORM IN MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE IMPACT OF THE EVENTS LIKE
THIS CANNOT BE MEASURED IN
DOLLARS AND CENTS.
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES LOST
EVERYTHING THEY OWN AND DOZENS
LOST THEIR LIVES.
THE TIMES FIRE CHANGE MY
COMMUNITY FOR EVER.
JUST OVER SIXTY DAYS LATER THE
THOMAS FIRE AGAIN FUELED BY HIGH
WINDS AND BADLY NEGLECTED LANCE
BECAME THE LARGEST FIRE IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
LET'S MAKE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRE SIXTIES AND THE
LAST FINAL WAKEUP CALL. MUST
CHANGE THE WAY WE MANAGE OUR
LANCE RESTORE RESILIENCE MUST
ACCEPT THAT WE HAVE TO FIGHT
FIRE WITH FIRE. MUST TAKE MAKE
THE INVESTMENT OUR NATIONAL
WORKING LANDS IS THERE STILL ARE
MOST POWERFUL CLIENT CLIMATE
CHANGE RESOURCES.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE AS PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
THE BILL CREATES A JOINT BURNER
PROGRAM WITH CAL FIRE TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
COLLABORATE WITH PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS ON PROACTIVE FIRES.
IT PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES TO CAL FIRE FOR THE
FOREST HEALTH PROGRAM SO WE'RE
PROVIDING SOME GUIDANCE ABOUT
HOW TO INVEST THOSE FUNDS. NAY
CALLS FOR INVESTING UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO. PUT FOR FIRE
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING THE HEALTHY FORCE
PROGRAM AND THE COMMUNITY FIRE
PROTECTION EFFORTS THAT WERE
ADDRESSED TO MISS ALONE SPELL
OUT LAST THAT WAS HER LAST WEEK.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
PAUL MASON WITH THE PACIFIC FOR
STRESS.
BOB GOOD EVENING TODD CHAIRMAN
WITH MANY PROMISE LOOKS AT
FORREST TRUST ODD GIVEN THE HOUR
ALL TRUNCATE RUINED MY REMARKS I
THINK SOMEONE WOULD COVER A LOT
OF THAT. TO PRE STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL TO PROVIDE SOME DIRECTION
TO THE APARTMENT FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THEY'RE GONNA FOR THE FOREST
HEALTH PROGRAM. AND SEEKS A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION BECAUSE
IN ORDER TO GET TO THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGE BOTH IN DEALING
WITH OUR WATERSHED RESTORATION
IN THE WILD LANDS. AND AROUND
OUR COMMUNITIES WE REALLY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PLAN FOR MAJOR
PROJECTS YEAR OVER YEAR WHETHER
IT'S THIS BILL AND MISS LOANS
BILL. REALLY TRYING TO GET TO AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT THERE SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
REED ADDED SOME BEHALF AMID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
TRUST THE ALSO BE SHORTENED JUST
SAYS HE MY COMMENTS WITH. A
COLLEAGUE THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE MEMBERS POTTIER SHUDDERING
IT'S WE JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SNOW MIA
JUST HAD ONE BILL TO HELP REPAIR
WHAT HAPPENED YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL TO HELP. TRY TO PREVENT IT
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
DRIVE BOTH THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELENA ORTIZ ON
BEHALF OF THE WILDLINGS
CONSERVANCY SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS EZOLA
GONZALEZ PARTER ON BEHALF OF BIG
SUR LANCE TRUST PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE FOR US IN SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY ON
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS BURNS ON BEHALF OF THIS
HERE BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
MARK FRIENDSTER MAKER FOR THIS
NUMBER COUNTY WATER AGENCY THE
CINEMA COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
PRESERVATION AN OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN THE CALIFORNIA TAHU
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORUS IN SUPPORT.
BUT NOTHING IN DOLLARS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
LUCAS FRERICHS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES APART.
MANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
IS EGGMAN IT IS LATE SO I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT BUT THANK YOU
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD I THINK I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO SEE
THIS PENDULUM SWING BACK THE
OTHER WAY. AND HOPEFULLY WILL
LAND SOMEPLACE RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE WHERE WE CAN TAKE CARE OF
OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR FORESTS AND
OUR WATERSHED.
MOVE THE BILL.
AND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED TO.
.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MS LIMB ON THEY JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THERE'S THIS IS
BEEN.
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE
STATE AND I KNOW WITH THE BILL
WE PASSED LAST WEEK AND THIS ONE
AND I THINK THAT THEY REALLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO WORK.
IN A GREATER WAY AND WORK
TOGETHER ABOUT THIS AND.
YOU KNOW WHEN APPROPRIATE LEFT
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR A CO
AUTHOR.
LEFT HAVE.
AND FOR THE WHAT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NONE.
MR WORD.
YEAR BILL ON CHOICE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION YOU HAVE.
WHICH ELECT CLOSE I JUST
RESPECT WE HAVE TRAVELED MISTER
THERE VERY MUCH.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY ONE BY WOULD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED IN REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SO IF YOU AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
AND I COSTS AYE CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA I'M
LIMON.
LIMON I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ.
REYES.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
BILLS OUT BEING SECURE THINK
MEMBERS THE.
.
INVITE MS AT YOUR CURRY YOU HAVE
THE TWO ITEMS ITEM NUMBER SIX.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT AND ITEM
NUMBER TEN. AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SO LET'S GO WITH THE FILE
ITEM ORDER.
OFFICER.
SHE STEPPED OUT.
OKAY
AND WE HAVE NO OTHER. AUTHORS
SO.
TAKE A BRIANNA OKAY MUSLIM
OWNED.
MRS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE.
S. THEM ON.
THINK YOU KNOW THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HAD SOME OF THE WORST
AND MOST DEVASTATING FIRES IN
STATE HISTORY WHICH WENT OVER A
MILLION ACRES OF LAND AND RESULT
IN OVER A BILLION IN DAMAGES.
IN THIS HALF HARPER REGION
SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THESE FIRES
FOLLOWED BY HEAVY RAIN RESULTED
IN DEADLY METS LIFE THAT
DESTROYED OVER FORTY. FOUR
HUNDRED HOMES AND KILLED OVER TO
IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITH ME TODAY REID
ADDISON WITH ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENERGY CONSULTING AND MAKE UP IN
THE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE.
ALRIGHT.
.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR
MEMBERS READ OUT US ON BEHALF OF
JOHN WICK COULD CO FOUNDER OF
THE MARIN CARBON PROJECT. VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS MARRIAGE OF
HEALTHY FORCE IN HEALTHY SOILS
IT'S LATE EVENING I'LL HOLD MY
TESTIMONY SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT ALRIGHT
JUST FELT DOES ENJOY IT SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION NO
OPPOSITION. I THINK WHAT NICK
OFFICE OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE. ACT.
MY ONE LINE STATEMENT ON THIS
THAT COMPOST CAN REALLY DO A LOT
TO HELP RESTORE.
THAT THAT LANCE THAT AREA MAKE
IT SUBJECT TO FIRES TO PREVENT.
LANDSLIDES AND SOIL EROSION BUT
ALSO CAN HELP PREVENT THAT FOR
SURE THE.
FIRES BY TAKING BOMB* OUT
OF THE FORCE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER TECH CRAPPIE
WENT REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATE
A COMPOST PRODUCERS AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MALONE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOSED COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE SOLID
WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
WEST PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF.
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS AS
WELL AS THE SIERRA OUR CD AND
CINEMA COMPOST AND SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE MITCHELL BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE OF BEFORE WE GO ANY
FURTHER MISLIM ON YOU DO ACCEPT
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS IDEA OR
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED. ISLAM ALWAYS LIKED
CLOTHES ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN AYE
BUT THANK YOU. BROKE OFFICE ITEM
THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
MEMBERS OF ON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTE
SUCI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE AUSTIN
AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE LIMO
AYE LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ LINDA'S AYE
RADIUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO.
NO RIGHT TO A BILL IS OUT MUSLIM
ON ARE YOU PREPARED FOR IT
OUTSIDE OF MY RIGHT HAND THIS
IS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN.
THANK YOU AND MEMBERS AND.
DICK CHERRY MEMBER'S AB TWENTY
TWO ELEVEN REPEAL THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AND HAVE MATT ROBINSON'S WITH ME
AND FROM THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
BUSINESS THAT WORK REPRESENT
SUPPORT SUPPORT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WHICH I OR ITS WE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
BUSINESS NETWORK. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR ED HABITATS
ARE THE QUESTIONS YOU MAYHAVE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
AND IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOVED AND SECONDED.
IS THE MOST LIKE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NEVER MAKE
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANDWE DO NEED A MOTION AND I
KNOW HE DIDN'T NOW OKAY. SEC
OKAY ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION ROLL CALL PLEASE
I DON'T SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN BY MEMBER LIMB ON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MANDATORY
FOR TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTES
RICHIE AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA
AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE FLORA. FLORA AND LIMON AYE
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ LINDA'S
IRENAEUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE NINE TEN ZERO.
ELISSA THINK YOU THANK YOU KNOWS
AGAR CURRY.
IF YOU.
IT'S ITEM NUMBER SIX.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT AND ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIRST MISTER CHAIR WHO HAD NO
OBJECTION FROM THE COMMITTEE
RIGHT.
YES.
SINCE I WAS LATE UNDERSTOOD
MAKING MONEY WITH NO.
LET'S.
LARA MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THIS BILL
APPLIES TO PRIVATE FIRE
PREVENTION RESOURCES OPERATING.
DURING AN ACT OF FIRE INCIDENT.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY WILL
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION TO
COLLABORATE ON REGULATIONS
GOVERNING THE OPERATIONS OF
EQUIPMENT.
THIS BILL IS A DIRECT RESULT OF
COMMUNICATION I HAD WITH OH YES.
CALIFORNIA AND MS MYDLINK LIMON.
REGARDING FIRE IG REGARDING
EXISTING PRACTICES FOLLOWING THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES.
FIREFIGHTERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE WORKS TO FIGHT THESE FIRES
AND THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
PRESENCE OF PRIVATELY CONTRACTED
FIRE RESOURCES.
THIS PART CONFUSION AND I'M
QUESTIONS REGARDING HOW PRIVATE
RESOURCES INTERACT WITH STATE
LOCAL RESOURCES. REPORTS
INDICATED THAT THE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS IN THEIR CRIMINAL
WERE UNDISTINGUISHED OVAL FROM
THAT OF THE PUBLI FIREFIGHTING
AGENCIES. AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHTY WILL PUT AN END TO THE
PUBLIC CONFUSION ABOUT WHERE THE
FIRE RESOURCES ARE PUBLIC FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE PRIVATELY
CONTRACTED FOR SPECIFIC
PURPOSES.
AND STRENGTHENED OVERALL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE STANDARDS TO
BENEFIT ALL FIRE RESOURCES.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY DOUG SUPERS
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST OBSERVERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. WERE
HERE TODAY AND A STRONG SUPPORT
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD.
THIS MEASURE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
COORDINATION.
AND AND WORK BETWEEN ANY
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS THAT ARE OUT
ON A WILDFIRE AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY FIRST RESPONDERS THAT ARE
OUT IN THE WILD FIRE SEEN AS
WELL.
THIS.
.
CONCEPT WAS.
AND CONCEPTS AND STANDARDS WERE
DEVELOPED A FIRE SCOPE WHICH IS
A LEGISLATIVELY ESTABLISHED BODY
THAT BRINGS THE FIRE SERVICE
TOGETHER STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
TO TALK ABOUT WAYS TO BETTER.
INTERACT AND.
OPERATE ON INCIDENTS WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL WILL TAKE THE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE ALREADY
DEVELOPED AND FOLLOWED PUT THEM
INTO STATE LAW TO ENSURE THAT
THE COORDINATION IS CLEAR.
WHETHER THEY INCIDENT COMMAND IS
RUN BY THE STATE OR LOCAL BODY
OR ANOTHER REGIONAL BODY FOR
THOSE REASONS WE. ASK FOR
SUPPORT NEXT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
CNN AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION THAT WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED MOVED AND SECONDED
SEEING NO CAN QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
NASDAQ OR CURRY WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE SAFE
YOU.
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS AYE
THOSE
I RECALL PLEASE. ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY BY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU. CHA ADMIN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMON.
LET ALONE AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ LINDA'S AYE RADIUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I.
IF NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THE BILL
IS NOW.
ALRIGHT NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX.
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S.
AB TWENTY TWO OH IT WILL PROVIDE
A NECESSARY COURSE CORRECTION
FOR THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS PROGRAM.
AS WE MOVE TO INCREASE RENEWABLE
PROCUREMENT TOWARD FIFTY PERCENT
AND BEYOND ARE RENEWALS ARE OUT
OF BALANCE AND LESS DIVERSE.
THERE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH OF WIND AND ESPECIALLY
SOLAR.
WHICH ARE VALUABLE BUT
INTERMITTENT RESOURCES.
AT THE SAME TIME BIO ENERGY AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES HAVE NOT
GROWN.
MANY FACILITIES HAVE CLOSED AND
MANY MORE WILL BE COMING OFF
LINE WITHOUT BEING RE CONTRACTED
IN THE COMING YEARS.
BEFORE HE REACHED FIFTY PERCENT
ARE PS MARK WE'RE ON TRACK TO
LOSE VALUABLE RESOURCES THAT THE
STATE HAS A SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
IN PRESERVING.
THESE AREN'T RESOURCES ARE
VALUABLE NOT ONLY TO SMOOTH THE
GRID IMBALANCES BETWEEN SUPPLY
AND DEMAND. BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL BENT
BENEFITS TO THE STATE.
IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE A LARGE
GEOTHERMAL FACILITY THOSE
PROVIDED HIGH WAGE JOBS REDUCE.
DECADES.
MY CONSTITUENTS CONSTITUENTS
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE THOSE
JOBS.
WE ALSO CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE THE
GRID BENEFIT THE GEYSERS PROVIDE
TO CALIFORNIA.
THE RELIABLE RENEWABLE ENERGY
THE KIDS THE LIGHTS ON AT NIGHT
WHEN THE SUN IS THAT SHINING.
THAT FACILITY ALSO TRADE TREATS
WASTEWATER AND HAS HELPED CLEAN
UP WILD RIVERS LIKE THE RUSSIAN
RIVER.
THESE RIVERS FACE INCREASING
ENVIRONMENTAL DEVASTATION FROM
WALLFLOWER FIRES AND LANDSLIDES
IN A NEW ERA OF EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S AN AGRICULTURAL
STATE I HAVE A LOAN OF FAR
MYSELF WITH MOUNDS OF
AGRICULTURAL WASTE WITHOUT A
PLACE TO GO.
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
CONVERT AGRICULTURAL WASTE IN
THE BIO ENERGY.
WE SHOULD BE USING THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO VIA A TO AVOID THE
SORT OF OPEN BURNS WE SAW LAST
YEAR THAT FURTHER POLLUTED OUR
AIR AND WATER IN THE WILDFIRES.
WE PHASE A RAMPANT FIRE WILD
FIRES THAT DEVASTATE OUR
ENVIRONMENT WATER SUPPLY CLIMATE
GOALS AIR QUALITY. AND
ULTIMATELY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH.
NUMEROUS STATE AGENCIES HAVE
WEIGHED IN ON THIS ISSUE MANY OF
CONCLUDED THE FILE ENERGY IS ONE
OF THE BEST IN USES FOR FOREST
WASTE.
TO PREVENT AND MITIGATE AGAINST
WILDFIRES.
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION DEAD TREES IN OUR
FOREST DUE TO DROUGHT AND BARK
BEETLE INFESTATIONS.
THESE TREES ARE ESSENTIALLY
KINDLING FOR THE FUTURE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
WILD FIRES CANCEL OUT THE GAINS
WE MAKE TO OUR G. H. G. AND
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE REDUCTION
GOALS.
WE NEED TO AGGRESSIVELY AND
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO REVERSE
THIS WILDFIRE SIDE SAGA AND THE
STATE'S BIO ENERGY RESOURCES
MUST BE AN ASPECT OF THAT
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION.
I KNOW THE PHONE I KNOW THE
FOLKS HAVE RAISED ISSUES ABOUT
THE COST OF GEOTHERMALAND
BIOENERGY.
BUT THE PENSKE IS A BUT THAT BUT
VALUE IN THESE RESOURCES ON A
COST PER MEGAWATT BASIS IGNORES
THE HUGE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC VALUES THESE RESOURCES
BRING TO THE STATE.
WE KNOW THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
ONE CATASTROPHIC FILE IN MY
DISTRICT IS ALREADY OVER TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN INSURANCE
CLAIMS ALONE.
FAILING TO CONSIDER THESE
ADDITIONAL COST FOR REPAIRS AND
OUR STATE FAILS TO EVALUATE THE
THIS ISSUE FROM A COMPREHENSIVE.
I ALSO KNOW FOLKS HAVE RAISED
QUESTIONS ABOUT AIR QUALITY
AROUND SOME BIOMASS FOR US
FACILITIES.
WE KNOW THE BIOMASS ENERGY IS
FAR BETTER ALTERNATIVE FOR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR AIR QUALITY
THAT OPEN BURNING A RAPID FIRES.
BUT I AGREED THE STATE CAN DO
BETTER TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS.
HOLLYWOOD BIOMASS FACILITY IS
LOCATED IN EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT AREA.
I COMMIT TO YOU.
I WANT TO REPEAT THAT I COMMIT
TO YOU SHOULD THE BILL MOVE FOR
TODAY I WILL AMEND THE BILL TO
REQUIRE. IMPROVEMENTS IN HIT AIR
QUALITY TECHNOLOGIES FOR
BIOMASS.
FINALLY IF THESE ISSUES ARE
IMPORTANT TO YOU I ASK THAT YOU
BE MY PARTNER. IN MOVING THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FORWARD
SO WE CAN GET THIS DONE RIGHT.
A PROCESS NOW OFF TO MY A JOINT
AUTHORS MR GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRED
COLLEAGUES ARE PLEASED TO
PRESENT A. B. POINT TO AWAIT
CONJUNCTION WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM WINTERS.
A BILL THAT SEEKS TO PROMOTE THE
USE OF PROCUREMENT OF SPECIFIC
RENEWABLE RESOURCES.
WITHIN THE EXISTING APPIAH'S
FRAMEWORK.
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
CLIMATE AND ENERGY GOALS.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I AUTHORED
AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THAT
DIRECTED THE STATE TO ENSURE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS WERE
HAPPENING IN OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES.
THIS MEANS IT'S JUST NOT ABOUT
SETTING STATEWIDE STANDARDS BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT ENSURING
SIGNIFICANT CO BENEFITS.
I REALIZE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE MOVING TOWARD INTEGRATING
OTHER.
DIVERS RESOURCES SUCH AS
DETERMINED BY OF ENERGY WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CURRENT COST OF
DOING NOTHING.
NON THAT NOTE OF COST IT IS
OFTEN SAID THAT JILL THERMAL.
IS SOMETHING THAT COST A LOT
MORE THAN MANY OF THE OTHER
RENEWABLE.
ENERGY RESOURCES AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT IN MY DISTRICT.
THE HIGH LEVEL OF INVESTMENT
AND SOLAR AND WIND HAS BEEN A
VERY POSITIVE THING.
AS IT RELATES TO CREATING JOBS
AND IMPROVING THE ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES OF IMPAIR COUNTY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE HIGH
PENETRATION OF THESE
INTERMITTENTLY SOURCES SUCH AS
SOLAR WIND. CURRENT CREATE.
COST PRESSURES
DUE TO THE NEED OF NATURAL GAS
PLANTS.
AND NOT TO MENTION THE EXTERNAL
COSTS.
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THAT'S BEEN
RAISED BY SOME OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS ARE IN OUR DISTRICT.
WHEN THESE KINDS OF COSTS ARE
NOT QUANTIFY COLLECTIVELY.
IT'S LIKE COMPARING APPLES AND
ORANGES OF WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE COST OF GEOTHERMAL AND OTHER
RENEWABLES.
ONE THING WE DO KNOW FROM THE
INDEPENDENT SOURCES SUCH AS THE
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LABORATORY. IS
AT THE DEVELOPMENT OF GUILT THE
MORE RESOURCES AT THE SALTON
SEA.
IT'S COST EFFECTIVE AND WOULD
SAVE ENERGY CONSUMERS ABOUT
THREE SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION PER YEAR.
TODAY THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AN
APPEAL COUNTY IS SIXTEEN
PERCENT.
THE SECOND HIGHEST IN THE STATE
NEXT TO COLUSA COUNTY.
IF YOU YEARS AGO THIS COUNTY HAD
THE HIGHESTUNEMPLOYMENT. IN THE
NATION WITH TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT
ALMOST A THIRD OF ITS
POPULATION.
MEMBERS WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
NOW.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE HUNDREDS A GOOD PAYING
JOBS IN THE PART OF THE STATE
THE SUFFERS FROM STUBBORNLY
HIGH.
UNEMPLOYMENT WHILE ADDRESSING
SOME OF OUR GREATEST AIR QUALITY
AND ECOLOGICAL THREATS AT THE
SOLVENCY.
THIS IS WHY AB TWENTY TWO AWAY
IS SO IMPORTANT TO US AND WHITE
IT ENJOYS THE STRONG SUPPORT.
OF ALL OF OUR.
STAKEHOLDERS IN A PILL COUNTY
INCLUDING THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
I'M PARA IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
NUMEROUS.
DEVELOPERS INCLUDING OR MATT
CAL ENERGY ENERGY SOURCE
CONTROLLED THE MORE RESOURCES TO
NAME A FEW OF THE GEOTHERMAL
DEVELOPERS IN THE REGION.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE.
SUPPORT THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING PROCESS BEFORE
THE CPUC.
UNFORTUNATELY APPEAL COUNTY DOES
NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF THE TIME.
TO WAIT ON THE I RP.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE MARKET
CERTAINTY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CREATING
COMPANIES.
TO THOSE RISK VALUABLE
INVESTMENTS.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CONSTRUCTION COSTS TO BUILD
THESE FACILITIES NOW.
THE STATE HAS KICK STARTED ITS
INVESTMENT IN MITIGATION
PROJECTS NECESSARY FOR HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. NOT
ONLY FOR COMMUNITIES IMMEDIATELY
SURROUNDING THE SCENE. BUT THE
ENTIRE STATE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP MOVE THE
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES FORWARD
NOW.
IN ADDITION THERE IS A NEED TO
REDUCE THE STATE'S CURRENT A
STARK DEPENDENCE ON IMPORTED
COAL FROM NEIGHBORING STATES.
IN ANTICIPATION TO TRANSITIONING
TO A GREEN ECONOMY.
AGAIN THIS IS THE TIME TO BETTER
COORDINATE AND INTEGRATE GREAT
BALANCING RESOURCES TO AN ENERGY
PORTFOLIO THAT URGENTLY NEEDS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS REGARDING MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION THAT IS NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED.
HOWEVER WE ARE FULLY COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS ANY OF
THE ISSUES RAISED TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
WITH US TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE
RICH GORDON WITH CALIFORNIA'S
AND KELLY BOYD WITH THE LOW
CARBON FUEL ENERGY COALITION AND
OTHERS THANK YOU.
THE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
A I I KNOW THAT A NUMBER OF YOU
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCES IN THEIR COSTS.
SO LET ME TELL YOU WHY.
DESPITE THOSE CONCERNS YOU
SHOULD MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
TODAY.
IT'S AN ARGUMENT BASED ON THE
ENVIRONMENT.
ARE FORCE OR SIMPLY OVERGROWN.
WHEN THE EUROPEANS ARRIVED IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAD ABOUT FORTY
TREES TO AN ACRE.
TODAY THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THIS OVER GROWTH LEADS TO TREE
MORTALITY INCREASED FUEL FOR
DEVASTATING FIRES.
FORCED HEALTH
IT WILL REQUIRE THINNING OUR
FORESTS.
THE MATERIAL LEFT FROM THINNING
IS BIOMASS.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THIS
MATERIAL CAN BE BURNED ON SITE.
RELEASING CARBON OTHER NOXIOUS
GASES.
OR IT BE LEFT ON SITE
A IN THEIR IT STAYS IS FUEL.
FOR FUTURE FIRES.
THE THIRD CHOICE
ETERNITY AND ENERGY.
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR ABOUT
WILDFIRES FORCED HEALTH CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT
WILL HAVE TO INCLUDE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT BIOMASS.
YOU CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
CONVERSATION BY MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
THIS IS THE ONLY VEHICLE IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT DEALS WITH BIOMASS
IN THIS MANNER.
MOVING THIS BILL THE SHORES OF
THE ASSEMBLY WILL REMAIN IN THE
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
WILDFIRES AND FORCED HEALTH AND
FOR THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND THINKING GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE KELLY
BOARD ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LOW CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY
COALITION I'M AYE ONE ECHO.
THE REMARKS OF THIS. THE
AUTHORS ANDA AND MISTER GORDON
AND STRESSED FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
.
WE NEED TO START CO MINGLING HOW
WERE ADDRESSING OUR PROGRAMS AND
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE OUR PS
ARE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
AND DEAL WITH CLIMATE ADAPTATION
WE NEED TO MAKE BEST USE OF THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE. IN OUR OUR PS
ARSENAL.
BIOMASS AND GEOTHERMAL POWER
GRID BALANCING RESOURCES THEY
WILL ALLOW US TO REDUCE THE COST
OF THE GRID GOING FORWARD WE
WON'T HAVE TO. PURCHASE AS MUCH
NEW DISTRIBUTION AND
TRANSMISSION MORE IMPORTANTLY AS
HAS BEEN POINTED OUT HERE.
THEY'LL HELP US TO AVOID AND
NINETY NINE PERCENT OF THE
CARBON THAT WOULD OTHERWISE. BE
ADMITTED INTO THE AIR BY OPEN
BURNING FROM OTHER SOURCES THEY
WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO ARM ATTAIN
OUR LANDFILL REDUCTION
OBJECTIVES THESE ARE KEY
RESOURCES THEY'RE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE TO THE GRID. THE
EXISTING FORTY TWO COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
IN SOME OF THE MOST ECONOMICALLY
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS WE NEED TO
KEEP THE JOBS THERE WE NEED TO
KEEP THE FOCUS ON NOT AN.
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY IN THOSE
REGIONS AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE CALPERS
THE PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE WESTERN
CITY COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS TO STAY ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES IN LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE THE FOREST PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY.
I I THINK YOU ALL UNDERSTAND THE
JOB'S IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL
BUT I TWENTY THREE.
POINTS.
WHEN WE CLOSED OF THE SENATE NO
FOR NUCLEAR. OPERATING STATION
AND WE LOST TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF CLEAN GHG FREE
NUCLEAR POWER.
THE SOLUTION TO SOLVE THE WHOLE
IN THE LA BASIN. BY THE CPUC AND
BY THE CAL I SO WAS TO BUILD A
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
TRANSMISSION LINE WITH
CALIFORNIA REPAIR MONEY. OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA TO BRING IN MORE
NATURAL GAS FIRED POWER TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO DECOMMISSION
DE DIABLO CANYON NUCLEAR POWER
STATION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY FIVE THEY WERE GONNA LOSE
ANOTHER TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF GHG FREE.
POWER LET'S NOT MAKE THAT SAME
MISTAKE TWICE
LET'S TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
GEOTHERMAL IN THE BIO MASS THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED. AND NOT
REPLACE IT WITHOUT A STATE
NATURAL GAS ON THE COST ISSUE I
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT.
THAT IF THE OPPONENTS ARGUMENTS
ON COST WOULD HAVE PREVAILED
ABOUT A DECADE AGO.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE ROOFTOP SOLAR
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE SPENT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OF REPAIR MONEY
ON A CSI PROGRAM FOR ROOFTOP
SOLAR.
SO THAT'S NOT A VALID ARGUMENT
FOR THE SAME INDUSTRIES TO MAKE
TODAY.
LET'S GET THIS BUILT AND IT AND
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE LIFE CYCLE
COSTS.
ARE ACTUALLY BETTER.
DIDN'T CERTAIN TYPES OF
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY.
THE LIFE CYCLE COSTS OF A
GEOTHERMAL FACILITY FOR INSTANCE
OR A NEW BIOMASS FACILITY IS
IT'S GOING TO LAST LONGER YOU
GONNA GET A BIGGER BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK. THEN.
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD A ORIGIN I
THINK YOU.
THE COMMISSION CHAIRMAN MR
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
TO THE ELEVEN BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU LEAVE ALLEN ASKING ALL OF
YOU HAVE A CALIFORNIA BY A MASS
ENERGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FLOOR
KNOWING HE JACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA RACE COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS TRICIA GUARANTOR
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT THE
LOSS ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MURS LUCAS FRERICHS ON BEHALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PER SILVIUS
ELISE SHAUN BEHALF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE PARTICULARLY THE
PURCHASE OF BIOMASS ENERGY FROM
PLANTS THAT ARE YOU UTILIZING
AGRICULTURAL WASTE MATERIAL
THINKING.
MR JANITORS VINCENT WHERE MODEL
WITH THE WHITE MEAN GROUP ON THE
HALF BY CHECK POWER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS FROM
THE COLD BENEFITS STATED. A
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMBER BLIX FOR THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT OF THIS PORTFOLIO
APPROACH TO RENEWABLE
PROCUREMENT.
KAREN MILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT.
CASSANDRA COUGH WITH CALPINE WE
AS WE.
MAKING PRODUCED SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MEGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE ALL GEOTHERMAL ENERGY
WE EMPLOY THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE
MAJORITY OF WHICH LIVE IN AND
MISS I GO AYE CURRY'S DISTRICT
AND IMPORTANTLY WE KEEP YOUR ICE
CREAM COLD AT NIGHT.
MET CLUB AND STEAM WITH ENERGY
SOURCE MINERALS HERE IN SUPPORT.
EHRENREICH BROKE WITH THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
JEFFREY HARMON FROM DOES REVIEW
POWER HONEY LIKE POWER AND TRACY
BIOMASS POWER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
WHAT I TO GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
CONTROLLED THEIR MORE RESOURCES
WERE ONE OF SEVERAL DEVELOPERS
IN THE SALTON SEA REGION STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THEM?
AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
ANDY HARM THE DEPUTY CEO FOR
NATURAL RESOURCE FOR THE COUNTY
OF IMPERIAL HER TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SUASANA HERE
LABOR STATE COUNCIL SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN EMERITUS WITH YOUR
PERMISSION LIKE DEAL TWEENER
THING LOOKS AGREED ON SPORT
EMPLOYER SHUDDER INTO A WE HAVE
THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL IN GENERAL. DISRESPECTFULLY
IS POSSIBLE WOULD LIKE SEE THE
SPECIFIC REFERENCES SOLVENCY
TAKEN OUT AND SUBSTITUTED FOR
WITH BASELOAD. BASIL RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCES THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT AND FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
.
IF THE.
PROPONENTS CAN.
YEAH CLEAR THE SEATS THANK YOU.
BUT.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL WE DO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
PROCUREMENT OF RENEWABLE
RESOURCES HOWEVER THE RPF HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN.
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND I THINK
THE SUCCESS OF THE OUR PS
IS BECAUSE OF THAT TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY. IT'S ALLOWED THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES TO
COMPETE HICH HAS BROUGHT THE
REACHED THE COST OF THESE
RESOURCES DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE OUR
PS
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
THE JOB BENEFITS THAT CERTAIN
RESOURCES HAVE WHETHER IT'S YOU
GET SHE. AND ACCOUNT YOU CAN'T
JUST LOOK AT COST
BUT WE DO SUPPORT THE IRP
PROCESS TO.
LOOK AT THESE TYPES OF
PROCUREMENT DECISIONS THAT IRP
PROCESS WHICH IS JUST ITS
INFANCY LOOK THAT NOT JUST COST
BUT ALSO LOOK THAT GHGS AND
GREATER RELIABILITY WE THINK
THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE PLACE
FOR THESE TYPES OF PROCUREMENT
DECISIONS.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TWENTY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION.
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT AND ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLECTION ANY AT THE LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION WE ARE
ALL OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS.
AS PROPOSED
THINK WE ARE ALL ON.
SYMPATHETIC TO THE STRUGGLES OF
THE BIOMASS THE D. THERMAL
INDUSTRY WE RECOGNIZE THE VALUE
THEY PROVIDE TO THOSE OUT
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY RESIDE
WITHIN HOWEVER THE OUR PIASTS
WHICH HAS BEEN A LEASE COST BEST
THAT MECHANISM SINCE IT'S BEEN.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND TWO IS
THE BEST WAY TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT WE HAVE WHILE ALSO
KEEPING A CHECK ON REPAIR COSTS.
AND FOR THOSE PURPOSES WE ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
WAS IN THE EARLY CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY WE HAVE A COUPLE
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL IN ITS
PRESENT FORM NUMBER ONE WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THE BLANKS FILLED
IN.
WE THINK IT'S REALLY CLICK
CRITICAL THAT THE COMMITTEE A
COMPLETE THIS BILL BEFORE IT
LEAVES TODAY.
NUMBER TWO THE COST OUR
RATEPAYERS.
BOTH THE SOLAR IN THE WIND
INDUSTRY HAVE GOTTEN AND IF WE
USE SOME TREMENDOUSLY IN OUR
BUSINESS.
HAVE GOTTEN SIGNIFICANT
SUBSIDIES FROM BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND THE STATE GOVERNMENT OVER
THE YEARS.
WE BELIEVE IN WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
BUT THE WHAT THIS BILL IS
PROPOSING TO DO BUT THE IMPACT
ON OUR RATE PAYERS WOULD BE
HORRIFIC.
NOT JUST THE COST OF THE
GENERATION BUT THE TRANSMISSION
COST ASSOCIATED WITH IT WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE COST
OF THIS BILL TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
AND WE URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS TRANSMIT ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITY ASSOCIATION AND ARE
THIRTY NINE OF OUR FORTY MEMBERS
OUR POSITION DOES NOT REFLECT
THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT.
BUT WE OPPOSE BASED ON THE
REASONS YOU PREVIOUSLY HEARD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON ANCHORED WITH ADULTS TING
GILBERT ROPES AND SMITH. ON
BEHALF OF CAL CCA THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION.
BRIEFLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
AMONG THEM.
GRANDFATHERING OUT AND EXISTING
CONTRACTS FROM JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. DOES PUT A NEW CCA'S
AT A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
COMPARED TO THE INCUMBENT
UTILITIES ARE ALSO THE EXTENT
THAT THE THE BILL WOULD
INADVERTENTLY RESULT IN EXCESS
PROCUREMENT BY THE I. O. U.'S.
THAT WILL RESULT IN COST FOR ALL
RATEPAYERS INCLUDING CCA
RATEPAYERS FOR THOSE REASONS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
HOWEVER DO WANNA QUICKLY NO. OUR
PRE SHAKES INTO THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF FOR THEIR EARLY OUT
REACHED US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN POWER
ROSS WE SEE CA. AND OUT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS AND.
WITH THE BILL ONE OF THE MAIN
WEEK CONCERN IS THE PURCHASE
HAVING TO PURCHASE THE SALTON
SEA A GEOTHERMAL WE ALREADY
PURCHASED FIFTY WE HAVE FIFTY
MEGAWATTS AND THE GUYS USED. IN
THE CINEMA AREA AND BY MANDATING
THAT WE PURCHASE ADDITIONAL THAT
IS GOING TO HURT THE RATE PAYERS
ON MEMBER WE WORKING. M. AND
PURCHASED FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
FOR THE COMMUNITY SELL
PURCHASING OUTSIDE WOULD BE VERY
DETRIMENTAL THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DUNCAN
MCFETRIDGE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
OF FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
PRINCIPALLY WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT CIRCUMVENTION OF THE IRP
PROCESS.
AND CIRCUMVENTING THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS THANK YOU.
CURRENT SLOW PREFERS EMPEROR
ENERGY IN SENATOR CASF ELECTRICO
WE ARE ALSO IN. PROPOSED WE
HAVE.
WE THINK WE'RE WELL POSITIONED
TO MAKE ART RPO SCHOOLS THROUGH
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE THE RP PROCESS THINK.
GOOD EVENING CAO JOHNSON CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE POSED THE
BIOMASS REGIONS THE POTENTIAL
AIR QUALITY IMPACTS PARTICULARLY
IN NON ATTAINMENT AREAS OR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
I'M NOT SURE HERNANDEZ WE HAVE
TURNED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
ANOTHER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON ALSO
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS VARIOUS THEM AS EGGMAN.
I HAD I SHARED A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS.
.
BUT ONE OF THOSE HAVE HAS TO DO
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
STANDARDS BEING BUILT INTO THE
PLAN. AYE KNOW THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WILL BE LOOKING INTO
REMOVE.
ANOTHER CONCERN IS WHERE THE
FACILITIES WILL BE LOCATED IN
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE.
TRUCKS.
COMING IN TO WIN THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE THE DIRTY AIR
BEING CAUSED BY THE DIESEL
TRUCKS.
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT AS A WHAT ARE AS WELL.
ALSO REDUCING THE NUMBER OF BURN
DAYS.
CLOTHING SOME LANGUAGE ABOUT.
LIMITING THE BURN DAYS
ESPECIALLY NEAR THE FACILITIES.
AND IN GENERAL ON BIOMASS.
IS THIS REALLY.
A SOURCE OF ENERGY WE WANT TO
INVEST IN.
CAN WE LIVE WITH IT ARE THE
CLEANER SOURCES OF ENERGY THAT
WE CAN INVEST IN.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
BUT I I FEEL THAT I FROM MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
THAT.
THE THE CONVERSATION WILL
CONTINUE.
AND THE.
TO STAKEHOLDERS ESPECIALLY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
WILL BE.
INCLUDED IN THE CONVERSATIONS
SO THAT WE DON'T CAUSE MORE
HARM.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO.
ALLEVIATE PROBLEMS THROUGH YOUR
BILL.
I AM PREPARED TO TO.
AND VOTE. IN FAVOR TO ALLOW IT
TO GET OUT OF COMMITTEE. BUT
RESERVE MY. RIGHT TO CHANGE THAT
VOTE WHEN IT COMES ON THE FLOOR.
DEPENDING ON THE END RESULT
AND THE. POTENTIAL HARM AND THAT
BALANCE BETWEEN THE GOOD AND THE
BAD BECAUSE TO THE COMMUNITIES
AS A WHOLE.
CONSIDER.
SO AUTUMN AND I APPRECIATE
BECAUSE IT HAD SOME GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ARE BROUGHT TO
LIGHT A COUPLE THINGS THAT.
WANTED TO SHARE SO LET'S
REMEMBER THE INTENT OF THE BILL
IS TO ENSURE WE HAVE CLEAN AIR.
CLEAN WATER A BETTER CLIMATE FOR
ALL CAME. YOUR TRUCK A
CONVERSATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
IF WE PUT WE NEED A BIOMASS
PLANTS WHERE THEY MAKE SENSE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
THEM IN AN AREA THAT THEY DO
HAVE TO TRUCK IT IN AND OUT.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD MAKE
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE SO THE
INTENT THE INTENT IS THAT MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THE EXISTING
BIOMASS OF FACILITIES UPGRADED.
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN GET THOSE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF NEW
TECHNOLOGY SENSE THAT EVER
HAPPENED.
SO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE TO
THIS
THE OTHER ONE IS THAT YOU KNOW
IF WITH THIS BILL DOESN'T GO
FORWARD I CAN'T REDUCE BURN
DAYS.
WE STILL HAVE ALL THAT WASTE
PARTICULARLY AG WASTE AND I SOME
OF YOU'VE BEEN TO MY.
DISTRICT BEFORE BUT IF SOMEONE
IS SAY TO ME YOU NEED TO BURN
THOSE STUMPS BECAUSE THE OTHER
STARTING TO ROT BECAUSE METHANE
OTHER THINGS I. I WOULD SAYIS
THAT. YOU GIVE ME A WINDOW TIME
WITH THEY ARE BE FOR TWO HOURS
IS A BURN DAY YOU GET A PHONE
CALL IT'S A BURN DAY YOU RUN OUT
YOU START OF. A.
.
STUMP ON FIRE THEY DON'T BURN.
LIKE THAT QUICK THEY SMOLDER IN
SMOKERS IN THE AIR FOR HOURS AND
HOURS AND IT'S THE SAME WITH
OTHER THINGS WE'VE BEEN ASKED BY
OTHERS ABOUT ONE THAT WAY STE.
FROM THE HALLS WHEN THEY IN
PROCESSING THIS IS HARD HOLES
AFTER PROCESS OF WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THAT.
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO GET RID
OF SOME OF THE SAG WASTE
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
BECAUSE WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
AND WE NEED TO AT LEAST LOOK AT
A HOLISTIC APPROACH RATHER THAN
JUST BEING JUST IT'S ALL ABOUT
KOSTER. YOU KNOW YOU KNOW IS IT
GOING TO COST A LOT MORE
ABSOLUTELY BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THE
GOAL IS TO BRING THAT COST DOWN
FOR THE REPAIRS AS WELL AS THE
TAXPAYERS.
SO YES AND I COMMITTED TO LIKE
INCENTIVIZE THEM OPENING
STATEMENT I'M NOT GOING TO BRING
THIS THIS TO THE FLOOR. UNLESS I
KNOW THAT YOU AND OTHERS WERE
GONNA COME UP ON THAT THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND WE DID OUR BEST TO
MAKE SURE WAS GOOD CLEAN AIR FOR
ALL.
THANK YOU.
THE SEGMENT.
SO.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THE TO THE
COST ISSUE FOR RATEPAYERS?
I'M I'M A DIVERSE.
ADORES DIVERSE PORTFOLIO.
MAKES JUST MORE SENSE.
ITS GONNA BE CHEAPER IN THE LONG
RUN.
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT IF
WE DON'T DO THIS WITH
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE BUYING
ENERGY ELSEWHERE.
AND WE HAVE GOOD STRINGENT LAWS
THAT WE NEED TO IMPROVE THOSE
THE WHAT WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE
WITH BIOMASS.
DOESN'T NEED TO BE IMPROVED
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE THOSE RULES
MORE STRINGENT AND THAT'S WHAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO DO.
I THINK WE NEED TO REMEMBER.
IT'S CHEAPER TO MAINTAIN.
AND I HAVE A BALLOTS.
WE KNOW THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
THE FIRES TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND WE IF WE CAN'T REMEMBER
THAT'S PART OF THIS THIS.
HOLD A.
FORMULA IF WE'RE GONNA SPEND
THAT MUCH MONEY WE COULD HAVE
BEEN DOING SOMETHING IN BENEFIT.
A ARE WE LOOKING AT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES ABSOLUTELY CAN WE
TAKE SOME OF THOSE BY THOSE
TREES THAT ARE FALLING DOWN ALL
OVER THE PLACE MAYBE NEW WOOD
PRODUCTS.
SO THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE TO
THINK REALLY HOLISTICALLY. AND.
I'M HOPING THAT YOU WILL ALL
AGREE WITH THAT BECAUSE I JUST
THINK THAT.
IT'S IT'S GONNA COST HUNDRED
INITIALLY.
BUT IT DID FOR EVERY OTHER EVERY
OTHER THE.
UTILITY WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST
OR BUTTRESSING SO.
YES I I MEAN I WOULD I WOULD.
THE I'M A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
AND.
AND I AND I BELIEVE IN I HAVE
BELIEVED FOR A LONG TIME I'VE
HAD BIOMASS PLANTS GO OUT OF.
OUT OF BUSINESS IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT THE WITH THE LOSS OF
JOBS AND THEN MORE OPEN BURNS ON
AG LANDS. TYPE I A BUT TO THE TO
THE FORCE AND I CERTAINLY HAVE
SPENT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TAKING OUT DEAD TREES. THAT
THERE'S NOTHING TO DO WITH I DID
A BILL LAST WEEK ABOUT HOW DO WE
CREATE. AND.
USING CAN'T TELEPHONE
CONSERVATION CORPS MAKE MAKE
THEM THE WHOLE NEW AREA TO WORK
ON HIS TO DEVELOPING SOMETHING
WITH TIMBER PRODUCTS.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE AND WE CAN'T JUST LOOK
AT.
THE COST I THINK JUST OF THE
PROCUREMENT OF THAT ENERGY
WITHOUT LOOKING AT THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH DOING NOTHING
AND DOING THE SAME THING OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
AND ALSO WHEN WE SET POLICY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE FIND WAYS TO REDUCE COST WE
FIND WAYS TO BE ABLE TO BRING
THAT DOWN UNBALANCE THE GRID. I
TRUST WE CAN DO THAT WITH THIS I
THINK THIS IS A STEP FORWARD.
PROM AND I I THINK I THINK WE
NEED TO DO MORE. NOT LESS A MOVE
THE BILL.
THINKING.
MS LEE MOANED AND MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THIS CONVERSATION I KNOW
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS ACTUALLY FOR SOME TIME.
AND.
THIS IS ACTUALLY AN IN BIOMASS
IS AN ISSUE THAT THE THING
COMPLICATED IT'S NOT THE
DIRECTION. THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
ENERGY GO AND.
.
AND THEN A FACE THE FACT THAT
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT HAS
BEEN DEALT. A VERY DIFFICULT
CARD NUMBER I BEING THE SITE OF
THE THAT CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
WILDFIRE.
AND.
.
I HAVE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THIS YOU'VE ADDRESSED I
THINK SOME OF THE.
THAT CONCERNS RELATED TO TYING.
THE BILL.
TWO CLEANER AND BETTER
TECHNOLOGY HATE WHICH I THINK IS
A VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK WE
KNOW THAT SOME FACILITIES.
.
ARE BETTER THAN OTHERS ARE
DIRTIER THAN OTHERS AND I THINK
THAT.
WE'VE SEEN THAT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND PARTICULARLY WORRIED.
AS SOME OF THOSE HAVE BEEN IN
SOME OF OUR MOST
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
I THINK THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS.
THAT I I'D LOVE TO HAVE A
RESPONSE ONE WHO.
FROM ABOUT ONE IS RELATED TO
THIS CCA'S THERE'S BEEN SOME
COMMENTS MADE THAT THIS.
WOULD NOT I SUPPORT SOME OF THE
WORK THAT CCA'S ARE DOING AND
THE OTHER ONE IS TO WHAT AND.
IS BEING KIND OF REFER TO AS THE
S. EXCLUSIVITY OF GEOTHERMAL
WHAT THE SALTON SEA AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN. COMMENT
ON. THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS BUT IF YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THOSE.
SO SALTY REGION AS YOU'VE ALL
HEARD.
ME IN MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE.
CENTER WESSEL TALK ABOUT QUITE
CONSTANTLY. IS A.
BOTHA AN ENVIRONMENTAL.
CATASTROPHE IN THE PROCESS OF
HAPPENING.
AND AT THE SAME TIME A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY. ABOUT WITH THE
CLOSER TO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
GEOTHERMAL ENERGY.
RESOURCES AVAILABLE.
TO HELP MEET CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE IN RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOALS.
TOUGH FOR THE STATE.
WE HAVE A CIRCUMSTANCE AS I
ALLUDED TO EARLIER.
WHERE UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT THE
HIGHEST?
LEVEL.
IN THE STATE PAYING CLOSE TO
COLUSA COUNTY.
ONE OR TWO PERCENT GIVE OR TAKE.
AND WE HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO BOTH ADDRESS AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS HERE.
AND MEET CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
GOALS.
AND ADDRESS WHAT HAS BEEN.
A SYSTEMIC.
.
BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ISSUE IN THIS PART OF
THE STATE.
THE EXCLUSIVITY.
THAT IS REFERRED TO.
IS THE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
SAYING THAT A PERCENTAGE OF
GEOTHERMAL.
ENERGY SHOULD COME FROM THAT
REGION. IS TO ADDRESS.
THE POINTS THAT I'VE JUST MADE.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT NEEDS THIS
TYPE OF INVESTMENT.
TO TURN AROUND BOTH THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
EXIST AS WELL AS THE ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES
TODAY.
HA
IF.
WERE ALLOWED TO.
THE SALTON SEA REGION.
CAN
DEPLOY.
CLOSED ABOUT A THOUSAND.
.
MEGA WATTS.
OF JAIL DOOR MORE ENERGY.
WE HAVE THE TRANSMISSION THAT
EXIST AND THAT'S.
ACCORDING TO THE CALLASPO.
STUDY THAT WAS DONE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE REGIONAL
PARTNERS OUT THERE.
AND SO THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE. I AM.
YES IS IT IS AN EXCLUSIVITY IN
BUT THERE'S ALSO IT EXTRA
ORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES THERE.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
AS I MENTIONED BOTH ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ISSUES. AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES.
IN THE REGION.
CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF YOU.
HAVE SUPPORTED LEGISLATION.
THAT ENSURES THAT THE.
STATE IS MOVING FORWARD WITH A
SOLVENCY MANAGEMENT PLAN. TO
ADDRESS THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACTS OF.
S. C. DRYING UP IN.
EXACERBATING AIR QUALITY
PROBLEMS THAT ARE OUT THERE I
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY THIS BEFORE
SEVEN OUT OF TEN CHILDREN OUT
THERE SUFFER FROM RESPIRATORY.
DISEASE PROBLEMS.
.
I DON'T HAVE TO REITERATE IT
BUT.
YOU KNOW COUNTY THAT'S GOT
TWENTY SIX PERCENT UNEMPLOYMENT
IS CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING THAT.
IN A WE SHOULD BE VERY PROUD OF
WHEN WE WAVE THE FLAG THAT
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
IS THAT I GOT THE LOWEST.
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS FOUR
PERCENT THAT WE'VE EVER SEEN.
IN THE STATE.
BUT THERE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT THAT PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS.
SO I AM.
I LOOK AT THIS FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT. CALIFORNIA.
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO THIS
PART OF THE STATE.
IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED IN. MY
OPENING STATEMENTS AND IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY GOALS. AND THEY'RE
SITTING RIGHT THERE.
AT THE SOLVENCY.
REGARD THE CCA'S I THINK.
YOU KNOW PROBABLY WITH SOME OF
CAME TOGETHER THEY WERE NOT
THINKING OF SOME OF THIS OTHER
ENERGY AND RESOURCES.
THIS THE TIME WE WENT THROUGH
THE TABLE SO WE CAN HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SO I'M NOT PUTTING
ANYONE OUT THAT IS WHY WE ARE
TRYING TO TAKE A REALLY GOOD.
STRONG STRATEGY DOING THIS THIS
IS THE TIME WE CAN DO IT RIGHT.
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME AND I
REALLY THINK THAT.
WE ALL NEED TO BE AT THE TABLE
AND THEM. YOU KNOW I JUST I I
WANNA MAKE A REAL QUICK COMMENT
I'M WHICH I THOUGHT WAS.
GREAT THE I'M OF THE AT ONE THE
OPPOSITION WAS SMUG.
AND.
THERE'S THE ASSEMBLY THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD ACTOR.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE DOING
THE REALLY GOOD JOB.
SMUD WOULDN'T HAVE TO CHANGE A
THING TO COMPLY WITH THIS BILL.
THAT'S GREAT.
THIS BILL IS ENCOURAGING OTHER
ELECTRICITY PROVIDERS TO PROCURE
ENERGY IN THE SAME. IN THE
BALANCE WEIGHT THE* ALREADY
DOES.
SO I WANT OUR FOLKS AT THE TABLE
I WANT ALL OF US TO BE AT THE
TABLE.
AND.
FOR THE EARTH TO MAKE IT INTO
TO BE AT THE TABLE TO MAKE SURE
WE MAKE A GOOD OF A RELIABLE. A
WAY TO A DEAL WITH ENERGY GOING
FORWARD.
AND FINAL QUESTIONS IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE SOME
BLANKS IN THIS BILL WHO CAN YOU
WALK US THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING HOW THOSE BLANKS ARE
GOING TO BE FILLED OUT AND WHEN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL MIGHT BE
ABLE TO LEARN WHAT THOSE BLANKS.
WILL BE.
THE.
.
FIRST ITERATION OF THE
LEGISLATION HAD.
SOME NUMBERS THERE AND IT WAS
BOMB.
THE PRIOR COMMITTEE THAT DECIDED
TO KEEP THOSE.
BLANK IN THE INTERESTS OF
BEGINNING TO EXPAND.
THE CONVERSATION TO BECOME A BIT
MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE.
THE ISSUE OF THE.
RP S. POTENTIALLY INCREASING.
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE I
RP.
.
THE ISSUE OF REGIONALIZATION
TAKING PLACE.
TOOK PLACE LAST YEAR LIKE IT.
IT CONVERSATION THAT COMES UP
AGAIN.
.
AND SO THERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY.
BRING A LOT OF PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE.
AND TRY TO GET THIS RIGHT.
AND SO.
ALTHOUGH THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
I REPRESENT IN PURE COUNTY.
DID NOT FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE.
PICKING OUT THOSE PERCENTAGES.
THE IDEA OF BEING INTENTIONAL
RIGHT TO PROCURE GEOTHERMAL IN
OUR REGION IS IS HAS BEEN. PART
OF MY GOAL PART OF THE REGION'S
GOAL AND SO BY TAKING THOSE
PERCENTAGES OUT. IT REALLY
LEAVES US AGAIN.
IN A POSITION WHERE WE ARE
HOPEFUL.
RIGHT THAT THE MARKET WILL
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
GUILD THERMAL RENEWABLE TREE
BANK SHOULD BE INTEGRATED INTO
THE.
PROCUREMENT PROCESS AND MAYBE.
AND MAYBE WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP SOME OF THIS OUT THE
SONG SEE.
THAT WILL HELP AGAIN ARE.
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
RELATED TO A DYING SEE.
SO WHAT WERE.
I WRITE MORE EAGER MAYBE THAN.
MANY OF YOU HAVE THESE CONCERNS
WANT TO SEE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT PERCENTAGES GET BACK ON
THE TABLE AND REALLY THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. VIA THE
CONTINUED DIALOGUE.
OF THIS BILL IF IT MOVES
FORWARD.
THANK YOU AT LIKE I MENTIONED I
A DEATHLY HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL.
AND.
I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT THERE'SAN
INTEREST TO GET ALL THESE
CONCERNS.
AT YOU KNOW AT LEAST DISCUSSED
THAT ENOUGH THERE WILL BE FULLY
ADDRESS.
I'M AYE A WILL THAT SUPPORTED
TODAY BECAUSE I ALSO KNOW THAT
I'M IN A DISTRICT WITH MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES. OF BIOMASS SITTING THERE
NOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
ANSWER IS. UP BUT I I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION AND
IF THE BILL IN CONVERSATION
DOESN'T MOVE IN A DIRECTION THAT
I THINK IS CONSISTENT WITH. THE
BALANCING AN INTERSECTION OF
WHERE WE WANT TO GO IN TERMS OF
ENERGY.
A WHAT WE WANT TO DELIVER TO
CONSTITUENTS.
A AND.
YOU KNOW JUST AIR QUALITY OVER
ALL AND. YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
IF I WILL BE THERE ARE NOT I'M
ONCE IT COMES ON THE FLOOR BUT I
DO THINK THAT THIS IS.
IT'S A HARD CONVERSATION BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE FORCED TO
HAVE IT?
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MISTER
POSTED THEN MISTER STONE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
I I THINK YOU BOTH FOR TACKLING
SUCH A THORNY ISSUE HERE THIS IS
A CHALLENGING.
.
IF YOU TO BE ABLE TO TO ADDRESS
AND I TELL YOU I.
JUST LIKE YOU KNOW THE GOOD NEWS
BAD NEWS YOU KNOW IT'S AN AREA I
HAVE GOOD NEWS BAD NEWS ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT THE BAD NEWS THE
THING I DON'T LIKE ABOUT THE
SPILLS WHAT'S GOOD.
BEEN LAID OUT.
I'M NOT TOTALLY COMFORTABLE.
WITH. THE SALT SEA ISSUE ALL
RESPECT I I'VE BEEN DOWN THEM
MANY TIMES OVER THE YEARS. AND I
KNOW THERE'S SOME SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES IN YOUR DISTRICT AND I
THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE.
AS A SOCIETY FRANKLY BUT.
OUR THE EXCLUSIVITY SAUCY HAS ME
TROUBLE. THE. PERCENTAGE BEING
BEING GONE HAS ME TROUBLE NOT
BEING THERE AND I KNOW THAT
WASN'T YOUR CHOICE.
YOU THE AUTHOR'S CHOICE.
BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE.
AND OF COURSE RATE PAYER ISSUES
IN AND ALL THOSE KIND OF THINGS
BUT I THINK WHEN YOU BALANCE IT.
WITH THE FACT THAT ANYONE WHO
HAS BEEN ON.
TIMBER TOURS OR BEEN.
THAT YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE AG
SECTOR IT IS YOU WORK IN THE AG
SECTOR AND HAVING BEEN DOWN TALK
TO PEOPLE ON ACT.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
THERE AND I I SAW WE ALL SAW
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE WILD FIRES
WE ALL SAW THE THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION THE
LOSS OF LIFE THE COST OF THE
SURE IT'S COST. ON AND ON AND ON
I WON'T BELABOR THAT BUT WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT FIRES IN MY DISTRICT
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS BILL
WOULD WOULD REALLY HAVE
ADDRESSED THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE
THERE ARE MOSTLY YOU KNOW THE
BRUSH TYPE BUYERS WILL HAVE THE.
SOME OF THOSE SELF SAME ISSUES
BUT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT FROM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDPOINT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE I THINK TO
TAKE SOME OF THIS MATERIAL OUT.
DO THE RIGHT THING WITH IT
PRODUCE SOMETHING IN OUR
BASELOAD ENERGY IN OUR BASE LOW
THAT WE REALLY DESPERATELY NEED.
AND AND SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS SURROUNDING.
YOU KNOW THE COST OF BIOMASS
ETCETERA.
LOOK I I AGREE.
I THINK THE FREE MARKET SHOULD
DECIDE ALL OF THE STUFF YOU KNOW
BIG SURPRISE I KNOW YOU'RE ALL
SHOCK WERE WAY THAT SHIP SAILED.
AND WE SORT WEEKS WE.
SUBS.
SET UPON THEY MISSED THE
DIVESTMENT PUN OKAY.
WHAT THAT THAT SHIP SAILED AND
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IS
THAT WE DO SUBSIDIZE LOTS OF
THINGS INCLUDING SOLAR AND WIND
ENERGY? AND THEY DON'T WORK ALL
THE TIME AND WE ARE AS IS OUR
STATE GROSS FROM THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION TO FIFTY MILLION AS IS
PROJECTED TO DO WE NEED TO HAVE
ALL THE RESOURCES WE POSSIBLY
CAN BRING TO BEAR. AND I THINK
THE BASELOAD ANSWER HERE THAT
THAT THAT IS PROVIDING TO OUR
BASELOAD IS IS VERY IMPORTANT AT
THOSE TIMES ONLY.
.
I DON'T HAVE THAT THE ENERGY
THAT WE NECESSARILY NEED. I
THINK IT'S A PART OF US THAT THE
SOLUTION IS A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE IS A LOT OF WORK FREE TO
BE DONE DOWN ON THIS. I'M NOT
TOTALLY THERE YET BUT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
PARTICULARLY SINCE THIS IS THE
ONLY BILL. ADDRESSING ALL OF
THIS MATERIAL THIS YEAR SO LET'S
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION I'LL
SUPPORT IT RELUCTANTLY TODAY.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO.
IT AS ALWAYS I THINK
KIND OF REDUNDANT TO SAY THAT WE
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CHANGE OUR
OUR OUR VOTE ON THE FLOOR BUT.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE THAT THOUGH
THAT CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE ON
THIS PARTICULARLY WITH YOU KNOW
WITH UTILITY SECTOR WITH
CONSUMER GROUPS AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES.
AND OF COURSE THIS MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE CLEANEST
POSSIBLE SOLUTION IN THIS ROUND
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GET RID OF
THE MATERIAL SOMEHOW SO. THANK
FOR BRING US FOR AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY THANK YOU.
CHAU.
THANK YOU.
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD THIS
CONVERSATION.
EVERY YEAR FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS AND.
WERE.
WE'RE NO FURTHER WITH IT WHICH
IS FRUSTRATING DO I THINK
FRUSTRATING TO ALL OF US
LEGISLATURE CONSISTENTLY. HAS
TURNED DOWN THESE MANDATED
CONTRACTS APPROACHES.
AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S GOING
TO CHANGE EVEN IF THIS BILL
MOVES.
SO WE'VE BEEN HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS EVEN WITHOUT
NECESSARILY A BELL SO YOU KNOW
THIS CAN FACILITATE THAT OR NOT
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY A BIGGER
PICTURE.
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
CAUTIOUS.
AND.
IT I I HAVE BEEN DOWN SOLD CA
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH AND I'VE
TRIED TO HELP SENATOR HUESO EVEN
BACK WHEN HE WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
ON THIS ISSUE WITH WITH THE
SOLVENCY AND THEY'RE REALLY TWO
ISSUES GOING ON HERE.
THE BIOMASS ISSUE AND THEN THE
SALTON SEA.
AND EVEN THEN GEOTHERMAL ON TOP
OF THAT THEY THEY ARE DISTINCT
ISSUES.
AND EACH OF THEM ONE THINGS THAT
THAT.
THAT DOES DISTRESSED ME A LITTLE
BIT IS THIS IS A WAY OUT OF.
TRANSMISSION THIS IS A WAY NOT
OUT OF TRANSMISSION.
WE'RE STILL EVEN IF WE DO THAT
PUT THESE IN PLACE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
TRANSITION IN TRANSMISSION LINES
WITH.
AND MAYBE LESS OUT OF STATE BUT
THAT WE HAVE THE REGIONALIZATION
CONVERSATION WHICH IS THEN
MOVING.
TRANSMISSION LINES OUT OF STATE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BLEND IT
ALL TOGETHER SO I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO FRAME THIS WHAT THE
BENEFITS ARE IN THE BENEFITS
ARE.
FINDING A WAY TO. PUT MONEY INTO
THE SOLVENCY AREA I'M WITH. AND
IF THAT'S ULTIMATELY COST
SHIFTING THROUGH THE RATES THAT
GIVES ME SOME SOME HEARTBURN
MAYBE THERE ARE MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD WAYS ULTIMATELY
DOING THAT BECAUSE IF WE MANDATE
CONTRACTS WHICH HAS SPENT SOME
IN THIS LEGISLATURE AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN HAS SAID NO TO.
THEN WE ARE IN FACT PUTTING
BURDENS ON SOME OF THESE NAY
SAID CCA'S THAT ARE DEVELOPING.
AND MAKING THEM LESS COMPETITIVE
THAN THE THE OTHER MECHANISMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT'S IT
THAT'S A CONCERN AND FINING
SUBSIDIES WE SUBSIDIZE SOLAR YES
AND WHEN THAN WE HAVE DONE ALL
THAT. BUT NOT THROUGH THESE
MANDATED CONTRACTS.
WHICH WHICH CAN HAVE LONGER TERM
IMPLICATIONS IN FOR US TO
SUBSIDIZE A PARTICULAR IDEA OR
TECHNOLOGY OR CONCEPT HAS BEEN
INTERESTING TO LEGISLATURE FOR A
LONG TIME. THAT HAS DRIVEN
MARKETS
WE HAVE BECAUSE OF THAT THE SIZE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAS HAD SOME
VERY POSITIVE EFFECTS.
BUT AGAIN MANDATING THIS A
CONTRACTS IS IS WHAT. I'M REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THIS IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL SO IF THIS IS THE
ONLY MECHANISM TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. AND IT'S PROVEN BY
HISTORY NOT TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I I'M NOT SURE WHERE THAT WHERE
THAT LEAVES US.
AND THEN EVEN ON THAT THE BIO.
I HAVE ALWAYS HAD A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT BURNING THINGS AS
THE ANSWER EVEN THOUGH IT IS
BETTER THAN THE OPEN BURNING IN
THAT THERE ARE WAYS ABSOLUTELY
TO MANAGE IT. BUT WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL CAN BE PUTTING THOSE
FACILITIES. LOCATED IN EXACTLY
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE WANT TO
TRY TO PROTECT.
AND
THAT'S NOT WORKING AND BECAUSE
THE SCOPE OF ALL OF THE DEAD
TREES AND ALL THAT THE AREAS
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT
WOULD. THAT MEANS HAVING MANY
MANY BIOMASS FACILITIES CITED.
BUT ALSO MEANS TRANSMISSION
LINES OR WERE TRACKING THAT
MATERIAL IN.
AND ITEM THAT WE'VE ACCOUNTED
FOR ALL.
IN IN THE QUESTION OR IN THE
CONVERSATIONAL TIMIDLY THAT WERE
HAVING BECAUSE IT'S AN IN ALL
THIS AGAIN THIS IS KIND OF I
THINK YOUR POINT IS ITS ABOUT
TRADEOFFS.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT.
WHAT I CONTINUE A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF A BY A MASS IN
THE BURNING AT THAT LEVEL BUT I
AM INTERESTED IN THEIR COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE? SINCE GETTING EVEN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THIRTY PLUS
PERCENT OF THEIR ELECTRICITY
THAT IS PROVIDED BY MAP BY
BIOMASS AND THEY IMPORT BIOMASS
IN ORDER TO DRIVE THAT
ELECTRICITY INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THOSE ARE SOME VERY.
ECOLOGICALLY CLEAN COUNTRIES
WITH WITH GOOD GOOD AIR QUALITY
SO I THINK THERE ARE SOME SOME
MODELS OUT THERE. BUT IF IT'S
ABOUT RESTORING THE FACILITIES
THAT HAVE CLOSED DOWN OR ADDING
NEW FACILITIES WE'RE NOW ADDING
A LOT OF COMPLEXITY WE'RE ADDING
NEW AIR QUALITY QUESTIONS TO IT.
AND READING TRANSMISSION LINES
NOW. ALL OVER THE PLACE IF IN IF
WE HAVEN'T THOUGHT THAT THROUGH
I'M NOT SURE WHERE WE GO WITH
THIS.
SO LAST YEAR THERE WAS A BILL
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
PUSH A LOT OF AMENDMENTS THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORTED THEM NOT
QUITE SURE WHAT THAT THE CHAIR
IS GOING TO DO.
PROBABLY INCLINED TO TO FOLLOW
THE CHAIR AND HELP OUT BECAUSE
THIS IS THE THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S BEEN HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION BUT ALL THE
SUPPORTERS OUT THERE WHO WANT
THIS.
TO TO PASS THROUGH.
THIS HASN'T BEEN THE ANSWER.
THIS PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE THE
ANSWER THIS YEAR BECAUSE IT'S A
MY GUESS IS GONNA DIE AGAIN LIKE
IT'S DIED BEFORE EVERY SINGLE
TIME SO WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE
US.
WHY AREN'T WE WHAT'S THE REAL
ANSWER?
HOW DO WE PROVE AND AND THERE
ARE SYSTEMS THAT ARE LOOKING AT
THIS THE PC AND OTHERS TO TRY
AND AND PEACE ALL THESE THINGS
TOGETHER AND THEN THIS YEAR ON
TOP OF ALL OF THIS?
WE'RE GONNA SEE SOME THAT THE
UTILITIES ARE LOOKING FOR.
A CHANGE IN HOW LIABILITIES
CALCULATED.
AND IF THAT WORKS.
THEN GUESS WHO'S GOING TO BE
PICKING UP THAT LIABILITY WHICH
MEANS THERE NOW IT'S THE RATE
PAYERS IT'S THE HOMEOWNERS.
THEY'RE NOW PAYING A WHOLE LOT
MORE
SO WE'RE. WHICH WOULD ADDING
BURDEN ON TOP OF BURDEN IN. IN A
WAY IN SITUATION NOW BECAUSE OF
THE FIRES OF HIS SITUATION WE.
THAT IT'S REALLY UNCERTAIN.
SO I.
I FEEL YOUR PAIN I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. THERE'S A
LOT OF IT THAT I LIKE THAT HAVE
REALLY PUSHED AND STRETCH.
TO TRY AND HELP BEFORE BUT IT
JUST SEEMS AND THIS IS NOT YOUR
FAULT.
THIS JUST YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR WE'RE JUST IN THE SAME
PLACE.
AND SPINNING OUR WHEELS SO I
HOPE WE GET A LITTLE MORE
CREATIVE FIND SOME SOME WAY
ELSE.
TO TRULY INCENTIVIZE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE IF
THERE. IF IT'S WORTH IT A LITTLE
BIT A SUBSIDY MIGHT END UP
CREATING A MARKET.
BUT LONG TERM CONTRACTS IF THE
IF WE END UP SUPPORTING THEM AND
NOT DRIVING TECHNOLOGY AND NOT
CREATING THAT MARKET NOT
CREATING THAT INNOVATION THAT
THEN ULTIMATELY DRIVES COSTS
DOWN. AND WE JUST END UP IN A
POSITION OF OF. OF SUBSIDIZING
THROUGH THE RATES.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE GOING
ANYWHERE ANYWAY THAT I DON'T
THINK WE'VE DONE OURSELVES A
GREAT SERVICE.
SO THAT'S.
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT
LEAVES US RIGHT I THINK I THINK
IT NEEDS IS A PLACE WHERE I
THINK YOU NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN
THIS CONVERSATION.
I CAN APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM EVERYONE. THUS
FAR BUT YOURS IN PARTICULAR HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY. HELPFUL RIGHT IN
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN.
AND VOTING NO. RIGHT IS REALLY
NOT THAT GOING TO GET US
ANYWHERE DIFFERENT THAN AS YOU
JUST SAID. THEY WERE WE'VE BEEN
BEFORE. AND SO THE FACT IS I
THINK COMMITTEES ALL THE TIME
AND PEOPLE SAY I WOULD VOTE NO
ON YOUR BILL BUT I WANT TO BE IN
YOUR IN THE CONVERSATION. WHAT
LIGHT AND THAT AND YOU'RE
WELCOME TO WRITE NAY WE I THINK
THAT YOU BRING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF OF VALUE TO THE
DISCUSSION?
FOR US TO LOOK AT THIS
HOLISTICALLY ARE. THE ISSUES
THAT YOU RAISE AS IT RELATES TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
AS THEY'VE BEEN RAISED UP BY
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES HERE
INCLUDING FOLKS IN OUR DISTRICT.
DOT IDEA AND I KNOW HOW
CONCERNED YOU ARE ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AT IT AND
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND THAT
BRINGS. THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE BRINGS A LOT OF CREDIBILITY
TO THIS TO AUTHORIZATION AND SO.
WERE ROLLING UP OUR SLEEVES.
WE HAVEN'T PICKED A WHOLE LOT OF
EASY ISSUES OF THE THREE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN HERE TO WORK ON.
AND DON'T INTEND TO CHANGE THAT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THESE ARE PRESSING MATTERS IN MY
DISTRICT. AND THEY TIE INTO THE
OVERALL STATE.
CONVERSATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
AND SO.
AYE MULLIN.
WHEN IT COMES TO ROLLING UP OUR
SLEEVES.
A.
DEALING WITH THESE HARD ISSUES
AND IF WE CAN'T GET TO A PLACE
WHERE FOLKS FEEL COMFORTABLE
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF
YOU HAVE SAID THAT I WILL
RESERVE MY RIGHT. TO VOTE ON THE
BILL WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLOOR
IF IT COMES TO THE FLOOR. AND
IT.
DOESN'T DIE.
.
YOU KNOW THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
EXCLUSIVITY TO THE SALTON SEA
HAS COME UP.
YOU TELL ME ANOTHER PLACE ON
THIS CONTINENT.
THAT HAS THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES.
LIKE THE SONGS THE AREA DOES AS
A RELEASE A GEOTHERMAL.
THERE ISN'T.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THERE IS. OF
THE INTENTION HERE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE PROCURE SOME
ENERGY FROM THAT REGION TO HELP
US ADDRESS BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IN THAT.
THIS PART OF THE STATE SO.
I'D MISTER STONE AYE I WELCOME
YOUR PARTICIPATION.
DIRECTLY AND I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT MY COLLEAGUE THAT AS WELL.
I THINK WE CAN GET THINGS DONE
YEAH I AND. NOT JUST YOU BUT TO
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL.
IF THIS THING MOVES DIE
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE.
WE'RE GOING TO BACK HAVE THE
SAME CONVERSATION NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE WE HAD AT LAST YEAR WE
HAD A YEAR BEFORE WE'VE HAD IT
EVERY NUMBER OF YEARS.
SO NOTHING'S MOVING.
IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO MOVE
SOMETHING.
WE NEED SOMETHIN DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IT'S YOU WE CAN'T KEEP
TRYING THE SAME THING TO GET
THROUGH AND IT AND IT NOT WORK.
IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS IN THE SALTON SEA
WHICH I BELIEVE AND.
PROBLEMS WHICH PROBABLY MULTI
FACETED TO ADDRESSTHE LARGEST
AG WASTES BUT THE FORCE FIRE
ISSUES AND THAT. AND.
.
THE WAY THE FORCE OF GROWN IN
AND OUT OF THAT WE NEED TO BE
CLEARED OUT BECAUSE I'M NOT.
COMMENCING SO MANY COMMENCEMENT
OTHERWISE BUT WE JUST PUT SOME
BIOMASS PLANTS AROUND.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IT'S A MUCH BIGGER
PROBLEM THAN ABOUT.
WITHOUT NECESSARILY SOMETHING IN
MIND AND IF WE AND IF WE.
PAST THE HOUR THE RATEPAYERS TO
NOW PUT MONEY IN THROUGH THESE
LONG TERM CONTRACTS.
TO A SYSTEM OF.
BIOMASS FACILITIES THAT
ULTIMATELY DON'T.
HELP US SOLVE THE PROBLEM OR OR
ART LONG TERM SUCCESSFUL.
THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO ANSWER
THAT THAT AT SOME POINT IT SO
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S THE WAY
MAYBE WE NEED OTHER INVESTMENTS
ME WE NEED TO FIND SOME OTHER
WAY TO TO SPUR THAT TECHNOLOGY.
AND SEE AND SEE WHAT'S POSSIBLE
AND ANSWERING THEIR QUALITY
ISSUES ALONG THE WAY.
SO THAT'S.
AND.
SO WHAT WAS IS A TOUGH ISSUE IT
IS A TOUGH ISSUE AND.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW IT'S OUR JOB IS
LEGISLATORS TO MOVE THESE KIND
OF THINGS THROUGH AND AND
THERE'S THESE ARE TOUGH POLICIES
WE GOTTA FIGURE IT'S GONNA TAKE
A LONG TIME I'M DOES NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT I WANT YOU AT THE
TABLE.
AND I THINK I AGREE WITH.
AND SOME REMEMBER GARCIA.
IT'S OUR JOB TO ME YEAH HIS
LEGS SO TO SAY HOW THE STATE
SHOULD BE MORE SUSTAINABLE
MANAGER FOR US. ITS SUPPORT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT'S
PART OF THIS FOR.
AND SO.
.
I GROUP I DON'T OF THOSE ARE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BUT.
I HOPE THAT YOU THAT ALL OF US
STAND TOGETHER.
MAKE A CHANGE.
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME AND
THERE'S THE REASONS OF NOT
NUMBERS IN THINGS SOMETIMES
BECAUSE WE PUT IT YOU GUYS BILL
ABOUT THE NUMBERS NOT LOOKING A
HOLISTIC APPROACH. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING.
MOST SINCE BEEN MADE HER SECOND.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NIZAGARA CURRY MISTER GARCIA.
OF.
I THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE.
THAT WE ALL RESPECT HEALTH HARD
YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR YOUR.
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT.
YEAR IN YEAR OUT.
.
I.
LIKE TO ECHO MISTER STONE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW.
THERE IS A FRUSTRATION.
AND.
SPINNING. FEELING.
LIKE WE'RE SPINNING OUR WHEELS.
WITHOUT MOVING FORWARD.
.
BUT THAT IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
TALKED ABOUT. HOW IT'S OUR JOB
AND YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB?
EXCELLENTLY BOTH OF YOU.
I FEEL YOU KNOW AND I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS A LOT WAS
STAFF.
YOU NO AND MY DOING MY JOB AS
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE TO PASS
ON A BILL WITH BLANKS IN.
AND.
.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD SAY
NO.
FUNDAMENTALLY I AND YOU KNOW.
I I TO BELIEVE THAT.
THAT THE IRAQI PROCESS.
SHOULD.
.
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND THAT.
MY PRIMARY CONCERN IS.
THE IMPACT ON THE RATEPAYERS
ESPECIALLY. YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID
ON THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE ALSO AND.
WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION AT THE
LAST MEETING.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A LOT OF BIG
ISSUES REALIZATION.
CCA'S.
A WILDFIRE LIABILITY.
AND TO ADD THAT YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR YOUR
DISTRICT BUT OUR JOB IS TO LOOK
OUT FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HOW TO RESPECT TO THE AUTHORS
I'M GIVING A NON RECOMMENDATION
I NEVER TO CONVEY THAT TO THE?
TO THE.
COMMITTEE SO.
EVERYONE'S.
TO FOLLOW THEIR CONSCIENCE.
.
BUT I FEEL LIKE I I CANNOT VOTE
WITH THAT WITH THE BLANKS IN IT.
AND SO I WILL BE OF SPAIN.
JUST LIKE YOU'RE UP STATING WHAT
THE BLANKS IN THE BILL I GOT IT
STAINED.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
IF NOT NOW WHEN.
YEAH.
IF NOT NOW WHEN I WOULD ASK HIM
FOR THEM AND.
WERE COMMITTED TO DO IT TICKET
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE BLANKS.
AND.
.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING WE
DON'T HAVE MEN THIS BECAUSE A I
WANT THAT THE DISCUSSION TO BE
HOLISTIC OTHERWISE WERE JUST CAN
WE ARE. OVER A NUMBER.
SO WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR.
ENTERTAINING.
AND THIS PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW I.
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE SEEN.
FURTHER AND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS COME OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IN FACT MAYBE EVEN THE
PERCENTAGES AND WE COULD HAVE
GONE BACK TO YOU ANY AND. HAD
THAT DEBATE DISCUSSION THERE AS
WELL AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
SOMETHING THAT STAKEHOLDERS IN.
MY DISTRICT.
A BIT FRUSTRATED ABOUT.
THE OTHER IS PERHAPS YOU KNOW
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB IN ARTICULATING
THAT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT OUR
DISTRICT.
THIS IS ABOUT TRYING TO.
NEAT.
STATES RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS.
A CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES.
AT THE SAME TIME TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY.
ISN'T ONCE AGAIN LEFT BEHIND.
AND CONTINUE WITH THE SAME
PRACTICES.
THE SAME OUTCOMES.
AND ULTIMATELY CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION AND IT NOT
MOVE ANYWHERE.
AT SO YOU KNOW I. APPRECIATE THE
NON RECOMMENDATION AND
HOPEFULLY.
.
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
FURTHER EXTEND THIS DISCUSSION.
AND.
COME BACK THE AT SOME POINT
THAT BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
WHETHER BE WITH YOURSELF FOR.
YOU ANY IN AND FILL IN THOSE
BLANKS.
AND ONCE AGAIN HAVE THIS DEBATE
IS TO SEE IF AND PACKETS OF
WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE STATE. OP I KNOW NOW I
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF.
OUR DISTRICT.
AND WE'VE TRIED TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT IT. MEETS
MANY OF THE GOALS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS STEPPED FORWARD.
THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE STILL.
ABSOLUTELY AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
AND THE REST OF THE FOLKS WHO
RAISE THOSE QUESTIONS TODAY TO.
ENGAGE WITH US THEM DIRECTLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVALED.
A COLLEAGUES.
ALRIGHT.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE WE DO.
IS OUR SECOND.
SECOND RATE.
BROKE UP WITH.
ITEM SIX A. TWENTY TOOL EIGHT BY
AGRA CURRY AND EDUARDO GARCIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ON REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ROUTE TO CHIEF NOT FOR.
ROUTE TO GIN UP VOTING ACOSTA.
HI ACOSTA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA AYE
FLORA AYE LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
THE LENDERS KNOW RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE NO.
EIGHT.
SEVEN TWO.
BILL IS OUT THEY CAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
MISTER BIGELOW.
IF THE CHAIRMAN IF IT WOULD
PLEASE THE BODY.
HAS A.
COMMITMENT I WOULD FEEL
TERRIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GRACIOUS
OFFER.
WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION IS
FRIEDMAN.
THINK YOU COULD AFTER THEIR
CHAIR MEMBERS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS MEASURE.
THIS BILL WAS AN IDEA THAT I
HAD BASED ON.
WORK I'VE DONE WHEN I WAS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER WHERE WE
WOULD HAVE OF PEOPLE COME TO
PROPOSE PROJECTS IN FRONT OF MY
CITY COUNCIL. AND THERE'D BE A
LOT OF BAD THINGS IN THE SECRET
DOCUMENT THAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THE PROJECT WAS BUILT BUT THE
DOCUMENTS WERE BASICALLY SILENT
WHEN IT WOULD COME TO BAD THINGS
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU DIDN'T
BUILD THE PROJECT.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
INSURES THAT THE ECONOMIC LEGAL
SOCIAL TECHNOLOGICAL OR OTHER
BENEFITS INCLUDE REGION WIDER
STATEWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
OF A PROPOSED PROJECT. AND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF DENYING A
PROJECT OR INCORPORATED IN HOW A
PROJECT IS DESCRIBED EVALUATED
UNDER SEQUEL.
THIS WORKS TO A DO THIS WOULD
HELP TO EXPLAIN THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A PROJECTS DELAY
OR PROJECTS NOT PROJECTS
OBSTRUCTION. I'M AS THE NEED FOR
DENSITY IN URBAN AREAS INCREASES
INFILL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ARE OFTEN TARGETED.
TO YOU KNOW FOR ALL KINDS OF
REASONS BUT THIS WOULD HELP
EXPLAIN TO DECISION MAKERS WHAT
THE IMPACTS ARE OF NOT DOING
THAT PROJECT AND SECRET DOCTRINE
TO SUPPOSED TO GIVE US THE MOST
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION. SO THIS
WILL I FEEL AS SOMEONE WHO USED
TO HAVE TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND REALLY THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF NOT JUST DOING
A PROJECT BUT OF NOT DOING A
PROJECT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO ADDS
A METRIC OF BENEFIT IN THE STATE
OF OVERRIDING CONSIDERATION TO
ME I ARE TOTALLY IT AND SHE
NEEDS TO CONSIDER IN THE FINAL
DETERMINATION OF THE PROJECT.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW WE'VE GOT NO
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ROSS FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
VERY MUCH SO WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING YELLING COVERAGE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN WHERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BUT WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR LEAD AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS. OF THEIR
DENIAL OF A PROJECT ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S SO MANY COMMUNITY
ACTIVISTS OUT THERE SEEKING TO
PRESERVE THEIR OWN LITTLE SLICE
OF HEAVEN. IT'S USUALLY AT THE
EXPENSE
OF CALIFORNIANS WORKING POOR AT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES
THANK YOU.
Q. AND A FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
UP THE PLACE COME FOR.
ANGER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SYNC MS MELENDEZ THANK YOU KNOW
QUESTION I JUST WANNA MAKE A
COMMENT THIS WAS THE NINE
RECOMMENDATION FOR OUR CAUCUS
ANYWAY.
AND WHEN I FIRST READ THROUGH
THE BILL IN THE ANALYSIS I
SCRATCH MY HEAD A LITTLE BIT SO
THAT WHAT IS SHE UP TO.
BUT THE REALITY IS NO NO I MEAN
BECAUSE WE ARE THAT'S NOT YEAH
IT'S NOT MEANT TO BE AN INSULT
THAT'S MEANT TO BE THAT WE ARE
TYPICALLY ON OPPOSITE SIDES OF
ISSUES LIKE THIS I'M.
BUT I THINK THAT HAVING ALSO
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT EVEN
THOUGH.
.
YOU NO PROPONENTS CAN COME IN
ANY CITY COUNCIL MEETING IN
SHARE THE BENEFITS TO THE
COMMUNITY I THINK INCORPORATING
THEM INTO SOME OF THESE
DOCUMENTS ONLY HELPS TO IT KIND
OF.
FURTHER SOLIDIFY THE ARGUMENT
RATE SO I DON'T FIND ANYTHING
OBJECTIONABLE ABOUT. MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL I JUST
THINK IT MAKES SENSE I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SAYING THAT IS OUR MOTION.
MOTION AND SECOND IRATE.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS MS
FRIEDMAN WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I REQUEST WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHOSE RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE.
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I DON'T TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO CHIEF AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE.
ACOSTA.
NO ACOSTA NO CHAU.
CHAU I EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE STONE. STONE AYE.
LET'S.
EIGHT ONE.
SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW AND.
YOUR ITEMS NEXT.
THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY TWO.
WHICH ENJOYS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SECOND.
WHEN WE WROTE THESE TALKING
POINTS.
WE KIND OF WHICH WERE BEING
OPTIMISTIC WE WILL OF. BY
STARTING OUT BY SAYING GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
BETTER WE ARE.
APPROACHING WELL A LITTLE AFTER
SEVEN O'CLOCK NOW.
SO SIMPLY PUT I'M HERE TO
PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
TO REGARDING THE WOOD PRODUCTS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I CAN GIVE
A LENGTHY A DISCUSSION TO THIS
BILL.
AND I.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND I HAD TO HAVE A SOME OF THAT
CAME HERE TO SPEAK ON IT SO IF
YOU WOULD INDULGE.
THE SUPPORT PERSON PLEASE. AND
WILL ALLOW HER TO SPEAK.
CARE SINGLE BECKY WITH THE
pIN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TOTHE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN ENCOURAGE NEW
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS AND
PRODUCTS. THAT CAN
SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE THE
HEALTH AND RESILIENCY OF OUR
FORCE WE WERE READY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING PLUS ANALYSTS ITER
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE MET
MADERA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS BURNS ON BEHALF THIS YEAR
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AARON HER ALBUM ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
A BRIEF WAVE OF TIME MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HARBORS MAGNANI
ABOUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CEMENT ASSOCIATION. HOW OUR
CONCERNS REVOLVE AROUND A ANY
POTENTIAL AT SUBSIDIES FOR
COMPETITIVE PRODUCTS IN THE
BUILDING? INDUSTRY MARKETPLACE
HOT THE PORTIONS OF THE BILL
THAT THAT DEAL WITH MAKING
ACCESS TO A DEAD AND DYING TREES
AND LADDER FUELS WE FULLY
SUPPORT. IT'S WHEN THE BILL GOES
THAT ONE STEP FURTHER IN AND
POTENTIALLY CREATE SUBSIDIES FOR
COMPETING.
PRODUCTS THAT'S WHERE OUR
CONCERN IS RAISED. IF IT'S A
GOOD IDEA WE THINK THAT THAT
CAPITAL INVESTMENT WILL COME TO
THE STATE ON ITS OWN. THAT WITH
ACCESS TO THAT TO THAT FUEL SO A
POTENTIAL FEEL SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE YOU.
CHARLIE BREA CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR I GOT READY MIX
CONCRETE AND DEATH AND.
TESTAMENTO PRODUCERS AND.
AGAIN WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
NEED AND BEING ADDRESS THAT HAVE
THE SOME ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
FAVORING HERBS GIVING PRODUCTS
AND WE KNOW THE AUTHORS MADE
SOME SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS
ALREADY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THEIR. FURTHER AMENDMENTS
AND BUT WE DO HAVE A
RESPECTFULLY A CLOSE LISTEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS ARE CANADA
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER BIGELOW WAS
LIKE CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE IRATE AND THAT IS
WITH THE AMENDMENTS FOR A
CORRECT. ALRIGHT SHE BROKE UP
WITH YOU. ITEMS GOING TO AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ABOUT
SEARCHING AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
ACOSTA HIGH COST AYE CHAU. CHAU
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON. LOW MOAN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S
LONDIS IRAN'S.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE NINE TEN ZERO THEN BILL
ITSELF. THANK YOU MEMBERS IN
MISTER TECH ALRIGHT I SEE MISTER
BLOOM IN THE AUDIENCE
SO LET'S.
.
WHICH ITEM IS FOR THE.
WHICH FOURTEEN.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE MISTER BLUFF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. MEMBERS
STUCK CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PROGRAM WHICH IS
BETTER KNOWN AS THE BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM IS A SELF FUNDED PROGRAM
THAT ENCOURAGES CONSUMERS TO
RECYCLE. BEVERAGE CONTAINERS TO
PREVENT LETTERING.
OVER THE THREE DECADES OF ITS
OPERATION THE BOTTOM BILL
PROGRAM IS DIVERTED MANY MANY
MILLIONS OF BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
FROM LANDFILLS AND FOR MOST OF
THIS TIME IT'S BEEN SEEN AS A
MODEL RECYCLING PROGRAM. HOWEVER
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THAT
REPUTATION HAS TAKEN A BIT OF A
BEATING AGAIN THE. PROGRAM HAS
BEEN TRENDING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN APPROXIMATELY
ONE THIRD OF THE TOTAL IN STATE
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
SHUDDERED ITS OPERATIONS. USE OF
THE VERY PLACES WHERE CONSUMERS
RETURNED THEIR CONTAINERS OR
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RETURN THEIR
CONTAINERS TO GET THEIR MONEY
BACK.
THIS MASS INFRASTRUCTURE LOSS IS
A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
COMPOUNDING EFFECTS OF
PLUMMETING WORLD WILD WORLD WILL
HEIGHT COMMODITIES PRICES AND
THE REDUCTION IN STATE PAYMENTS
TO THE RECYCLERS LOCATED AND ARE
CONVENIENCE OUNCE.
THE MASSIVE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE LOS BROUGHT TO
LIGHT MANY OF THE EXISTING
ISSUES WITH THE PROGRAM IN THESE
ISSUES INCLUDE FRAUD WITHIN THE
PROGRAM THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAMS THE
PROGRAM'S RIGID STRUCTURE THAT
IMPEDED THE STATE'S ABILITY. TO
REACT TO CHANGING MARKET
CONDITIONS AND CONSUMER
BEHAVIORS AND THE PROGRAMS
ONGOING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND
FINALLY AN OVER RELIANCE ON
CONSUMERS FOR FINANCING THE
PROGRAM. IDEAS ON HOW TO REFORM
THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM HAVE
BEEN SUED YET A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION HAS REMAINED ELUSIVE.
TODAY THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
CONTRACTION IN THIS AREA THAT TO
MANY AREAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE LIMITED OR NO ACCESS TO
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES.
AND IN THE ABSENCE OF RECYCLING
CENTER NEARBY GROCERS ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW CURRENTLY TO
TAKE BACK THE CONTAINERS. OR PAY
A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY FINE.
BUT MOST TRAGICALLY IS THAT MORE
AND MORE CONTAINERS THAT COULD
BE AND SHOULD BE RECYCLED
RECYCLED ARE ENDING UP IN OUR
LANDFILLS OUR WATERWAYS. AND ARE
OCEAN SIMPLY BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
IS BROKEN.
IN FACT IN THE LATEST ANNUAL
REPORT PUBLISHED BY RECENT CAO
RECYCLE THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING RATE HAS NOW FALLEN
FIVE PERCENT SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AND HAS REACHED ITS
LOWEST LEVEL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
THIS DOWNWARD TREND IS EXPECTED
TO CONTINUE ABSENT IMMEDIATE
CHANGES.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE IS
NOT A PANACEA BUT IT ATTEMPTS
TO TAKE SMALL STEPS TO IMPROVE
AND MODERNIZE THE BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM BY. AUTHORIZING CAO
RECYCLE TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
TO PROVIDE IMPROVE CONVENIENCE
FOR CONSUMERS.
BY REMOVING OPERATIONAL
RESTRICTIONS WE HOPE TO ENABLE
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION WITHIN
THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF FUN APPREHENSION AROUND
PROVIDING CAO RECYCLE WITH THIS
AUTHORITY BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH. ON DEFINING
CONVENIENCE JUST DOESN'T WORK
FOR STATUS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR BY BOAT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
PLEASE GO FORWARD.
MARK VERY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
AGAINST WASTE UP WERE GOOD
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT LIKE THE
GENERAL THRUST OF THE
LEGISLATION NOT ENTIRELY
CONVINCED YET ABOUT THE IDEA OF
DEFERRING THAT'S REGULATION AS
OPPOSED TO JUST.
LET'S GET IT DONE IN THE
STATUTE.
BUT URGED AN AYE VOTE IN TERMS
OF AFFECTING THE BILL TAX.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ REPRESENTING TOM READ
NORTH AMERICA A.
BOTTLE BILL TECHNOLOGY PROVIDER
WHICH HAS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR
QUITE SOME TIME OF VERY
PREVALENT AND.
EUROPEAN IN THE EASTERN UNITED
STATES.
WE THINK SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM FOR. REALLY REVIEWS
BE VISITING THE ROLE OF
TECHNOLOGY AND AND THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO WORK FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. IN OTHER A DEPOSIT
SYSTEMS AND GO LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH A STAKEHOLDERS AND
STAFF TO CONTINUE WORK ON THE
BILL THANK YOU.
IF OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
SYDNEY OUT OF EVERY PLANET IN
SUPPORT.
DROPPED MY.
ALRIGHT WITH THE YOUR CLOTHES
MISTER BLOOM HAVE.
I THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
CLOSE THIS UP OF THE ANNIE.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS MISTER
NUMBERS THAT MISTER BILL I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LOCALS WILL STILL HAVE. I DON'T
SEE ANYWHERE IN HERE WERE TALKS
ABOUT LOCAL AUTHORITY JOB I'M
SERVING ON A CITY COUNCIL AND
LIVING IN A RESIDENTIAL AREA
THAT HAD PLENTY OF. A.
CONVENIENCE ON OPENING UP THAT.
DREW A LOT OF FOLKS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD TO GOING TO
PEOPLE'S BACKYARDS AND COLLECT
THINGS IN THAT CAMP OUT
OVERNIGHT.
OPEN UP IN THE MORNING.
A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS WITH RECYCLING
CENTERS.
A SO I'M WONDERING AS THESE ARE
BEING DEVELOPED HOW LOCALS ARE
STILL ABLE TO WEIGH IN TO BE
ABLE TO CLOSE ONE OF ITS A
PROBLEM OR HAVE SOME KIND
JURISDICTION. AROUND WHERE THESE
GO.
SO AT THE BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS IT IS CURRENTLY THIS
IS SOMETHING WE WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS THINGS STAND
NOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO HAVE.
I'M AUTHORITY AND WERE NOT
INTENDED TO TAKE IT AWAY FROM
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
BUT IF WE'RE ALLOWING COVER
CYCLE TO CREATE A NEW STANDARDS
IS THAT NOT. MEAN WILL THE
LOCALS BEAT.
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
YES.
WE'LL SEE.
WE WELCOME ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
BLOOM I WANTED TO WERE.
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE RECYCLERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL
AS CONSUMERS.
AYE AND RECEIVED A CONCERN THAT.
THE BILL INITIALLY GRANTED TOO
MUCH AUTHORITY CAL RECYCLE WITH
NO PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS.
AND SO I ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO.
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
WE DO LIKE CLOTHES YES SITE
BECOME ATTACHED TO IT BUT A AT
THE HIP TO ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THIS POINT AFTER
HAVING WORKED ON THIS ISSUE FOR
ABOUT. THREE YEARS.
IT IT'S VERY COMPLICATED AND
AND TOUGH AND I'M.
HOPEFUL THAT THIS IS GOING TO
GET US TO A PLACE WHERE THINGS
START TO IMPROVE AND I ASK.
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
THE SLAB BILL HAS A.
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS RATS IF YOU
AYE REFUGEE AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
CONSTANT AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA
AYE LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S IRENAEUS.
REYES AYE STONE.
SO NINE TEN ZERO.
DON'T GO OUT THANK YOU.
MR GARCIA. BACK FOR MORE.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY.
AND.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES ALSO WITH A. B.
NINETEEN SEVENTY PROP TODAY TO
PRESENT. THIS BILL TO PROMOTE
INNOVATIVE FUEL DEVELOPMENT.
S. VAMANA THANK THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
ACCEPTED COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. TO STAB JUSTICE AS A
PILOT PROGRAM LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORK WITH YOU. TO FIND
THAT LANGUAGE.
FORGET INTO WHAT THE BILL DOES.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AYE
HIGHLIGHT WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT
DO.
AS IN THE PROCESS WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
HAVE BEEN RAISED. FIRST A BILL
NOT TAKING THE COUNTRY POSITION
TO THE GOVERNOR'S ZERO MISSION
TRUST TRANSPORTATION GOALS. IN
FACT AT LEAST ONE OF FEELS THAT
COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL
THAT WE KNOW ABOUT TODAY
HYDROGEN IS A ZERO EMISSION FUEL
THAT'S ONE POINT.
POINT THEY RAISE THE BILL IS NOT
TAKING FUNDING FROM A NOBLE
NATURAL GAS PROJECTS THE STATUS
OF OVERALL FUNDING FOR BIOFUELS
PRODUCTION THAT ALIGNS WITH OUR
STATES.
NOTHING MITIGATION EMISSIONS
REDUCTION GOALS IS A SEPARATE
ALTHOUGH RELATED DISCUSSION. AND
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT DO IS.
NOT JUST ABOUT BENEFITING A
COMPANY OR A FUEL THE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL DEFINITION FOR
INNOVATIVE LOW CARBON FUEL IN
THE BILL WILL APPLY TO A VARIETY
OF FUELS. ON THE HORIZON TODAY
IN ADDITION TO THE NEW FUELS WE
HAVE NOT YET IDENTIFIED.
HE BE NINETEEN SEVENTIES ABOUT
LIGHTING OR MULTIPLE POLICY GOES
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA MEETS OUR
CLIMATE TARGETS WHILE ALSO
DEVELOPING AND DEPLOYING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN BENEFIT
OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
THAT DON'T HAVE OUR RESOURCES
FOR RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT.
SEVERAL YEARS INTO OUR EFFORTS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WE ARE HEARING THAT
NEW AND INNOVATIVE FUEL
PROVIDERS ARE HAVING TROUBLE
ACCESSING STATE. RESOURCES WHEN
COMPETING WITH FIRST GENERATION
FEELS THAT HISTORICALLY RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANT SUBSIDY AND ARE LESS
RISKY TWO PROJECT DEVELOPERS.
WHAT WE WANT TO FUND?
INTERVENTIONS THAT WILL MEET THE
NEED OF COMPLIANCE ENTITIES
TODAY.
WE WOULD MISS AN IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL OPPORTUNITY IF WE
DIDN'T USE SOME OF THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING. FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL TAKE
US FURTHER INTO THE FUTURE.
THIS WILL BENEFIT COMPANIES LIKE
THOSE OF MY DISTRICT.
BUT ALSO COMPANIES LIKE THEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME GAINING
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ENTER THE MARKET AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE INCENTIVES
AVAILABLE. THROUGH LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD CREDITS.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY WOULD HELP
PUSH CALIFORNIAN COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO BE THE WORLD LEADER
IN CLEANTECH INNOVATION ARCH
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING I REBEKAH BUJOR ON
THE PRESIDENT OF OBERON FEELS ON
MY PC CHEMIST BY TRAINING AND
FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS HAVE
WORKED FOR START UP COMPANIES
THE LAST SEVEN OF WHICH WITH
OBERON. EIGHTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
IS ABOUT PROMISING NEW FUELS AND
SUPPORTING THEM THROUGH THE
VALLEY OF DEATH. MOVING A
CONSTANT UP FROM A CONCEPT AN
IDEA TO THE COMMERCIALIZATION
PHASE. STARTED BY TWO SAN DIEGO
ENTREPRENEURS O'BRIEN'S THEY
CALIFORNIA HIM COMPANY FOCUS ON
CONVERTING WASEEM SEE DMB A
CLEAN BURNING DIESEL
REPLACEMENT.
DB PERFORMS LIKE DIESEL BUT
GENERATES NO PARTICULAR MATTER
HELPS CONTROL KNOCKS AND OFFER
SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED ONE PERCENT
REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GASES
WERE MADE FROM RENEWABLE
SOURCES.
OVER THE PAST SEVEN AND A HALF
YEARS INVESTORS HAVE PUT OVER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A PRIVATE
FUNDING INTO O'BRIEN RECEIVING
ZERO DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING.
AND ZERO AND FEDERAL FUNDING.
AROUND HAS A DEMONSTRATION
FACILITY IN IMPERIAL VALLEY.
PROVIDING FUEL FOR DEEMING
TRIALS AROUND THE WORLD REVOLVER
TRACKS
MAC IN FORT.
WITH ALL THIS PROGRESS HOWEVER
WE'RE STILL NOT AT THE POINT OF
COMMERCIALIZATION WE HAVE NOT
MADE IT THROUGH THE VALLEY OF
DETH.
THREE REASONS THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT
IT'S ABOUT CALIFORNIA MAY FEELS
AND CALIFORNIA INNOVATION.
AROUSE ONE COMPANY AMONG MANY
COMPANIES LIKE THIS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE
INDUSTRIAL MICROBES A SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA COMPANY
STARTED BY A GROUP OF BRILLIANT
MICROBIOLOGISTS IS USING
BACTERIA TO CONVERT NOTHING TO
CHEMICALS AND FEELS.
AND THIS TECHNOLOGIES VERTICALLY
PROMISING CONVERTING DAIRY
MANEUVER TO FUELS EXPRESSLY
SMALL DAIRY FARMS REYES NO
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE SOLUTION
TODAY FOR THEIR DAIRY BIOGAS.
TOO MANY PROMISING TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN HELP CALIFORNIA REACHES
ADMISSIONS GOALS
WON'T WILL DIE ON THE VINE IF WE
DON'T HELP BRIDGE THE VALLEY OF
DEATH.
NUMBER THREE THIS PAVES THE WAY
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF GREAT
MOLECULES.
WHILE RENEWABLE DME HYDROGEN AND
PROPANE ARE CALLED OUT AS
EXAMPLES IN THIS BILL. NONE OF
US WANT TO BE THE INNOVATIVE NEW
KIDS ON THE BLOCK FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW.
BUT BOY DID THAT WAY THE WAY THE
DEFINITION HAS BEEN CRAFTED WE
HIT A CERTAIN VOLUME WE REACH
COMMERCIALIZATION WE NO LONGER
QUALIFY. BUT WE HAVE PAVE THE
WAY FOR THE NEXT GREAT MOLECULES
THAT OTHERS WILL INVENT.
LET'S CONTINUE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE LAUNCHING PLACE
FOR INNOVATIVE FEELS.
IT.
FOR THE WITNESSES OR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
ANDREW CAN'T WE WILL SHOW YOU
HER AUNT'S WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN PROPANE.
GAS ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AS THE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT OUR
INDUSTRIES VERY MUCH INTERESTED
IN. UTILIZING PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
AND JUST REALLY LOOKING FOR
INCENTIVES TO FOSTER OF THE
CREATION AND USE A PRODUCTION OF
RENEWABLE PROPANE WHICH CAN BE.
A MAJOR FEEDSTOCKS AND MANY
REFINERIES TODAY HAVE THE
CAPACITY.
JUST A MATTER OF IF PENCILING
OUT AND SO THERE'S A COST
BENEFIT QUESTION BEING PART OF
THE LOW CARB FUEL STANDARD WOULD
VERY MUCH ALLOW US TO DO THAT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE LIKE TO
SEE THE DEMONSTRATIONS THE SPILL
THIS BILL AS A MEDICAL FOR.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A MICHAEL COATS FROM MONEY COME
REPRESENTING THE FULL. GROUP
NORTH AMERICA.
A ONE OF WORLD'S LARGEST.
PRODUCERS OF TRUCKS
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT BUSES
AND.
MARINE ENGINES.
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FOR.
YEAH GOOD EVENING THAT YOU'RE
MURATSUCHI MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE.
SOON EVERGARCIA I'M I'M
WRITING CAN BE CLEAN ENERGY ON
BEHALF OF OUR COALITION WHO HAS
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO. REMOVE THE UPPER
RIVER OF THE OPPOSITION PENDING.
THE PRINT OF AYE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE DO.
BELIEVE THAT THEY ANY POLICY
SHOULD BE IF YOU KNOW FEEL
MITCHELL. AND DATA BASED UPON.
PEOPLE PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL
WHILE FEELS THAT WE DO WELL LET
THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT I TO THE
LAST THREE YEARS THE BUDGET
PROCESS HAS TAKEN OUT.
IN STATE PRODUCTION. INCENTIVES
FOR BIOFUELS. ETHANOL BY A
METHOD ABOUT DIESEL.
WE DO YOUR JOB THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT A F. YOU'LL NEED FOR
POLICY IN SUPPORT OF AYE FURTHER
INCENTIVES.
BUT AT THIS TIME ABOUT TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION PENDING THE.
EMINENCE IN PRINT.
IF YOU.
WELL GOOD EVENING THOMAS LAWSON
CALIFORNIA TRIP GAPS VEHICLE
COALITION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS OFFICE ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
WE.
ALSO ARE MOVING OPPOSITION FROM
THE BILL OUT BE BECAUSE OF THE
MEMBERS FOR THE PILOT PROJECT WE
DO ONE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION AND HOPE AND
BEGIN A CONVERSATION ABOUT. HOW
THE STATE SUPPORT ABOUT BILLS
AND IN HOLE RIGHT THERE ARE A
LOT OF BAO FEELS ARE DOING?
YEOMAN'S WORK IN LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD AND WE THINK THAT
THERE IS NO ROOM TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT INNOVATION A BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE A SECURE POT OF
MONEY RIGHT IN IF YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO. HAVE THAT
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO PILOT
PROJECTS AND SOLO UP POLLS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THERE
ARE OTHER PROPOSALS ON ON THE
STATE ON THE REGULATORY SIDE SO.
WHILE SOME ARE LOOKING AT THIS
BILL BY ITSELF WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE ENTIRE SUITE OF ISSUES THAT
ARE FACED THEM OFF INDUSTRY. AND
WE HOPE TO HAVE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION AND
HOPE THAT BEGINS BUT WE THINK
ALL THE HARD WORK AND.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY.
JULIA ELEVEN WITH A BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL WE WOULD HAVE MOVED TO
OPPOSITION BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE WILL NOT. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT HE IS SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE IN THE CALL. WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO DEVELOP
DEFINITIONS OF THE DIFFERENT
RENEWABLE FUELS THEY'RE NOT
DEFINED IN THE BILL. AND HAS
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN RENEWABLE PROPANE THAT
SUDDENLY DO THINK. THAT'S GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT BUT HOW WE DO
THINK THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE
BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
THE GOALS ARE CRITICAL THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADLER
KNOWING HE JACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUELS
ALLIANCE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND WILL LIKELY BE
REMOVING OUR POSITION BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS BUT WE JUST NEED
TO SEE THEM IN PRINT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION DEMAND MINTS WILL
REMOVE THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
ALLOCATION. AND DIRECT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TO PROVE THREE
PILOT PROJECTS FOR INNOVATIVE
LOCAL LOW CARBON FUELS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
AS SURE AS SHE WAS LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE THANK
YOU. SIR.
ENJOYS A.
DO PASS
A CONDITION.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECOND.
I DON'T TO AB NINETEEN SEVENTY.
BY EDUARDO GARCIA DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO TREAT I RENTED
SHE AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA NO
CHILD.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ. LONDOS NO REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I SEVEN THREE BILLS UP.
HE WAS A CHAIR.
WE HAVE ONE BILL LEFT PRESENT
IN.
IT WILL BE TO HAVE ONE FELLOW
LIGHTER I'D HAVE TO HAVE.
WEEK TEAM WHERE I THINK THAT
AFRICAN.
AYE AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOR FIFTY THREE BILL TO
ADDRESS OUR POLLUTION EXPOSURE
AT SCHOOLS WANT THANK YOUR STAFF
AGAIN FOR. HARD WORK IN THE.
AN ANALYSIS THAT WAS PUT FORWARD
AND WE ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE
DIRECT AIR DISTRICTS TO
PRACTICALLY WORK WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
INTERVENTIONS. BABY AVAILABLE TO
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION EXPOSURE AS
A PRIORITY HEAVILY POLLUTION
BURN COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SIX ONE SEVEN.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE ANY
FUNDING MANDATE BUT SIMPLY OPENS
THE DOOR TO POTENTIAL FUNDING IF
IT'S A LOCAL PRIORITY AS WE WORK
TO ACHIEVE OTHER STATE CALLS.
AB TWENTY FOUR THREE MAKE
SIMPLE CHANGES TO HELP REDUCE
EXPOSURE TO AIR POLLUTION RIGHT
NOW AND FOR. OUR MOST. IMPORTANT
CONSTITUENCY OUR CHILDREN.
EXPECT GAS REVIVAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR GARCIA THIS AS A
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
SUPPORTING GO WITNESSES.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CAITLYN
REDNER SUTTER I'M A SENIOR
CLIMATE ANALYST WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE TO
INCLUDE AIR QUALITY AROUND
SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY IN THE MOST
HEAVILY BURDENED COMMUNITIES.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATIONS TWENTY SEVENTEEN
STATE OF THE AIRPORT EIGHT OF
THE TEN MOST POLLUTED CITIES FOR
PARTICULATE MATTER ARE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE TOP FOUR IN
THE COUNTRY ARE IN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHERE I LIVE.
THIS MOST IMPACTS CHILDREN AND
THE MOST VULNERABLE WHO ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE TO AIR
POLLUTION.
HE'S COMMUNITIES LIKE MODESTO
EARL CENTRO OR THE TYPES OF
COMMUNITIES ELIGIBLE FOR
COMMUNITY EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAM THROUGH CARB PER AB SIX
ONE SEVEN. THESE ARE COURSE
AMONG THE MOST STATE THE STATE'S
MOST HEAVILY BURDENED
COMMUNITIES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE
ALLOWS ANY FUNDING RECEIVED
THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO BE USED
TO REDUCE AIR POLLUTION EXPOSURE
AROUND SCHOOLS.
ENCOURAGING OR DISTRICTS TO WORK
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
ASSIST SCHOOLS IN FUNDING AND
IMPLEMENTING AIR QUALITY.
ADAPTATION AND MITIGATION
MEASURES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN CAN STUDY
AND PLAY IN A HEALTHY SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND FOR THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FOR.
KYLE JOHNSON CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MS
RADDATZ.
GARCIA I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MY
DISTRICT ALSO. AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD LIKE TO
BE CLOSED IT IS A CO AUTHOR.
NEARLY.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MR GARCIA WAS LIKE CLOSE.
EXPECT REST VARIABLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS A A CHOICE A.
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECREATIONAL.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE IS HER SECOND.
BROKAW PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY THREE BY EDUARDO GARCIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
RATS RICHIE AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE VARIOUS.
REYES I'VE STONE. STONE AYE NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO THE BILL'S OUT
THEY USE JIM THANK YOU.
OUR RATES WHERE WE HAVE MR
MCCARTY IS NOTS.
AS THIS VOLUNTARY NARRATE. IT
STRETCH ANYWAY.
THAT'S.
GETS.
OKAY.
YEAH NO THE THOUGHT AND THAT WAS
FOR MR GARCIA'S.
YES.
ALRIGHT MISS MCCARTY THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR ELEVEN THANK YOU FIRST OF
ALL LIKE TO I THINK IN THE STAFF
WORKING WITH US AND ACCEPT THE.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THANK USE OF THIS IS AN EFFORT
TO SPUR THE MARKET DEMAND FOR
COMPOST NO THIS COMMITTEES AND
WORKING LAST YEAR'S FOCUS ON.
ORGANICS THIS WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT. THESE. PRODUCTS ARE USED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BY ASKING THE STATE TO FOCUS ON
THE FEASIBILITY OF THE SOUTH'S
BEST PRACTICES THEY TO COMPOST
IN OUR STATE FACILITIES ACROSS
THE STATE.
COMPOST AS WE KNOW THE BIG A
GREENHOUSE GAS EMITTER BUT ALSO
WORKING ON COMPOSTING AND
ORGANICS CAN BE. A JOB CREATORS
ABOUT.
ASK YOU'RE AYE VOTE WITH ME IS
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
ALRIGHT LISTEN THIS BILL ENVOYS
A SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
WHO MADE THAT MOTION.
WHO MADE THAT MOTION?
HOW CAN MR ACOSTA AND AND MS
RICE SECOND IS?
HI GOOD EVENING I CROPS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE THIS
BOTH COMPLEMENTARY TO SOME
MEMBER LOW MOANS. MEASURE THEY
HEARD EARLIER IT TARGETS STATE
PROCUREMENT FOR COMPOST AND THAT
TOO AREAS ARE THE VOTING FREE.
CALTRANS AND AFTER FIRE
CLEANUPS.
.
WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THINKING IF YOU.
READ OUT OF SOME BEHALF OF A
JOHN WICK CO FOUNDERS MARIN
CARBON PROJECT. SO WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON SPELL VERY SAME
REASONS BELIEVE THIS BILLS
CREATE COMPANION MEASURE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN I.
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF COMPOST PRODUCERS
AND STRONG SUPPORT NEXT WEEK AS
COMPOST AWARENESS WEEK. RIGHT.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK A PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES.
A WE TALKED EARLIER A TODAY
ABOUT THE NEED FOR MARKETS
AND THIS MAKES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTNER IN CREATING
MARKETS FOR COMPOST.
TERRY L. WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
JUST MONTHLY COMPOSED COALITION
DATA.
DILIGENT'S ON BEHALF RECOLOGY IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA MELISSA SHY ORDER ENTRY
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA AND
THE WESTERN POSTURE WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
SPORT IN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE NON WITH MCCARTY.
MISLIM ON I JUST WANNA MAKE
COMMENT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS PART IS COMPLEMENTARY TO
THE BILL WE HAD AND I'D LOVE TO
BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR OF
PERHAPS HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE.
IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE AUTHOR
YES.
MANY OTHERS THIS SEGMENT.
YES. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT. YOU ARE AT.
MR MCCARTY THANK YOU HAS BEEN
LIVE THANK YOU.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED.
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
BROKE OFF PLEASE
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
ELEVEN BY MEMBER MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS BROUGHT SUIT
ON REFUGEE AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
ISLAND. LINDA'S AYE VARIOUS.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO.
IT WAS OUT THROUGH COSTA.
I BELIEVE YOU ARE NEXT IN LINE.
YES.
S..
OH YEAH I DON'T HAVE A FOLDER
ANYTHING BUT PASSED ASKED THAT
WE. ADOPT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
OTHER BILL ON THE DOCKET TODAY.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED THIS
IS FOR ADOPTION OF URGENCY
CLAUSE ONLY ON ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE.
SIR SECOND FOR THE MOTION.
SECOND.
ROLL.
ALRIGHT DOES SO.
WILL JUST TAKE THE A ROLL CALL.
ITEM THIRTY AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
NINE MCCARTY THE MOTION IS THAT
THE URGENCY BE ADOPTED AMEND AND
RE REFER TO NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ROUTE
SEARCHING I BROUGHT TO FEE AYE
ACOSTA AYE FOSSIL AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
FLORA. FLORA AYE LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ LINDA'S AYE REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
SO NINE TEN ZERO ZERO. RIGHT.
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I ALSO WROTE GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT SINCE THAT'S SHIP
DETAILED AS WELL I LOVE THAT
SCENE TODAY. A GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF A WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE.
A.
AS MENTIONED.
ALL AFTERNOON CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENTLY SUFFERING FROM AN
UNDISPUTED HOUSING SHORTAGE.
OF THE STATE NEEDS ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW
HOMES PER YEAR TO KEEP PACE WITH
THE DEMAND. BUT PRODUCES ONLY A
HUNDRED AND APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND MORE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE NEEDED BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO MEET INDUSTRIES
DEMANDS.
BUILDERS SAY THAT LABOR
SHORTAGES WERE SITTING AT THE
SAME TIME DEMAND FOR
CONSTRUCTION IS INCREASING.
ROUGHLY SEVENTY PERCENT OF
CONSTRUCTION FIRMS ARE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME FILLING HOURLY
CRAFT POSITIONS RESULTING IN
MANY FIRMS STRUGGLING TO PREVENT
LABORS FROM WALKING OFF THE JOB.
MADE PROJECT TO WORK FOR ANOTHER
COMPANY.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS HELPS EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLDS MANY OF WHOM ARE
AT RISK MINORITIES GAIN
VALUABLE.
EXPERIENCE REBUILDING TRAILS
PREVENTING AND FIGHTING
WILDFIRES AND FLOODS AND
INSTALLING ENERGY EFFICIENT
TECHNOLOGIES.
COR MEMBERS EARN MINIMUM WAGE
WILL SOONER MONTHLY STIPEND FOR
THEIR WORK AND ALSO COMPLETE
HIGH SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSEWORK. MANY CORPS
MEMBERS CREATE CREDIT THE
PROGRAM WITH HELPING THEM TO GET
THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK AND
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WILL
CREATE THE CONSTRUCTION CORPS
PILOT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS TO
PROVIDE AT RISK YOUTH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN CARPENTRY.
MASONRY DRY WALL ROOFING ANOTHER
CONSTRUCTION RELATED SKILLS TO
MEET THE INCREASING DEMAND FOR
SKILLED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
DID THE BILL WILL EXPAND THE
DEMONSTRABLY SUCCESSFUL CAUGHT
CONSERVATION CORPS MODEL AND
HELP THE STATE TRAIN MORE
MINORITY IN LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS FOR JOBS AND CAREER
FIELD PAN AVERAGE OF FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THERE IS A CLEAR NEED FOR MORE
HOUSING AND LABOR TO SUPPORT ITS
CONSTRUCTION.
ESTABLISHING A CONSERVATION A
CONSTRUCTION CORPS CAN ASSIST
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BY
REDUCING TURNOVER OF SKILLED
EMPLOYEES AND INCREASING
DIVERSITY AMONG LABORERS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WILL GIVE A
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEIR LIVES
ON TRACK. AND BREAK A CYCLE OF
POVERTY AND CRIME THAT ARE
TYPICAL OF THE COMMUNITIES.
THESE CORE MEMBERS COME FROM.
ESTABLISHING CONSTRUCTION CORPS
WITHIN CALLOUS CONSERVATION
CORPS ENABLES THE PROGRAM TO
REACH ALL REGIONS OF THE STATE.
WITH OVER TWO DOZEN RESIDENTIAL
AND NON RESIDENTIAL CENTERS
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
CONSTRUCTION CORPS CAN PARTNER
WITH LOCAL TRAINING PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND BUILDERS
TO RIDE THE RELEVANT TRAINING
AND EXPERTISE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY IS RICHARD
MARCUS AND WHO WILL.
GO AHEAD SORRY IT MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
IN MEMBERS SO RICHARD MARX AND
FOR THE SOCIT BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THAT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
IN ANTICIPATION OF THAT SOME
POTENTIAL OPPOSITION THAT WHAT
THIS IS REALLY INTENDED TO DO IS
TO.
DEVELOPED IN VIS A AT RISK
YOUTH OF AN APPRECIATION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS IS ABOUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT.
IT
DEPLOYING A HUNDREDS OF THESE
FOLKS.
TO REPLACE
EXPERIENCE DURING WORKERS ARE
REPLACE ANYONE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BUT TO
GIVE THEM A TASTE OF WHAT IT IS
OUGHT TO BE A SIMILAR TO WHAT
THEY'RE LEARNING IN SOME OF THE
OTHER FIELDS. A IT IS A AND A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM.
TO LEARN A CONSTRUCTION
TECHNIQUES AND TO THEN CONSIDER
A WHETHER THEY WOULD WANT TO GO
INTO A REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM OR INTO SOME OTHER CRAFT
TRAINING PROGRAM IN ORDER TO
BECOME ACCOMPLISHED JOURNEY
WORKERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
FIELD. A IT'S A GOOD A PLACE FOR
THEM TO START WE SUPPORTED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ AT
US ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS WE HEARD
TODAY IS A AND SUPPORTING
CONCEPT. THAT WE'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET BUT WE'VE APPRECIATED
TALKING TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE APPRECIATE HIS INITIATIVE AND
THE DIRECTION HE'S HEADING.
WELL WE'RE JUST GONNA CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM THAT
IS FOCUSED IN THOSE AREAS WHERE
IT'S NEEDED AND MAKE SURE WE
DON'T DUPLICATE IN OTHER AREAS
WHERE MAYBE IT'S NOT NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAINST PORN
CONCEPT THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
BAKER ANGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL A WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. A
WE THINK THE COMMITTEE OF FOR
THE AND THEN IT'S A NARROW THE
BILL.
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL BUT WE
UNFORTUNATELY STILL LEFT TO
OPPOSE.
MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE REMAIN
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL UP QUOTE
SAYS OF THE PURPOSES STATED
QUOTE TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR
SKILLED WORKERS INCREASE THE
STATE'S A PLAN HOUSING AND HELP
CORPS MEMBERS FIND CONSTRUCTION
LABOR JOBS.
WE DISAGREE FIRST OF ALL WHAT
THE FINAL CONCEPT THAT THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
THERE ARE FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
APPRENTICES. IN THE STATE TO PUT
THE PRESSURE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
FIFTY THOUSAND OF THOSE ARE THE
LABOR PROGRAMS.
OUR COUNCIL ALONE REPRESENTS
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
AS ONE OF THE MAIN DRIVERS
BEHIND THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARE IS ED THEM.
DECISION BY DEVELOPERS AND
CONTRACTORS TO NOT PAY LIVING
WAGES TO CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
TEAR UP EARNED TO. ATTRACT THEM
TO THE PROFESSION.
THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL OF
SHOWN TIME AND AGAIN.
THAT THEY ARE AMONG THE GROUPS
WHO ROUTINELY OPPOSE A SAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND A FAIR
WAGE STANDARDS FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
WAYS.
TO.
PAYKAN STRUCTURAL HERS AS LITTLE
AS POSSIBLE DID YOU WORK.
THE AUTHOR THE BILL SAID IT
CORRECTLY CAL CONSERVATION CORPS
MEMBERS EARN THE MINIMUM WAGE.
SO WE OF COURSE TO
PEOPLE TO BE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WHO WILL THEN EARN THE
MINIMUM WAGE INSTEAD OF OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS WAGES THE
CONSTRUCTION PACE NOW. SECONDLY
CONSTRUCTION AS WE ALL KNW IN
THE ROOM WAS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS JOBS AROUND. TWENTY
ONE PERCENT OF THE.
FATALITIES IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WASN'T
CONSTRUCTION THAT NUMBERS
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF ALL
FATALITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
KEY COMPONENT OF CONSTRUCTION
TRAINING IS THIS HEALTH AND
SAFETY COMPONENT.
OF THE TYPICAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM DEPENDING ON THE CRAFT
IS BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE YEARS
A LARGE PART OF THAT TIME NO
MATTER WHAT CRAFT IS. BECAUSE
LEARNING HEALTH AND SAFETY.
BEST PRACTICES.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS BY A IN AND IT. IS A
STATUTORY STATUTORILY REQUIRED
ONE YEAR PROGRAM.
SO CORPS MEMBERS IN IT FOR ONE
YEAR THERE'S N WAY THERE'S
ENOUGH TIME FOR CORPS MEMBER IN
THE PRO IN THE PILOT PROGRAM TO
LEARN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS. FUN
BEST PRACTICES THEY NEED TO KNOW
TO BE SAFE ON A JOB SITE.
AND ALL WRAPPED UP WITH THIS.
.
BY ASSUMING THAT ANYONE.
CAN DO CONSTRUCTION WORK.
IT'S DIMINISHING IN OUR OPINION
THE HIGHLY TECHNICAL AND
DETAILED TRAINING. THAT OUR
CRAFTS UNDERTAKE.
WE HAVE NO DOUBT THE AUTHOR
VALUES THE WORK OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS.
BUT AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
IN OUR OPINION WOULD BE THE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS CREATING A
POOL OF WORKERS WHO WILL WORK
FOR MINIMUM WAGE.
THEREBY TAKING CONSTRUCTION
CAREER JOBS AWAY FROM JOURNEY
MEN AND WOMEN.
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AWAY
FROM APPRENTICES TO LEARN THE
CRAFT THERE'S ALREADY A PLACE TO
LEARN HOW TO BE CONSTRUCTION
WORKER IT'S IN THE STATE OF
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN BROUGHT FORTH
UNDER THE GUISE OF A COME.
SEE OF LACK OF CONSTRUCTION OR
THE STATE WE JUST BUT AMENITIES
AGREE WITH THAT WE URGE OR KNOW
ABOUT THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GONNA BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL. THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS.
WITHOUT DELIVERING THE POINTS
THAT MISTER SMITH MADE I THINK
IT'S SIMPLE NOT TO SAY THAT IF
YOU WANNA LEARN HOW TO DO
CONSTRUCTION WORK. YOU NEED TO
BE IN A JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
MY QUEST ON BEHALF OF
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS
MITCH DYER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING QUE DONAHUE DURAN
WITH THE CITY COUNCIL LABORERS
JUST WONDERED BRIEFLY APOLOGIZE
TO COMMITTEE FIRST MEETING ARE
LITTERED LATE LAST WEEK AND ALSO
NOTE THAT WE.
DID SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR STOP
THIS MORNING TO DISCUSS OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THIS IS PATH LEADING.
TO ME TO LISTEN TO THE
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD AND
SUGGEST THAT IF WE ALLOW THE
CONSERVATION CORPS TO HAVE THIS
PROGRAM THAT IT WILL PUT
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS OUT OF WORK THAT IS.
FASCINATING TO ME ALSO FLATLY
FOX.
I THIS IS A PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
HELP AT RISK YOUTH
NOTHING MORE. THEY GET INTO THIS
PROGRAM THEN THEY'D THEY CAN
PERHAPS.
FIGURE OUT.
IF THAT'S AN AREA OF INDUSTRY
THEY WANT TO GO INTO AT ALL
MAYBE THEY DO MAYBE THEY DON'T.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED FOR IF IF YOU'VE BEEN
TO ONE IN THESE CAMPS.
.
I MEAN.
I HAVE ONE OF OUR I HAVE BECAUSE
REGION CORPS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
I VISITS MASSIVE I'M IT'S
INCREDIBLE WHAT THESE KIDS DO
THEIR THE YOUNG ADULTS.
THIS IS ON OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO LEARN TO LEARN SOME SKILLS IN
TREES A DANE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
PERHAPS THEY DIDN'T THEY THEN.
GROPING A HOUSEHOLD WHERE
SOMEBODY WAS MEANT TOURING THEM
AND TEACHING THEM THESE TYPES
OF.
TRADES SKILLS THAT THEY MAY NEED
THIS IS.
BUT THIS IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
LABOR THIS IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
IT.
THE TRAINING THAT LABOR UNIONS
PROVIDE I ASSURE YOU THERE WILL
NOT BE. AT A BATTLE FOR JOBS IF
THE CONSERVATION CORPS ALLOWS
THIS TRAINING PROGRAM GOING TO
PLACE A PROMISE SHE SAT.
I'M.
MR ACCOSTED YOU I DON'T IF YOU
WANT ADDRESSING YOUR CLOTHES OR
NOW BUT I'M JUST WONDERING DO
YOU HAVE SOME SORT OF COMMENT OR
REBUTTAL TO THE STATEMENTS THAT
WERE MADE AND BEFORE YOU.
ANSWER THAT THOUGH I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE IN THINKING AS WANT IS THAT
YOU KNOW I'M I'M A LITTLE BUT
BEFUDDLED ONLY BECAUSE.
WE HAD NO OPPOSITION UNTIL
FRANKLY THURSDAY NIGHT WHICH
WERE ALL GONE AND.
EARLY THIS MORNING AND IT'S IT'S
A LITTLE FRUSTRATING WHEN OUR
FIRST MEETINGS WITH THESE
ORGANIZATIONS WERE IN JANUARY.
.
I I'M I'M TRYING TO YOU KNOW
KEEP KEEP MY COMPOSURE BECAUSE I
AM ONE OF THOSE AT RISK YOUTH.
THAT ARE BEING TALKED ABOUT
HERE.
I AM.
.
BUT I'M GONNA STICK TO MS
MELENDEZ SPECIFIC QUESTION OR
COMMENT ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE. YOU
KNOW THAT WAS BROUGHT UP IN THE
BILL BUT IF IF THE.
OPPOSITION WAS LISTENING.
AND AYE I'VE NEVER BEEN ACCUSED
OF NOT BEING ALLOWED ENOUGH FOR
PEOPLE TO HEAR ME.
I ALSO STATED THAT THESE JOBS
AVERAGE FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE FOLKS.
THAT'S WHAT THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS
HERE'S TO EXPOSE AT RISK YOUTH
USE AT RISK YOUTH.
IT'S LATE AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BESIDES.
THE CHALLENGES OF THEIR LIFE
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY LIKE
THE REST OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO EARN THEIR
G. E. DIS THESE ARE YOUNG.
PEOPLE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WITHOUT.
THIRD THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS IN MANY MANY CASES.
THESE ARE A YOUNG KIDS THAT
AREN'T BEING PICKED UP BY THESE
UNION APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
WHICH GOD BLESS THEM THAT
THEY'RE THERE THAT'S WONDERFUL
BUT NOT EVERYBODY FITS INTO ONE
MODEL WE HEARD ABOUT. SO MANY IN
SO MANY OF OUR BILLS TODAY WE
HEARD ABOUT HOW.
ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL
DOESN'T FIT ALL FOR THE WHOLE
STATE EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
HEARING IN WILL IN IN ONE
COMMITTEE AFTER ANOTHER. WERE
GETTING ACCUSED OF TRYING TO DO
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL WELL HERE I
HAVE THE OPPOSITION UP YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT THERE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL ANSWER.
WORKS FOR EVERY SINGLE CHILD IN
THIS STATE AND I HAVE I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU THAT.
.
HAD IT NOT BEEN AFTER MY FATHER
DIED WHEN I WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD
FOR A MAN NAMED BOB KANA.
WHO TOOK ME UNDER HIS WING ALONG
WITH MY FRIEND MY BEST FRIEND
WHO WHO IS HIS SON?
AND KEPT ME VERY BUSY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
I KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT I
HAVE WORKED IN INSULATION IN
ATTICS PUTTING AND LAYING
INSULATION IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IN THE SUMMER.
I WAS A LOT THINNER THAN SITE
THAT FIT TO THE RAFTERS A LITTLE
BETTER.
AND I AND I'VE DONE PLUMBING AND
I'VE DONE ELECTRICAL WORK AND
I'VE WORKED IN A AUTOMOTIVE
GARAGES ET CETERA. I KNOW WHAT
THESE JOBS ENTAIL AND I KNOW THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO
ELEVATE SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BY GIVING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY AND A SHOT.
AND I HE I'M HERE TO TELL YOU.
BUT WE IT WILL BUT FOR NOT A GUY
LIKE BOB CONNELL AND A FEW
OTHERS IN MY LIFE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE I WOULD BE TODAY.
I CERTAINLY WOULD BE MARRIED TO
A BEAUTIFUL WONDERFUL WIFE WITH
THREE AMAZING CHILDREN. AND
SERVING IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STATE LEGISLATURE MOST LIKELY.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
THIS BILL IS KEY IS BORN OUT OF
ONE THING AND THAT'S A PASSION
FOR OUR YOUTH.
A PASSION FOR KIDS THAT NEED AN
OPPORTUNITY.
AN OPPORTUNITY THERE I'M ALL OF
US SITTING AROUND ERE TODAY
EVERYONE IN THIS AUDIENCE HAS
HAD SOMEONE THEIR LIFE.
SOMEBODY GIVE HIM A SHOT.
AND WHEN I HERE.
THE THESE THESE THE THE
OPPOSITION I AM LIKE WAR WHERE
YOU I'M I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THESE ISSUES LET'S LET'S.
IMPROVE THIS BILL BUT THIS
REALLY IF IF IF IF BILL IS BE
IMPROVED.
BUT.
THE.
LAKE OPPOSITION IS PROBABLY THE
MOST STRESS RESTFUL THING FOR
ANY OF US.
THAT'S THAT WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE YOU'VE REACHED OUT
YOU'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS YOU HAD
MEETINGS YOU'VE DONE YOUR
HOMEWORK YOU DON YOU DO
DILIGENCE AND THE LAST MINUTE.
POOF WORK WERE OBJECTING TO YOUR
BILL AND I REALLY RESENT THAT.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT TODAY. IS THE.
IMPACT.
THAT THIS KIND OF A PROGRAM WILL
HAVE ON A FEW KIDS LIVES.
IN OUR STATE.
AND. YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AYE I WENT ON AFTER A QUESTION
IF THERE'S ANY MORE QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ENTERTAINED
THEM.
.
THERE. AS THIS BILL AND YOU
SHORT I. AND PANEL AND. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AT.
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY VISIT SOME OF THESE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT OUR AT LABOR.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HAVE PUT
TOGETHER AND.
YOU MADE A COMMENT THAT THESE
ARE NOT THE TYPES OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE PICKED UP.
I HAVE SEEN.
OTHERWISE.
I ACTUALLY HAVE SEEN THESE
APPRENTICESHIP BUT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS PROVIDED
BY LABOR WHO DO.
I HAVE REALLY DIVERSE.
A WITH MEN AND WOMEN OF
DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE.
THIS YEAR OF SOME REENTRY SOME
NEW AND SO HOW WHAT WHAT.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THIS IS NOT IT
WHAT REALLY MAKES YOUR PROGRAM
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING AND.
AND YET BECAUSE THEY BECAUSE I
GUESS I EXPLAINED THE SAME HE'S
YEAH YOU JUMP GROUP YEAH YOU YOU
HONED IN ON THAT BY THE WAY.
I I BELIEVE I SAID OFTENTIMES
BUT IF I DIDN'T I I CERTAINLY
MEANT THAT ONE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTIC OF THIS AND ALSO
THE THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS. IS THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
THEIR GED.
WHILE THEY'RE DOING THIS PROGRAM
WHILE EARNING BURNING MONEY
GETTING A GED AND ALSO LEARNING
VALUABLE SKILLS I THINK THAT'S
REALLY ONE OF THE MOST OF THOSE
BUT THAT DOESN'T DEFINING
FACTORS BUT TO SAY. THAT. ONLY
ONE WHAT DOES ONE PATH AND IS
ONLY ONE PATH.
I I YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
BUILDS LITTLE LITTLE BRIDGES
OVER CREEK THEY HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT.
AND MAYBE LABOR DOESN'T LIKE
THAT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WHY IS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS SO
SUCCESSFUL IN SO MANY AREAS OF
OUR STATE. AND I THINK THIS
ISN'T JUST A SMALL ADDITION TO
THEIR MISSION US AT A A SLIGHT
VARIATION ON THE THEME YOU KNOW
IT BASICALLY BUILT ON THE SAME
KIND OF OF SKILLS. AND THIS IS
ANOTHER AVENUE IN ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR MAYBE SOMEONE
THAT DOESN'T FIT THERE DOESN'T
WANT TO DO IT WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE AT THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM. NO ONE'S GONNA MAKE
ANYBODY DO ANYTHING
CERTAINLY THAT THEY CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THAT AFTER THEY'VE
DONE THIS AND GOTTEN A TASTE AND
GOT MY GED THEN THEY'RE GONNA BE
MORE VALUABLE TO THE SOPRANO
SHIP PROGRAMS. AS THEY GO
FORWARD SO IF I MISSPOKE I
APOLOGIZE.
AND THIS CERTAINLY DIDN'T THERE
IS NO MENTION IN HERE OF
ANYTHING ABOUT LABOR THIS IS
ABOUT THE KIDS.
AND SO LAST MINUTE WE WE DO GET
THE OPPOSITION.
I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH THEM
SINCE JANUARY SINCE WE REACHED
OUT AND I CONTINUE TO WORK WORK
WITH ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
INCLUDING YOURSELF THAT WAS
STOLEN FROM A SPELL. AND MAKE IT
THE BEST BILL POSSIBLE FOR KIDS.
THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
MISTER COST AYE FIVE MINUTES THE
ENTIRE DEBATE TO THIS THING
START OVER TO ONE SURE WHAT
TIDES AND MAYBE WE COULD FOR
HIM.
WE'RE HERE ALL NIGHT SPRING UP
ON MISTER SMITH FROM THE US
FOOD.
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES.
REPEAT WHAT HE ARE THE SENATE
FOR THE AYE AYE WHY I MISS STEP
OFF THE QUESTION.
SO I I AM FAMILIAR WITH THE
INTENT OF YOUR BILL WE ALL OF
THE CONSERVATION CORPS IT'S ONE
OF THE GREAT PROGRAMS GOVERNOR
CREATE OF COURSE THAT.
I'M HEADS I AM FAMILIAR A LITTLE
BIT TOO LOCALLY FROM OUR CITY
COUNCIL THE REHAB THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THERE IS
THAT. THERE IS THAT THE UNION.
AND PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
HERE AND CCT. THERE'S A YOUTH
BUILD KIND OF A CONSERVATION
CORPS TYPE PROGRAM AND THEIR PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND SO
IS THE IDEA YOU'RE CUTTING HERE
BE A FULL SAIL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM MORE. LIKE A TRADITIONAL
PRE APPRENTICE PROGRAM TO
PREPARE PEOPLE TO MAYBE ENGAGED
WITH THAT STATE BUILDING.
TRAITS ADDRESSED MY IF YOU
ASKED HIM AYE I'LL ASK YOU FOR
OKAY THAT YEAH IT ASK YOU
CANCERS THAT YEAH Y. AGAIN HAS
THE FIRST WE'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO GOOD TO SEE CERTAIN
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
.
I ENVISION IT AS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY NOTHER AVENUE FOR
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AS AS A AT THE END YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION TO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING. TO BASICALLY BE ABLE TO
EXPAND IT SLIGHTLY BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE STUDENTS GET THEIR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE GET THEIR GED
SO DON'T HAVE THEM THESE ARE
THIS IS GEARED TOWARD EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLDS. AND TO
BE ABLE TO PICK UP SOME VALUABLE
LIFE SKILLS WHAT THEY DO WITH
THOSE LIFE SKILLS AFTER AS
MENTIONED A YEAR.
GOD BLESS MY HOPE THEY GO INTO
A FULL FULL FLEDGED.
YOU KNOW UNION PROGRAM OR
OTHERWISE WHATEVER THEY DECIDE
TO DO BUT TO ASSUME THAT
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO BE.
SLOTTED DOWN ONE WAY I THINK IS.
IT IS IS NOT ACCURATE IT
CERTAINLY WAS I WORK A LOT OF.
JOBS LIKE THAT AND I'M NOT AND I
I'VE BEEN IN THE SUIT AND TIE.
SIX TO SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
PROBABLY EXCEPT ON WEEKENDS WHEN
I'M REBUILDING CARS ARE RETYPING
MY HOUSE.
I.
UNDERSTAND WHERE THESE KIDS ARE
COMING FROM A WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY ANOTHER.
IT VENUE SO TO ANSWER QUESTION
I THINK I LOOK AT IT IS MORE OF
A OF A. PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WOULD BE MORE ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT THERE
IS TO IT YOU WANNA ENGAGE ON
THAT AS FAR AS YOU KNOW COULD
THIS BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO ENHANCE THE EXISTING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM STRUCK
CALIFORNIAN BE LEN ABOUT
PIPELINE AS A CAB PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION TO
THE CHAIR I WOULD I WOULD ANSWER
THAT.
YOU KNOW PRE APPRENTICESHIP IS
VERY VITAL.
WHAT'S BUT WHAT.
WE HAVE FOUND OFTEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IS.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME PEOPLE THINK
THEY WANT TO BE AN IRON WORKER.
AND THEY GET TO THE FORTY FLOOR.
AND THEY REALIZE THAT GIVING I
WORKER.
THERE'S OTHER EXAMPLES LIKE
THAT'S A PREPRESS SHIPPED IS A
SORT OF VERY GOOD PURPOSE AND.
I LETTING PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S.
IS OUT THERE WHAT A
CONSTRUCTION CAREER IS LIKE AND
WE HAVE OUR OWN A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
EXPOSES. A THE.
PREFERENCES TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
HOURS OF BUT. OF STUDY A OF ALL
THE CRAFTS TOGETHER MY IDEA. OF
ABOUT WHAT A CRAFT IS WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE TRISH KNOWS WHAT A
PLUMBER IS AND WHAT THEY DO. AS
A PRE PARTNERSHIP IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
WE.
BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW.
SINCE.
NINETY OVER NINETY PERCENT OF
THE STATE APPROVED A PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS THE UNION PROGRAMS THAT
USING THE CURRICULUM.
THAT THEY WOULD GIVE ENTRANCE
INTO THE MOST NUMBER OF THOSE
PROGRAMS MAKES THE MOST SENSE
WHEN IT COMES A PAIR
PARTNERSHIP.
AND I WOULD JUST FINISH BY
SAYING.
THAT.
WHEN IT COMES AT RISK YOUTH.
JUST THE MOST OF THE THAT THE
THE BIGGEST EXAMPLE I HAVE IS
THAT FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT.
THE IRON WORKERS UNION FRESNO
TOOK IN THREE HUNDRED
APPRENTICES HALF OF WHOM DID NOT
HAVE THEIR GED.
THE IRON WORKERS UNION WORK WITH
ALL OF THEM TO GET THEIR GED IS
AND THEN THEY BECAME
APPRENTICES.
SO WE ARE ALL ABOUT AT RISK
YOUTH WE ARE ALL ABOUT THE
PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT PIPELINE
AND FIGURING OUT HOW TO PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK WHETHER THERE.
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
TO FOLKS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED AND THEN I'LL
FINALLY SAY THE OTHER WAY TO DO
THIS IS TO INCREASE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION HIGH
SCHOOLS.
GIVE THESE KIDS GIVE THESE YOUNG
KIDS AN IDEA OF WHAT IT IS TO
WORK WITH YOUR HANDS AND LET
THEM KNOW THERE'S A WORLD OF
WORK OUT THERE DOES REQUIRE FOUR
YEAR UNIVERSITY DEGREE.
SO I PREVENT YOUR QUESTIONS
MCCARTY
.
I I JUST WITH JUST ONE THING.
YOU KNOW I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
THAT ANY.
YEAH I NEED.
.
ORGANIZATION THE IRON WORKERS
ARE HELPING THE STUDENTS GET
THEIR GED SAYS A STRUCTURED
PROGRAM. THAT THEY WILL BE
GETTING THEIR GT'S.
SHOULD THEY COMPLETED OF COURSE
AND IT NO WAY INTERFERES WITH
ANYTHING ANYONE IS DOING AND
ORGANIZED LABOR AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT THE INTENT. OF THE
INTENT IS.
IF THE IF THE GOAL IS TO HELP.
AT RISK YOUTH AND AS STATED BY
THE OPPOSITION THEY'RE ALL ABOUT
THAT.
WE BROUGHT THIS TO THEM IN
JANUARY WE'D LOVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM.
IDEA I WOULD I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU IF YOU REALLY MEAN THAT
THEN.
RIVER OPPOSITION LET'S WORK ON
THIS BILL TOGETHER AND LET'S
MOVE IT FORWARD AND HELP THESE
KIDS.
BUT I SENSE THAT SINCE WE
TALKED ABOUT IN JANUARY WERE IN
APRIL NOW AND MORE IT FISCAL
DEADLINES ETCETERA.
WITH THIS LATE OPPOSITION.
ALL I CAN. ALL I CAN ASSUME IS
THAT MAYBE THAT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE MOTIVE AND I APOLOGIZE BUT
IT IS LATE AND.
IT'S IT'S A BIT FRUSTRATING TO.
THE HOUSE AND LET OUR I
RESPECTFULLY.
FOR THE KIDS ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT.
IS WOULD.
THE.
I AM MAKING AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BY MEMBER ACOSTA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ROUTE TO
CHICO RATS WHICH YOU KNOW ACOSTA
AYE AYE.
SO I CHAU.
CHAU NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO MELENDEZ.
LENDERS AYE RADIUS.
VARIOUS NO STONE.
STONE NO.
THANK YOU
YEAH.
THERE WE GO.
MR CHOW.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE YOU CAN START WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ON AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FIVE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
ARB BASED ON BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE AND INFORMATION.
TO QUANTIFY AND REPORT IN A
STEEP GXT INVENTORY THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF GHG EMISSIONS.
RESULTING FROM THE LOSS OR
RELEASE OF UNCOMPRESSED IT THEIR
NATURAL GAS TO THE ATMOSPHERE
AND EMISSIONS FROM NATURAL GAS
FLARES DURING ALL PROCESSES.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PRODUCTION
PROCESSING AND TRANSPORTATION OF
NATURAL GAS THAT IS IMPORTED
INTO THE STATE FROM OUT OF STATE
SOURCES.
CALIFORNIA IMPORTED POSSIBLY
NINETY PERCENT OF OUR NATURAL
GAS USED IN THE STATE.
THE GAS IS USED TO HEAT HOMES
AND BUSINESSES GENERATE
ELECTRICITY AND POWER VEHICLES
HOWEVER BEFORE THAT GAS REACHES
ITS END USER. A PERCENTAGE IS
LOST TO THE ATMOSPHERE THROUGH
LEAKAGE INVENTING AND FLARING
DURING PRODUCTION PROCESSING AND
TRANSPORTATION.
MY THING THE PRIMARY COMPONENT
OF NATURAL GAS IS EIGHTY FOUR
TIMES MORE POTENT THAN CARBON
DIOXIDE. AT TRAPPING HEAT OVER
THE COURSE OF ITS FIRST TWENTY
YEARS IN THE ATMOSPHERE LEADING
TO SERIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
IF A LARGE AMOUNT OF GAS IS LOST
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
CURRENTLY A RB ONLY CALCULATES
IN STATE NATURAL GAS COMBUSTION
AND LEAKAGE EVEN THOUGH IN STATE
USES RESPONSIBLE FOR
SIGNIFICANT.
A POLLUTION OUTSIDE STATE.
ACCORDINGLY MILLIONS OF TONS OF
GX SHE POLLUTION GO AND
ACCOUNTED. FOR EVERY YEAR. AS A
RESULT THE TRUE ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL GAS USE IS HIDDEN FROM
THE STATE'S INVENTORY CONSUMERS
AND POLICY MAKERS.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE WILL HELP THE STATE MORE
ACCURATELY CAO EMISSIONS SO THE
PUBLIC AND POLICYMAKERS CAN
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND. THE SIZE AND
THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM OF
LEAKY HL RELATED TO THE USE OF
NATURAL GAS IN OUR STATE.
AND ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
ACCURATE EVALUATION OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE STATE'S NATURAL
GAS UP POLICIES.
OUR I HAVE ONE WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
MISTER MARK GUYS WOULD YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF PLACE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
SPONSORED AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO GET BETTER
ACCOUNTING OF THE NATURAL GAS
IMPACTS. FROM THE IMPORTS OF
NATURAL GAS INTO CALIFORNIA.
PRIMARY COMPONENT OF NATURAL GAS
IS METHANE A POTENT GREENHOUSE
GAS.
DO THIS POTENCY OF JUST A SMALL
PERCENTAGES LAS THE ATMOSPHERE.
OUT BEFORE IT REACHES OUR
CALIFORNIA'S BORDER CLIMATE
CHANGE BENEFIT USE OF THE USE OF
NATURAL GAS CAN BE GREATLY
UNDERMINED.
I CURRENTLY A ARE BE IN ITS
INVENTORY ACCOUNTS FOR NOW AFTER
OUR FOR.
GHG EMISSIONS FROM OTHER AREAS
SUCH AS.
INTERNATIONAL AVIATION AND FOR
OTHER.
IMPORTED
I RESOURCES.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE FEEL THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO MOVE FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SPORT.
KYLE JOHNSON CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THINK.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ABOUT
OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
AUTHOR.
IT'S LATE MAYBE TROVATORE. YOUR
LUCKY DAY.
YOU OUT WITH.
YOU HAVE A MOTION SECOND DO WE
GET THAT ALREADY I'M SORRY AGAIN
MOTION A SECOND POLITICS IT'S
LIKE.
.
WHICH CHAO DO YOU OUT ONE CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ALGO
PLEASE VERY LUCKY GIVEAWAY
MOTION A SECOND.
WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
I AM FIVE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE BY MEMBER CHAO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MERIT
TO CHEAT ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO CHILD TIE CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA FLORA NO LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I.
IT'S TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BILL'S UP THANK YOU.
STONE
I BELIEVE YOU'RE UP NEXT.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
LOVELY THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE
IT IS VERY MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS.
AMENDING THE STATUE FOR THE
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY.
FOR SOME KEY CHANGES TO.
PUT IN THE STATUTE THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER EFFECTUATE THAT PROGRAM
ENSURE THAT FUNDING GOES OUT
REASONABLY. UPDATING THE
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON
REQUIREMENTS.
AND UPDATING WITH IN THE
STATUTE.
WHAT THE TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
ARE BECAUSE CURRENTLY IT'S ONLY
THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
TRIBES ACROSS CALIFORNIA OR
INCLUDED IN THE GRANTS BECAUSE
OF ALL THE GREAT WORK? THAT THEY
DO AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
ANOTHER.
THANK YOU ANYONE IS A SPORT
SHIRT MANUSCRIPTS MEARNS WITH
THIS YEAR BUSINESS COUNCIL OUR
SPONSORING THIS MEASURE TODAY.
THIS WILL BE BRIEF BUT THIS
BILL WILL ACQUIT THIS YEAR ABOUT
A CONSERVANCY WITH THE TOOLS IT
NEEDS TO INCREASE THE PACE AND
SCALE FOREST AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION THIS HERE ABOUT IQ.
AND AND FOR THE RECORD THIS HAS
A SPORTS REPORT ON IT QUESTION I
DO ALSO WANT THAT I'M TAKING THE
AMENDMENT IS LISTED IN THAT. IT
DOES MY NEXT QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENCE RECORD FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT.
AND ALSO SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
THEY'LL ONE HOME.
I COULD REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE.
A SCENE NO.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
DID HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
I AM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY NINE BY MEMBER STONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS BROUGHT TUCCI
ACOSTA HIGH ACOSTA AYE CHAU CHOW
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN IS
AYE RADIUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU UP THERE GOES THE
BILL'S OUT OBVIOUSLY THINK YOU.
AND.
BUT IN THE CALL AND.
WEIRD.
IT WAS NOT YOU KNOW WAITING.
I STILL HAVE ONE MORE BILL ONE
WE DID LET THE CALL IN THE
CEMENT ON SWELL WERE. READY SO.
LET'S ROCK AND ROLL GO AHEAD.
YEAH.
SO THIS IS ITEM ONE AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY CALDERON. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CHAIR THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TO
THREE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON.
ITEM ONE.
LOW MOAN I.
PREVIOUS.
VARIOUS AYE.
SEVEN THREE.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT SOLACE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE FOR TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA. ACOSTA AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN. LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE STONE.
SO NINE TEN ZERO.
ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY LEVINE. DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
LAW AS FIVE TO THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS LOW MOAN.
LOW MOAN AYE FREYA'S.
ITEM NINETEEN. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SIX BRASS I.
SEVEN THREE.
ITEM THIRTY TWO A. B. THREE ZERO
TWO SEVEN CHVEZ.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT GOAL IS.
THREE TO THREE THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON.
LOW MOAN NO.
THREE TO FOUR.
ITEM.
FULFILL TOTALLY EVERY
CONSIDERATION.
WE I REQUEST FOR RECONSIDERATION
ON THE RECONSIDERATION.
ONE.
TEN.
IT'S GRANTED OKAY SECTION WAS
ASSURE HIGH ADDRESS.
BUT NO INJECTION OKAY.
SO RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
NOW WE HAVE ITEM THIRTY FOUR A.
B. THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX HOLDEN
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE THREE TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA NO ACOSTA KNOWS
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE.
STONE I SEVEN THREE.
NOW WE HAVE ITEM THIRTY FIVE.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
RUBIO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE AS FIVE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE. FLORA.
LARA I LIMON. LOW MOAN AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LINDA'S I TEND ZERO.
THIS WILL NOT LET THAT.
THAT'S IT FOR THE ON CALL THIS
YEAR.
.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU I'VE. LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE REYES
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I TEND ZERO.
.
SO.
LOW'S
OKAY ITEM ONE.
THAT BILL WAS OUT ON SEVEN TO
THREE.
ANYONE CHANGING VOTES.
ON A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR.
ITEM ONE CALDERON.
IT GOT OUT ON THE SEVENTY THREE
VOTES ANYBODY CHANGING.
NO CHANGES.
I DON'T TO A. BE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EDUARDO GARCIA.
THAT OUT ON SEVEN THREE.
YOU.
BEFORE GOING FURTHER I'VE LIKE
TO ANNOUNCE A ON THE.
A MICROPHONE THAT TO.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY ONE BY MR
LOW.
MISTER LOWE HAS PULLED THAT
ITEM AND SO WE WILL NOT BE
HEARING THAT TODAY.
.
IF YOU GO THROUGH.
EACH VOTE TO CUT JUST CALL OUT
THOSE THAT MAY HAVENOT HAVE
VOTED. BECAUSE WE PROBABLY DON'T
KNOW WHICH WHO HAS NOT VOTED. WE
KINDA DID THAT RIGHT BEFORE YOU
GOT BATTLE ARE A LETTER TO THE
CALL.
WE CAN GLENN OKAY SKIP THE BILLS
THAT HAVE TEN VOTES IF BUT IF
YOU ARE BOTH CHANGES PSYCHO.
WILL CHANGE.
YEAH SO WHEN I GO TO THE BEACH
BILL TELL ME IF THERE'S ABOUT A
CHANGE IN A LITTLE.
FOR THE RECORD I'M A LITTLE
CURIOUS AS TO WHY WE'RE GOING
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE BILL ASKING
IF THERE'S A VOTE CHANGE WHEN
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT
AT ARMS ARE BOTH CHANGES ARE
REASON WE'RE DOING THAT.
WELL I JUST SECURE ADAM WE DON'T
DO THAT YET I THINK IT HAS IT
HAS ABOUT THE SENATE SO JUST
ONLY GO TO THE ONES THAT CAN AND
HONORED TO VOTE CHANGE.
A TEST DRIVE AND SO WHAT WAS
JUST CALLED THE.
I'LL JUST SAY THE ITEM INTO A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY. ANY
CHANGES.
SIR WITH ALL RESPECT.
THE SAME THING
OKAY Y. WHAT DO YOU PROPOSE MY
SUGGESTION WOULD BE.
JUST LIKE RECALL ROLL ARE WITH
CHAIR VICE CHAIR GO RIGHT DOWN
TO THE END OF A VERY.
OR ALLEN SOME ANIMAL. THAT'S WE
SEEM TO DO NOTHING BUT I THOUGHT
I COULD BE WRONG SO HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHETHER.
THEY VOTED ARE NOT EXACTLY
THAT'S WE JUST SIT HERE.
ALL THAT.
SO I THOUGHT YOU WITH YOUR.
I KNOW YOU MISSED VOTES
SO WE HAVE A WE HAVE A PROCEDURE
IN MY BIO IF WE GET GOING IT'LL
BE DONE SOON.
OKAY.
I DON'T TO AB NINETEEN SEVENTY.
GOT OUT ON A SEVEN THREE VOTE.
ANY CHANGES.
THERE'S NO ABSENT MEMBERS.
YEAH IF YOU CAN JUST ASK WHO WHO
IS MISSING ON THE. ON THE VOTE
IF
IF THERE'S NO ONE MISSING THEN
WE CAN GO TO THE NORTH COAST ON
ITEM TO A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
THERE IS NOBODY MISSING IT WAS
FIVE SEVEN THREE.
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE. NO ONE MISSING GOT OUT ON
TEN ZERO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GOT OUT TEN ZERO.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FIVE.
CURRENT VOTERS SIX TO TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS MERRITT TO CHEAT
AYE WHERE TO GI.
AND MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SNOW.
SEVEN THREE.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT.
.
SEVEN TWO.
ANY CHANGES.
IT.
MERIT SURGERY WAS NOT LOADING
WHICH.
THIS AS ITEM SIX AB TWENTY TWO
OH A.
WE'RE GOOD. EVERYONE'S A.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN.
GOT OUT ON TEN ZERO VOTE.
THE GOOD.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY TO SIXTY
SEVEN.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO WHAT THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
SHALL I MELINDA'S MELINDA'S AYE
TEN ZERO.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. GOT OUT ON A TEN
ZERO VOTE.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY.
CURB OUT NINE ZERO WHAT CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
LARA.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY.
ABSENT MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA AYE TEN ZERO.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
ELEVEN GOT OUT ON A TEN ZERO
VOTES.
ITEM THIRTEEN. CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD.
SHALL I TEN ZERO.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY THREE GOT OUT ON TEN
ZERO.
I DON'T FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY ONE CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
ABSENT MEMBER MELENDEZ. MULLIN
IS FIVE TEN ZERO.
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE.
THREE TO SIX.
WHICH SHALL NOT VOTING.
ANY CHANGES.
OKAY ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
GOT OUT ON SEVEN THREE.
MAY BE.
I DON'T TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
GOT OUT ON EIGHT TO ONE WITH
FLORA NOT VOTING.
OKAY VOTE CHANGE ACOSTA FROM
NO TO.
FROM NO TO AYE.
SO THE VOTE IS NINE TO ONE.
I DON'T TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY TO GOT OUT ON A TEN
ZERO VOTES.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY NINE THE CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI TIME. REFUGEE AYE TEN
ZERO.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE.
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA.
FLORA I. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STONE. AYE STONE
AYE.
TEN ZERO.
FEDERAL TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU
AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON I.
TEN ZERO.
I DON'T TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY THREE.
GOT OUT ON SEVEN TO THREE VOTE.
ANY CHANGES.
SEVEN THREE WAS THE VOTE.
JORDAN.
ITEM THIRTY A. B. THIRTY FIFTEEN
CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT TWO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA.
FLORA AYE TEN ZERO.
ITEM THIRTY TWO AB THREE ZERO
TWO SEVEN.
CURRENT BEAU IS THREE TO FOUR.
WITH.
CHAO NOT VOTING EGGMAN NOT
VOTING ANDREAS NOT VOTING FOR.
AND THEN WE DID RECONSIDERATION
UNANIMOUS.
AB THIRTY THREE.
I MEAN ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY.
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE
TRAVELING I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
SHALL I LIMON.
I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO. VARIOUS.
A ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
THIRTY.
REST NOT VOTING.
AND STONE IS I TO KNOW.
SIX TO TWO.
YOU WANT TO DO THAT OVER AGAIN.
LAMONT STAYED OFF RIGHT.
STONE CHANGED FROM I TO KNOW.
U. OMINOUS
SO NOW WE'RE ON ITEM THIRTY
FOUR A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX.
THAT GOT OUT ON SEVEN TO THREE.
ANY CHANGES.
ITEM THIRTY FIVE A. B. THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT OUT OUT TEN
ZERO.
ITEM THIRTY SIX A. B. THIRTY TWO
A ONE. CURRENT VOTE SIX TO FOUR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS TRIAL.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
THIS IS ITEM THIRTY SIX A. B.
THIRTY TWO A ONE.
EGGMAN AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ BELINDA'S AYE TEN ZERO.
ALRIGHT AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE URGENCY
BE ADAPTED CHEN ZERO.
I WAS OUT.
YEAH WE TO IRATE
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU SIR